foreign
hello everyone I hope you're doing good
and staying safe welcome to Simply
learns YouTube channel and in today's
session we'll be going through SQL for
data analysis full course SQL for data
analysis refers to the database querying
language use of relational databases as
well as its capacity to interface with
numerous databases simultaneously one of
the most popular and adaptable languages
SQL combines an easy learning curve with
a depth that enables users to construct
sophisticated tools and dashboards for
data analytics to get more insights data
analysts can interact with data stored
in relational databases using the robust
programming language SQL for data
analysis many businesses have created
their own tools to swiftly retrieve data
from databases using SQL big data is
gathered and organized during the data
analysis process in order to extract
usable information that can be used to
make important business choices
technology has made it possible for data
analysis to find important factors and
predict pattern and Trends which boosts
business productivity additionally it
adds value to corporate operations
because it makes it easier to understand
the significance of data by providing a
thorough analysis now SQL analytics can
be used with languages like python using
its libraries numpy Scala and Hadoop
which are the three of the most popular
currently in the use for data science
along with big data management and
manipulation however SQL is still widely
used because it is a straightforward
language capable of executing
surprisingly complex data analysis so in
today's session we'll be going through
an exploratory data analysis with a
real-time data sets using SQL more on
that soon but before we get started if
you're new to the channel and haven't
subscribed subscribe to our Channel
simply learn and stay updated with all
the latest Technologies and hit that
Bell icon to level miss an update from
us so without any further Ado let's get
started
firstly let us discuss the agenda for
today's session we'll start the tutorial
with a quick introduction to data
analytics and then we'll understand what
is SQL and after that we'll see why SQL
is needed for data science and then
we'll cover basics of SQL after that
we'll be going through joints in SQL
after that we'll be covering some
important aspects of SQL like functions
views and procedure and then we'll jump
into advanced SQL Concepts where we'll
understand some window function CTS
Etc and finally we'll perform Hands-On
exploratory data analysis using SQL with
a real data time sets
so let us now jump into straight into
today's topic
what is a database data in today's world
plays a vital role in our everyday lives
be it your work related data in your
laptop your bank account details or even
your Gmail password so it's necessary to
store this data safely and in an
organized way that's where database
comes into picture which holds and
manages the data
a database can be defined as a
collection of information or processed
data that can be stored and accessed
whenever needed for example we can use a
database to store the complete details
of an employee working in an
organization
the primary goal of a database is to
store and retrieve information
efficiently
popular databases some popular open
source and commercially available
databases are MySQL Oracle database
Microsoft SQL server mongodb and post
clear SQL
why we need a database now that we have
understood what a databases let's
understand the use of database and the
need for it
database came into existence in the
early 1970s but all the data was stored
in computer files before that as the
technology kept advancing it became
difficult for computers to handle when
the number of files increased and the
volume of data grew
the so-called traditional file system
was no longer able to store and retrieve
data efficiently
let us now see some of the limitations
and drawbacks caused by traditional file
system
data redundancy and inconsistency
redundancy means when the same data is
getting duplicated and repeated in
different locations this leads to access
and unwanted storage which eventually
results in inconsistency where the data
in separate files do not match with each
other
data isolation data is isolated because
it is scattered in various files in
different locations and the files may be
in different formats as well at any
point writing your application programs
to retrieve the appropriate data becomes
difficult as the files are separated
from each other
limited data access file storage systems
usually do not have access for multiple
users this means multiple users at
different places cannot access the data
simultaneously
it becomes difficult to access important
data if multiple users are searching at
the same time
security and integrity issues data
stored in files can easily be accessed
and tampered so it's essential to
prevent unauthorized users access to
hold the data's integrity
in order to eliminate all these
drawbacks we use a database that is
controlled by a database management
system
let us now look at the history of SQL
SQL was developed by IBM in the year
1970. Dr Cod boys and Donald Chamberlain
proposed a paper on usage of relational
database management they came up with
SQL which can be used to perform
operations on data stored in the
databases
SQL was made publicly available and was
accepted for the use of relational
database in the year 1974.
initially the language was known as
Structured English query language
pronounced as sequel which was later
changed into SQL in the year 1978.
The American National Standard Institute
ANSI and other International
organizations have standardized SQL as a
language for database communication in
the year 1986.
though companies use a different version
of SQL nowadays the latest version of it
was released in 2019 by Microsoft
what is SQL SQL is defined as a
structure query languages
it allows the user to manage and
manipulate the database
so you might have got a doubt in your
head that you have discussed databases
earlier and why we are discussing SQL
now well you got it right both database
and SQL are interconnected to each other
SQL allows you to perform operations
like insert update modify and delete in
the database
in a nutshell SQL is used to communicate
with the database systems to retrieve
the information
features of SQL
SQL is one of the most demanding skills
nowadays with the ever increasing amount
of data SQL serves as a powerful tool to
provide insights to businesses while
handling databases
SQL is used to define the overall schema
that is the complete structure of the
database by managing and manipulating
the data accordingly and determining
information whenever required by the
user
SQL also allows flexibility as it uses
simple English words in its queries like
create delete
Etc
SQL can handle large amounts of Records
stored in databases with utmost
efficiency
let us now see how SQL Works a typical
SQL database engine includes a storage
engine which is a database server and a
query processor within the SQL engine
to understand simply let us take an
example
suppose Jon is an HR Manager working in
an organization he wants the information
of all the employees who have joined
last year
John writes an SQL query in his laptop
to retrieve the data in order to execute
the query it must interact with
relational database management system
within the database server
and the request should be a valid query
before the SQL engine can process it the
SQL engine then writes to and retrieves
data from the database server
both database server and SQL engine work
hand in hand together to process the
required data the system process the SQL
request and sends it to web server
to access the information via SQL
database and if the information is found
in the tables the database server sends
the information back to the user
in this way John can retrieve the
information from the database using SQL
types of SQL commands SQL commands give
instructions to database to perform
specific actions to retrieve the data
SQL commands are broadly classified into
four types the first one is data
definition language or ddl ddl allows
the user to define the table and change
its overall structure
commands that are used in ddlr create it
is used to create a new table
alter it is used to modify the existing
table by adding unique attributes drop
it is used to delete the whole table and
the data stored in it truncate it is
used to delete the rows in a table
the next one is data manipulation
language or DML DML is used to access
and manipulate data in tables commands
that are used in dmlr select it is used
to extract data from the tables update
it is used to update a value in the
existing table delete unlike the drop
command the delete command is used to
delete a specific Row in the table
insert it is used to insert a new value
into the table
the next one is data control language or
DCL DCL is responsible for maintaining
the security which gives control access
and permissions to the database commands
that come under dclr Grant it is used to
Grant permission to user to access the
database revoked it is used to cancel or
take back the earlier granted permission
the last one is transaction control
language or TCL
TCL has three commands namely commit it
is used to permanently save the
transaction
roll back it is used to restore the
transaction that is not saved
save point it is used to hold a
transaction temporarily it can be rolled
back to its previous state at any point
let us now look at some of the
advantages of SQL
one of the main advantage of SQL is that
it provides access to data stored in
database with its high speed and fast
acquity processing quickly and
efficiently
SQL is open source that means it is
publicly available and can be accessed
from the internet it is also
straightforward to implement as well
SQL also provides the user to have
multiple views of their content stored
in the database
SQL is efficient in retrieving vast
amount of data using simple queries
and also it is portable as well which
means you can perform all these
operations at your home or your
workplace through your laptops and PCs
disadvantages of SQL there are two sites
to every coin and similarly SQL also has
few advantages which are not that
significant
initially one may find it challenging to
work with SQL due to its complex
interface
since it's a platform-based languages
most of the commercially available SQL
servers costs are relatively higher
SQL is constantly working on this
massive amounts of data stored in the
databases and hence maintenance costs
are also high as well
let us now look at some of the
applications in real life of SQL SQL is
widely used in various sectors nowadays
some of them are education schools and
universities use SQL and databases to
store and retrieve information about
their students
faculty and staff
health care hospitals and other medical
centers use SQL to store the details of
the patients without any hassle it also
helps in maintaining all the documents
and bills as well
retail and e-commerce with its vast
presence in the market retail and
e-commerce companies store their
customers data to improve their shopping
experiences by providing special offers
which will in turn help their businesses
to grow
is one of the significant components of
backing sector as well bang store the
account details of customers and the
transactions done on day-to-day basis in
the database
Finance Finance is another massive area
where SQL queries are used regularly in
managing the assets Revenue details
shares of the companies Etc faster
execution and retrieval of data are key
for all the businesses to make
strategies and derive insights from it
companies using SQL
SQL is used extensively every day by
some big Tech gen companies like Google
Microsoft Oracle Amazon
Facebook
Etc even small companies and startups
heavily rely on SQL to make better
decisions and provide Solutions and
service to customers
with that we have come to the end of the
session on introduction to SQL by now
you must have got some idea of what SQL
is over the years SQL has evolved and is
widely used nowadays worldwide it is one
of the most efficient database languages
out there it can perform various
operations on the database to retrieve
the data instantly
SQL is very simple to understand and
easy to learn as well as all the
commands and queries are written using
English words
unlike other programming languages SQL
requires almost no coding it does not
require thousands of lines of code the
syntax is also user friendly and easy to
implement
so what is dbms dbms comprises of two
words the first one is database database
can be defined as a collection of data
that is organized as well as structured
on the other hand we have Management
Systems which directly interact with the
database to access the data
in a nutshell dbms is a software to
store and retrieve database information
efficiently and conveniently some
popular dbms softwares used by various
organizations are MySQL Oracle database
postgrew SQL
Etc
why we need dbms
dbms have come into existence in 1960s
and since then it had the edge over
traditional file system which had
certain anomalies and drawbacks like
data redundancy inconsistency privacy
and security issues and various other
factors
dbms manages the information stored in
databases effectively and effective
management of data is key to
organizations as it ensures the data is
available to the users whenever and
wherever needed data volumes continue to
grow exponentially and dbms are designed
to manage large volumes of database
efficiently
components of dbms dbms can be divided
into five major components the first one
is data perhaps the most important
component of dbms certainly from the end
user point of view in the data because
the primary reason behind introducing
dbms is to store and maintain the data
within the database data acts as a
bridge between machine components like
Hardware software and human components
like applications
the next one is Hardware
the DPMS requires Hardware to run
Hardware refers to the external parts of
the computer system which includes
storage devices like hard disk and other
input output devices it is used in
managing and accessing the database
software another important component of
dbms is the software which controls
everything and provides us with the
interface to store and access the data
the software component comprises the
dbms software itself and the application
programs to execute on the database
user access user access or database
access allows the user to access the
data to and from the database by writing
commands SQL is widely used as a
database access language to perform
operations like creating new tables
inserting and deleting values and
perform updations that is on the data
that is stored in the databases
procedures procedure refers to the
instructions and rules to use the dbms
the user who is managing the database
requires documented procedures on how to
run the database this includes
understanding the design and structure
of the database system setup and log
into the databases Etc
dbms architecture
database Management Systems architecture
will help us understand the components
of the database systems and the relation
among them the data is usually complex
in nature and developers generally hide
unwanted or irrelevant information from
the user this is called as data
abstraction which reduces the internal
complexity to make the system more
efficient
the database architecture has mainly
three levels and hence it is also called
as the three level architecture as well
the first one is physical schema it is
the lowest level of database
architecture it is also called the
internal level of the database schema
internal level is the physical
representation of the database that
means it describes how the data is
stored in the database
logical schema it is also called the
conceptual or logical level and it is at
a higher level than the physical level
this level basically represents the
community view of the database and
describes what data is stored within the
database and the relationship among the
data
external schema this is the highest
level in the three level architecture
and closest to the user it is also known
as The View level the external level
only shows the relevant database content
to the users in the form of view and
hides the rest of the data there may be
a number of external views for database
for different users
types of dbms architecture
there are three different types of dbms
architecture the first one is single or
one tire architecture
two-tier architecture and finally three
type architecture
Singletary architecture and dbms is the
simplest architecture of database in
this architecture the database is
directly available to the user the user
can directly access and use the database
for example let's imagine you want to
get all the employee records from the
database for that you can directly
communicate with the database from your
computer itself this is why this
architecture is also known as local
database system
two-tier architecture in two-time
architecture the database system is
located on the server machine and the
dbms application is present on the
client level
these two are linked via a reliable
Network the two Tire dbms architecture
is used when we wish to access the dbms
with the help of an application
threeter architecture this is an
extension to two-tier architecture and
also the most widely used dbms
architecture it is similar to this two
type architecture only but there is
another separate layer known as
application server between the database
server and the client
in this architecture the client
application doesn't communicate directly
with the database system present at the
server machine instead this client
application communicates the
communicates with the server application
and then internally communicates with
the database system present at the
server
data models and dbms
data model defines how data is connected
to each other and how they are processed
and stored inside the system it also
defines the logical structure and design
of data in dbms
data models are broadly classified into
four types the first one is hierarchical
model it was one of the first dbms
models ever used in this model data is
organized in tree-like structure and
connected to each other by Links
the next one is Network model it is an
extension to hierarchical model it can
represent complex data relationships
using graph like structure where the
data can have many to many relationships
the next one is entity relationship
model in this model we represent real
life entities in a pictorial form using
different shapes
finally relational model it is one of
the most commonly used models it
represents the data in the form of
tables
what is rdbms let us now discuss one of
the most popular data models in dbms
which is rdbms
rdbms starts for relational database
management system all the modern dbms
like MySQL Oracle Microsoft SQL Server
are based on rdmms only
rdbms stores the data in the form of
tables which is basically a collection
of related data this data is organized
in the form of rows and columns
the data that is placed horizontally in
table is known as the row and the
vertical arrangement of data is known as
columns
field
every table is broken up into smaller
entities called Fields fields in the
employee table are employee ID employee
name job department number and salary
rdbms versus dbms let us now understand
the difference between rdbms and dbms
though both of them are used to store
physical data in the databases there are
some difference between them as well
rddms stores data in tabular form
whereas dbms.data in individual files
for an application like XML or Json
format Etc
rdbms deals with vast amount of data
whereas dbms is designed to handle small
amounts of data and is meant for small
organizations
rdbms can support multiple users on the
other hand dbms is limited to a single
user
rdbms also supports distributed
databases wherein you can manage and
have the access for multiple databases
at the same time whereas dbms do not
offer the support for distributed
databases
these are some differences between rdbms
and dbms
types of keys and dbms
Keys play an important role in
relational databases that used to
establish a relationship between the
tables it is used to fetch information
from one or more rows in a table
in dbms there are several Keys which are
almost interrelated to each other but we
look at some important and most used
case in rdbms the first one is primary
key it is one of the main key that
uniquely identifies every row in a table
Super Key Super Key contains additional
or other sets of attributes that can
uniquely identify a row within the table
candidate key candidate key are selected
from the set of super Keys the only
difference is it shouldn't have repeated
attributes hence it is also called as
minimal Super Key
foreign key it is used to create a
relationship between two tables with the
help of an already existing table
basically it acts as a cross reference
between two tables
let us understand this keys with an
example
let us consider a table called employee
which has different fields like employee
ID employee name job role department
number pan number other number
Universal identification number which is
uan
now for the employee table we can take
employee ID column as a primary key
because it uniquely identifies each
record in the table
the Super Key can be pan number other
number or even un because two employees
can have the same name and by definition
a Super Key is a set of different
attributes which can uniquely identify
the table and hence uh different
employees have different pan number
other number and un as well
candidate key can be taken from either
of these three super Keys which we have
taken earlier except for the primary key
employee ID other attributes can be
candidate keys so I have taken un as the
candidate key for this table now each
employee Works in various departments
and we cannot store the department name
in the employee table that's why
building the already existing table that
is the employee table with a new table
by taking the department ID as primary
key and creating new attribute named
Department name
so in this case Department ID is
considered as foreign key
advantages of dbms one of the main
advantages of dbms is it controls data
redundancy redundancy means storing the
same data multiple times by having
centralized database system unnecessary
duplication of data is avoided
data Integrity integrity means the data
in the database is accurate and
consistent dbms ensures that the data is
correct and consistent for all the users
as it handles multiple databases at the
same time
data privacy and security
data privacy is Paramount for every user
and dbms allows only authorized users to
access the data from the database hence
dbms provides improved data security
under any circumstance
data consistency
data inconsistency occurs when a CM
files are located in different locations
but with dbms they can achieve increased
data in data consistency because any
changes in the database are immediately
reflected to the user
ease of sharing data dbms allows the
user to share the data in any number of
application programs users can also have
access to the database simultaneously
and share the data between themselves
backup and Recovery dbms take care of
recovery and backup on its own users are
not required to take regular backups
because the dbms does it for them it
also restores the database after a
system failure or crash to prevent it
from reverting to its original state
disadvantages of dbms
well to store a huge amount of data one
needs a huge amount of space as well
eventually it requires additional
hardware and software which are
relatively of higher cost and because of
its constant functionality the
maintenance costs are also high as well
complexity dbms is an extremely complex
software initially one may find it
difficult to operate different functions
on dbms because of its complexity end
users must have proper knowledge while
handling database systems otherwise it
may result in database failure
Speed and Performance issues dbms is
made to handle extremely huge data and
queries and if the resources become
Limited at any point and optimization is
not done properly the database will
become slow and it reduces the
performance of the whole system
increased vulnerability dbms system
works on a centralized system
that means all the users from all over
the world have access to this database
hence any failure of this dbms will
impact all the users so there is a high
chance of losing the data so these were
some of the disadvantages of dbms
finally let us look at some of the
applications of dbms dbms is widely used
in various Fields nowadays some of them
are
banking dbms is used in a banking sector
to store the customer information
Account Details and all the transactions
done on a daily basis
additionally to keep track of the loan
amounts account balance sheets ATM and
deposit records Etc are maintained with
the help of database
education
schools and universities manage their
students information like personal
details course details exam maths grades
Etc all this information is stored in
databases and is managed by dbms
Finance the database management system
is used by companies and corporations to
store information about Revenue sales
Holdings and purchases of financial
instruments such as stocks and bonds and
it also stores real-time Market data to
enable online trading
Healthcare hospitals and medical centers
use dbms to store the details of the
patients and assist them with their
diagnosis and treatment procedures it
also helps in maintaining patient
medical record history documents
previous bills Etc
Manufacturing manufacturing companies
make products and sell them on a daily
basis to manage the supply chain and
track the production of items in
factories and warehouses maintain
records of all details of the product
like number of orders purchases Bill
amounts Etc we use dbms
travel
dbms is used by Railways and Airlines to
store the booking information of
passengers departure and arrival timings
and finally e-commerce online shopping
is the new normal for everyone nowadays
e-commerce platforms store and access
details of customers purchase
information payments and addresses Etc
in the database using dbms
firstly go to Google and type MySQL
you'll find MySQL official website page
on the search result click on that
once you reach the official website page
you'll find download section click on
that
now scroll down a bit and you'll find
MySQL Community GPL downloads click on
that link
now you'll find various options for
download such as various repositories
MySQL shell MySQL workbench Etc but
since we are installing it for the first
time on our Windows system and we are
only concerned with the MySQL workbench
and shell I will go with mySQL installer
for Windows click on that link
now you'll find two options for download
uh the first one is Windows 86 32-bit
MSI installer it is showing here 32-bit
but it will work for a 62-bit systems as
well so don't worry and you can choose
either of the two and I'm going with the
first one click on download
I will find this page where you will
have login and sign up uh for the Oracle
account for time being just ignore that
and click on no thanks to start my
download
save it on your system
once it's downloaded uh open the file
give all the necessary permissions
now you will find a setup page where
you'll have different options such as
developer server client full and custom
I will choose custom because we want
MySQL workbench and MySQL shell so click
on next
now you have to select the products
which we want to install in our system
uh you can find MySQL server click on
that and expand it you'll find MySQL
server 8.0 click on that you'll find the
latest version of it click on that and
select the arrow and send it to the
other side now scroll down a bit and
you'll find applications click on that
you can see MySQL workbench
expand it and you'll find the latest
version of it as well click on that and
click on the adder and send it to the
other side scroll down a bit and you'll
find MySQL shell as well click on that
expand it select the latest version
click the arrow and send it to the other
side now we are good to go and uh click
on next
now it will ask for the path where you
want to install all these files we are
saving this on our C drive
just check all the necessary paths and
click on next
now all the three products are ready to
download click on execute
again uh now depending upon your
internet speed this may take a while so
don't worry just sit back and wait for
it to get downloaded
you can see all the three are
successfully downloaded uh click on next
now we need to install all the three
products click on execute
so you can do the installation process
simultaneously with me or just take a
note of it and perform it later as well
on your PCS and laptop this might take a
while so we'll wait for it to get
installed
as you can see all the three of them are
successfully installed click on next
click on next again
I'll find the server configuration type
you'll find different port number and
protocol Port just leave as it is
because it is set by default by the
system click on next
I will have the authentication method
you'll be provided with two options I
will choose the recommended one which is
given by the system
click on next again
now we have to set a root password so by
the way guys the root is basically the a
default user which will have who will
have the access to all the files and
programs so enter a password of your own
choice
and make sure you take a note of it
because I will have to use it at a later
stage and also by logging into the MySQL
server you will use the same password
so click on check
so as you can see there's a blue tick
mark which means it's verified so you
can go ahead click on next
now I'll find the windows service which
is the standard system account
choose that and click next
now you have to apply all the
configuration for the system files for
that just click on execute
and the system will automatically
configure itself
so this might take a while so we'll wait
for it to complete
as you can see the all the files are
successfully configured click on finish
click on next
so once you click on finish uh MySQL
workbench and MySQL will automatically
launch
so workbench and shella started in the
background uh as you can see there's a
local instant mysql80 click on that
now it will ask you to enter the
password which you've set earlier click
on that
so that's it guys we have successfully
installed MySQL workbench on our system
but before you get started there's
another little process that will with
that we are left behind with uh now you
have to connect all the files and
packages to the server before you start
working on the tables so for that we
need to locate where the where the MySQL
files are stored for that we'll go to
file manager
since we have saved the files on local
disk D local disk C uh click on C drive
go to program files
click on MySQL
open MySQL server 8.2
click on bin now these are all the files
and packages that you have to connect to
the server for that double click on
location path
copy the whole address
and open command prompt
on the command prompt you'll have to
type CD that is the current directory
and paste the address that you have
copied earlier and click enter
now type MySQL space my U root
minus P here minus U is the user which
is the root user which you have taken
minus p is the password click on enter
now it will ask you to enter the
password that you have set earlier type
the same
so if you find what you are seeing in my
system that is Oracle is registered
trademarkov Oracle Corporation and all
this thing that means you have
successfully downloaded and installed
all the files and packages into the
MySQL server and you are good to go and
start working on your tables right away
what is SQL syntax
just like other programming languages
SQL follows a unique set of rules and
guidelines called syntax we use Simple
English words in SQL syntax in order to
execute various queries
SQL syntax is by default case
insensitive that means the system allows
the user to write the queries in both
uppercase as well as lowercase but if
you are working with mySQL server then
you need to give table names exactly as
they exist in the database
we know that rdbms is the basis for all
modern database systems including SQL
which manages and performs various
operations on the tables like insert
update modify and delete so in order to
retrieve the data stored in the database
it is necessary to learn SQL syntax
first
before we move ahead with the topic if
you want to learn more about the basics
of dbms and SQL make sure you check out
our previous playlist videos on
introduction to dbms and SQL on our
Channel we'll leave the link in the
description below
SQL Expressions SQL expression is a
combination of one or more keywords and
values operators data types and other
SQL functions these SQL expressions are
like a formula which are similar to
mathematical formulas which we generally
use to solve a problem and in this case
the written in a query language using a
proper syntax
SQL statement SQL statements are
basically collection of SQL expressions
for example let us consider an employee
table to understand it in a better way
the table is having attributes like
employee ID name age City and salary
now if I want to fetch the record of all
the employees and their IDs I'll write a
simple SQL query
that is Select ID comma name from
employee here select is the database
object or the keyword that is used ID
and name are the columns from employee
employee is the name of the table when I
execute this query this will be the
output it will display the ID and name
of the employee
let us look at another query now I want
to display uh the salary of employees
having uh more than 30 000. for that I
am using the query as select ID name
from employee where salary is greater
than 30 000. here where is the
conditional statement that I'm using or
it is a SQL clause also we are using
greater than symbol which is an SQL
operator
so with the help of Escape statements we
can fetch uh the records of all the
information from SQL tables
SQL data types SQL data type specifies
which type of values is stored in the
database tables SQL data types are
mainly classified into three categories
the first one is numeric numerical data
refers to the data that is in the form
of numbers a numerical data type we have
different types as well for example int
int holds values of integers and whole
numbers without any decimal point
further they are again divided into
small end and begin also the difference
between them is the size and range of
the value they can store and operate
bit bit data type is an integer data
type that can only take values of 0 1 or
any null value SQL optimizes storage of
bit columns if a table has eight or
fewer bit columns SQL stores them as one
byte if a table has 9 or up to 16 bit
columns SQL stores them as two bytes and
so on
float float stores the numbers having
decimal values depending upon the number
of digits after the decimal point SQL
gives the size accordingly in its range
Boolean it is used to specify Boolean
values that is true and false 0 is
considered as false and non-zero values
are considered as true
string data type string data types
allows us to store fixed or variable
character values they are again further
divided into various types the first one
is care
carries used to specify a fixed length
string that can contain numbers letters
and special characters its size can be 0
to 255 characters
is similar to care but it stores
variable lens strings and size of
wirecare is also more than the car data
type with a range of 0 to almost 60 000
characters so if you're storing strings
with a widely variable lens such as name
address email ID then we have to use a
wire care
text text data type stores any kind of
text Data it can hold string value that
can contain maximum length of 255
characters
date time in SQL date time data type is
used for storing values that can contain
both date as well as time
the first one is date it is used to
specify date format that is year month
date in this data type we can store only
the value of date
and the next one is date time it is used
to specify the combination of both date
and time the format is here
month date Hearts minutes and seconds
for instance I have taken the example as
2022
3 that is the month 20 is the date 23
hours 59 is the minutes and 59 is the
seconds
timestamp it is also similar to daytime
data type the format specification is
also the same as well the only
difference is it has less a range of
values to store it is also used to
convert current time into various time
zones like UTC GMT Etc
we also have XML and Json data types
which are not that significant and we do
not use as frequently as other data
types in SQL
SQL operators SQL operators are used to
specify certain conditions in an SQL
statement SQL operators are broadly
classified into five categories the
first one is arithmetic arithmetic
operators perform mathematical operation
on numerical data on the SQL tables
these operation performs addition
subtraction multiplication and division
operations on the numerical operands the
next one is logical The Logical
operators in SQL perform Boolean
operations which gives two results
either true or false these operators
provide True Value if both operands
match The Logical condition some logical
operators are and not are between
Etc
comparison the comparison operator is in
SQL Compares two different data
in the SQL tables and checks whether
they are same greater or lesser the SQL
comparison operator are used with a
conditional Clause where in the SQL
queries
equal to is highly used uh comparison
operator in SQL
bit wise bitwise operators perform bit
manipulations between two expressions of
any integer data type category bitwise
operators convert two integer values to
Binary bits and perform and or are not
operation on each bit which finally
gives the required result
final one is set the set operators in
SQL combine a similar type of data from
two or more SQL database tables
basically it merges the result which is
extracted from two or more SQL queries
into a single result SQL Union intersect
and minus operators are some of the
examples offset operations
foreign
s we know that SQL commands are broadly
classified into four types the first one
is data definition language ddl ddl
allows the user to define the table and
make changes to its overall structure
commands that are used in ddl are create
it is used to create a new table
alter it is used to modify the existing
table by adding new attributes drop it
is used to delete the whole table and
the data stored in it
truncate it is used to delete the rows
in a table
now that we have got the idea and
understanding of various operators data
types and commands let us look at the
syntax of all these commands
the first one is SQL create statement
perhaps one of the most important and
used SQL statement because if you want
to create a table you have to first name
the table and then specify the columns
and the columns data types
so let us look at the syntax of create
statements
the syntax is followed as a create table
which is the keyword that is used
followed by table name that you want to
create and within the parenthesis you
have to mention the column give space
and add the data type
so in this way you can add a number of
columns and mention the data types but
make sure guys you have to give the
appropriate data type for the columns
that you have taken because there might
be a chance there might be instance
where you have you have given the column
such as age and you are mentioning data
type as character care which is
basically a mismatch the computer
doesn't accept it because generally age
is basically a numerical value but you
are mentioning care but it should
ideally be int to store the data so just
keep an eye on it when you are creating
new tables so let us now look at an
example of create statement so I want to
create a table name employee for that I
am writing as create table space
employee and within the parenthesis I'm
mentioning employee ID as my first
column space int which is the data type
and I'm giving name worker address
worker close the parenthesis and put a
semicolon and if you execute this
statement this will be the following
result it will display uh the table with
different columns with the First Column
as employee ID the second column is name
and the third column as address
easy right
the next one is SQL alter table
the SQL order statement is basically is
used to add modify or even delete you
know certain columns from the existing
table let us look at the syntax of a
scale law order command
so the SQL alter command is altered
table space table name that you have to
mention
add and within the parenthesis you have
to mention the column and the data type
similarly you can add a number of data
types as per requirement
let us now look at one of the example
now I wanted to add the date of birth of
the employee in a new column for that
I'll write as alter table employee at
and within the parenthesis date of birth
and I'll mention the data type as well
which is the date and if you execute
this it will show the result like this
it will add another column date of birth
in already existing table
now due to certain reasons if you want
to drop or delete the date of birth
column for that we have to write syntax
as alter table give the employee
table name drop column which is the
keyword we use and date of birth so this
will be the final output when you
execute the query it will completely
drop the date of birth from the table
next we'll look at SQL drop statement
SQL drop statement basically removes all
the data and the changes the overall
structure of the table by deleting the
records in the table so let us look at
the syntax the syntax followed is a drop
table followed by the table name that we
want to create
let us look one of the example uh the
syntax followed is a drop table employee
and when I execute this it will show an
error stating that table employed does
not exist which means you have
completely deleted all the records from
the employee table
SQL truncate statement
let us look at the SQL truncate
statement syntax the syntax is truncate
table which is the keyword that is used
and we have to specify the table name
for example if you want to truncate the
values in employee table we have to
write truncate table employee so this
will be the output where it shows null
that is uh there are no values in the
employee table and you can further add
values of your own choice
foreign
let us now look at data manipulation
language data manipulation language or
DML
is used to access and manipulate data
tables commands that are used in DML are
insert it is used to insert new values
into the table
select it is used to extract data from
the tables
update it is used to update values in
the already existing table
delete unlike the drop command delete
command is used to delete a specific row
or all the rows on the table
let us first look at the SQL insert
statement
the syntax followed in SQL insert
statement is insert into which is the
keyword that we use
space table name that we have created
values and inside the parenthesis you
have to mention the values
there is also another method to insert
the values where we specify the column
name as well as the values
now if you execute this
so but before executing we'll take an
example uh we are creating a table
student and we are inserting uh values
such as roll number name age and City
so the roll number uh is given as one uh
the name is given as Rohan the age is
given as 22 and the city is given as
Hyderabad for the first row
similarly uh we'll do the same for the
next two rows as well and if you execute
this query this will be the final output
where you'll have four different uh
columns having the First Column as rule
number the next one having name age city
with the lower roll numbers as one or
Rohan 22 Hyderabad and the second row
consists of the Roll number two anjana
uh age being 20 and the City Bangalore
and the third one is roll number three
the name is kaushal age 21 and the city
is Mumbai
SQL select statement let us now look at
the syntax of SQL select statement
the SQL is followed the syntax is
followed as select column 1 column 2 and
a number of columns from the table name
and if you want to uh display all the
names from the table you have to use
hashtag that is Select star from table
name let us look at the example
so I want to display the roll number
name age from the student table for that
I'll write select row number
comma name comma H from the table that
is student and if I execute this it will
only display roll number name age of the
students and it will not display the
city of the students
and if you want to display uh even the
city uh
so which they belong we have to write
select star from student then it will
display even the city in the uh table
SQL select condition statement
consider employee table with having ID
name age City and salary
and if you want to specifically uh you
know display uh the employees name uh
who live in a city New Delhi you have to
write select star from employee where
city is equals to New Delhi here we are
applying a condition that is where which
is a SQL clause and we are using an
operator as well which is equal to and
if you execute this statement it will
show this as output where you will find
the ID of aloxing Ravi Patel who
belonged to the city New Delhi
SQL update statement
it is used to update already existing
values in the statement for example if
you consider the syntax it is followed
as update space table name that you have
created set column name equals to new
value that is the updated value that you
want to keep into the new table and you
have to keep a condition as well that is
where condition
let us look an example now if you want
to update the student table and if I
want to insert uh if I want to change
the city of the Roll number three that
is cow shells uh City uh I'll write as
update student set CT equals to Chennai
where roll number is equals to 3 and
when you execute this it will show like
this
so the city uh which is Mumbai has been
changed into Chennai
SQL delete statement
SQL delete statement is is used to
delete a specific row or even all the
rows from the table the syntax is delete
from table name
for example if you want to delete all
the records from the student table we
will write it as delete from student
semicolon so this will be the output it
will only display the uh column names
and the data inside it will be
completely erased
and if you want to delete only a certain
number of rows we have to use Query as
delete from student where role number is
equals to 1 and when you execute this
query it will show like this it will
completely erase the records of uh the
roll number one student
and the final one is data control
language or DCL
DCL is responsible for maintaining the
security which gives control access and
permissions of the database commands
that come under DCL are Grant it is used
to Grant the permission to user to
access the database revoke it is used to
cancel or take back the permissions that
were earlier granted
let us now look at SQL Grant statement
sometimes user is restricted from
creating or making any changes within
the table but with the help of Grant
statement we can give privilege to the
user to create or modify the records in
the table
let us now look at the syntax of SQL
Grant statement it is followed as Grant
space privilege list that is basically
the set of commands that you are giving
access of permission to the user to
perform certain operations on the table
that you have created to user we have to
mention the username example Grant
insert select on employee to Rahul that
means Rahul is able to access the
employee table and can perform a command
such as insert and select
SQL revoke statement SQL revoke
statement is basically the opposite of
Grant statement it is used to take back
the permissions that were earlier
granted the similar the syntax is also
similar to the grant statement instead
of Grant keyword you have to replace it
by revoke let us look at the example
revoke insert on employee from Rahul
that means Rahul is no longer able to
insert new values into the employee
table
what are SQL operators SQL operators are
basically reserved words or special
characters that are used to query a
database SQL provides us with many such
operators to ease the process of data
manipulation
SQL operators are used to perform
various tasks including complex
mathematical operations like arithmetic
and binary
to query a database using operators we
use a where Clause operators are
necessary to define a condition in SQL
as they act as a connector between two
or more SQL statements based on the
operative functionality it manipulates
the data accordingly and gives the
result
types of SQL operators SQL operators are
mainly classified into three types the
first one is arithmetic operators the
arithmetic operators perform the
mathematical operation on numerical data
of SQL tables they're further classified
as addition operator the addition
operator is used to perform addition or
numerical data using this we can add
values of single or multiple columns in
the table
subtraction operator subtraction
operator in SQL performs the subtraction
on the numerical data of the database
table
multiplication operator multiplication
operator in SQL performs multiplication
on the data items in SQL we can easily
multiply the numerical values of two or
more Columns of the same table by
specifying both the column names as the
first and second operand
and finally division operator division
operator in SQL divides the operand on
the left side by the operand on the
right side we can also divide the
numerical values of one column by
another column of the same table by
specifying both column names as the
first and second operand
let us now look at the execution part of
the arithmetic operations on MySQL
workbench
as you can see workbench has started but
before we proceed to the syntax of SQL
operators we have to first create a
database and then we have to create a
table within the database so for time
being I've already created a table named
employee so let us just briefly go
through the syntax of create table
so the syntax is followed as create
table space now you can declare the
employee that is the table name in two
ways that is you can directly mention
the table name that is employee or else
you can mention database dot table name
that is employee and after that in the
parenthesis you have to mention the
column names followed by its appropriate
data types so as far as this table
employees concerned I have taken a
column names as ID name age City and
salary
and also I've chosen primary key as ID
as it uniquely identifies each and every
record in the table
close the parenthesis and put a
semicolon
now that you have created a table you
have to insert values into the table and
for that we use insert command so the
Syntax for insert command is insert into
space
table name that is employee and within
the parenthesis you have to mention all
the column names that you have taken uh
in the single quotes
after that close the parenthesis and you
have to write values which is the
keyword and mention different values as
per your choice accordingly that you
have taken uh into the columns
so in this way you can insert n number
of Records into the table using insert
command for this employee table I have
taken out values total of 10 values
now that you have created and inserted
values into your table and if you want
to display all the records of the
employees you have to uh write you have
to select the query as
select
star
from
the table name that is employee
and when you execute this
it will show the records of all the
employees that you have taken that is
their ID their name age City and salary
so we have taken total 10 values and it
will be displayed
now that we have understood all these
let us uh proceed with the SQL operators
first let us look at uh addition
operator
uh let us understand this with an help
of an example uh suppose you want to add
10 000 to the salary of each employee
specified in the table then we have to
write the query as
select
salary
plus 10 000
as I'm taking a new column that is
employee new salary
to specify all these values into the
column
as employee new salary
from the table name that is employee
now when you execute this you
it will show the result like this that
is uh it will add 10 000 to each and
everyone's uh values that is 30 000 has
been changed into forty thousand twenty
eight thousand has been changed into 38
000 and so on
now if I want to display their ID name
their previous salary and the final
salary simultaneously I'll write the
query as select ID
comma space name space
salary
space salary plus 10 000 as employees
new salary from employee
now if I execute this
it will display like this that is it
will uh mention the ID name the previous
salary and employee new salary
simultaneously
so in this way you can add two or more
columns in the same table using addition
operator
let us now look at subtraction operator
subtraction operator is also similar to
that of addition operator the only
difference is you have to replace the
plus sign
with the minus sign so again for this
example uh let us say uh if you want to
subtract 2000 from salary of each
employee given in the employee table
then we have to write the query as
select
ID
comma space name comma space salary
comma space salary
minus two thousand
as
employee new salary
from the table that is employee
so let us execute this
and it will show the new values that is
2000 has been deducted from the salary
of each and every employee as you can
see 30 000 has been reduced to twenty
eight thousand twenty eight thousand has
been reduced to twenty six thousand
thirty five thousand has been reduced to
33 000 and so on
so next let us look at the
multiplication operator
again let us take the same example uh if
you want to multiply the salary of each
and every employee
uh then you have to write the query as
select
ID
name
salary
into two we are using hash asterisk
operator as the multiplication sign here
as
employee new salary
from the table name that is employee
now if you execute this
it'll show the values like uh in this
way that is the salary has been doubled
if it as you can see the employer Rahul
salary 30 000 has been multiplied uh and
has changed into 60 000 that is doubled
20 000 has been doubled to fifty six
thousand and so on
so in this way you can apply
multiplication operator and finally let
us look at a division operator
let us take the same example suppose
let's say if you want to divide the
salary of each and every employee then
you have to write the query as select
ID
name
salary
divided by two
as employing your salary
from the table name that is employee
and put a semicolon let us now execute
this
and as you can see the salary has been
divided uh into half uh Rahul salary 30
000 has been changed to 15 000 Kiran
salary 28 000 has been changed to 40 14
000 and so on so in this way you can use
automatic operations to perform various
uh operations on your table that is
addition subtraction multiplication and
division
the second type of SQL operators are
comparison operators the comparison
operators in SQL Compares two different
data of SQL tables and check whether
they are same greater and lesser the SQL
comparison operators are used with a
conditional Clause where in the SQL
queries they are again further divided
into various types the first one is
equal to SQL equal to operator is one of
the popular and most frequently used
operators in SQL queries it shows only
that data which matches the specified
value in the query
less than the less than operator in SQL
shows only those data from the database
tables which are less than the value of
the right right hand side operand
greater than the greater than operator
in SQL shows only those data which are
greater than the value of right hand
operand
we also have less than equals to and
greater than equals to operators as well
which basically shows the data in the
tables which are less than and equals to
as well as greater than and equals to
the value of the right hand operands
let us look at the syntax and execute
them in the workbench
firstly let us look at the equal to
operator
let's say if you want to access the
records of all those employees who are
having salary uh equals to 40 000 so for
that we'll write the query as select
star
from the table
that is employee
we have to use the conditional statement
where
salary
is equals to forty thousand
and put a semicolon when you execute
this
it will show the records of all those
employees who are having salary equals
to 40 000 as you can see it is showing
three IDs uh uh pranay Anusha and Prem
who are having salary says forty
thousand
next let us look at uh not equals to not
equals to is basically the opposite of
equal to and uh
to understand this let us take an
example suppose if we want to access the
records of all those employees whose
salary is not equals to uh 35 000 so for
that we'll write the query as select
star
from the table that is employee
where
let us put the keyword in the upper case
where salary
not equals to 35 000.
let us execute this and let us see the
output
so as you can see it will display the
records of all those employees who are
not having the salary uh 35 000 so it
will display the record such as rahul's
Kiran pranay Anusha varsha who are
having salices thirty thousand twenty
eight thousand forty thousand twenty
three thousand and so on which are
basically not equals to 35 000.
next let us look at a greater than
operator
uh for this let us take an example for
instance if you want to access the
records of all those employees from the
employee table uh whose ID is greater
than one or four so for that we'll write
the following query as
select
star from the table that is employee
where ID greater than 1.4
for a semicolon and let us execute this
so as you can see it will display the
records of all those employees uh who
are having ID greater than 104 that is
it will display from one not five and up
until 110.
similarly uh we have the less than
operator as well
which is basically the opposite of
greater than operator for that uh
we'll take an example uh such as if you
want to display the records of all those
employees who are having ID less than
1.5 so for that we'll write the query as
select
star
from the table that is employee
where
ID
is less than 1.5
let us execute this
so as you can see it will display all
those records of the employees who are
having less than one or five that is it
will display the records of the
employees one or two one one or two one
not three and one not for IDs
next let us look at uh greater than
equals to
greater than equal to is also similar to
that of greater than but the thing is we
are also mentioning the equal to
operator as well
so for instance let's say if you want to
access the records of all those
employees in the employee table who are
having salary greater than or equals to
40 000. so for that we'll write the
query as select star
from the table employee
where
salary
greater than equals to forty thousand
let us execute this
and this is will this will be the output
it will show the records of all those
employees who are having salary greater
than or equals to forty thousand so in
this case it will display a total of
four records of the employee table
similarly uh let us look at the less
than equals to operator as well
which basically uses less than and equal
to operator
so suppose if you want to access the
records of all those employees from the
employee table who's having salary let's
say less than or equals to thirty
thousand so for that uh we'll have to
write the following query as select
star
from employee
where
salary
less than or equals to thirty thousand
so let us execute this
and the output will be like this that is
it will display all the employer Records
who are having salary less than or
equals to thirty thousand a total of
three records that is ID employee ID is
one not one one or two one or six have
been displayed because we are having
salary is thirty thousand twenty eight
thousand twenty three thousand which are
basically less than or equals to thirty
thousand
so in this way you can use comparison
operator to perform various operations
on your data
and finally we have logical operators
The Logical operators in SQL perform
Boolean operations which Give two
results either true or false these
operators provide True Value if both
operands match The Logical condition and
vice versa
various logical operators in SQL are and
are not and between let us understand
the syntaxes and execute them in the
workbench now
firstly let us discuss about the and
operator and operator in SQL will show
the records from a database table if all
the conditions separated by the and
operator is evaluated to be true let us
understand with an example let's say if
you want to access the records of all
those employees from the employee table
whose salary is greater than 25 000 and
the city that they belong to is
Hyderabad so for that we'll write the
following query as select star
from table name that is employee
where salary
is greater than 25 000
and
the city that they belong to is
Hyderabad
so when you execute this statement
the following output will will be
this that is it will display the uh
total three records of the employees
that is Rahul Kiran and Chinmay who are
having salaries more than 25 000 and the
city that they belong to is Hyderabad so
in this way and operator in SQL is used
to compare data with more than one
condition if and only if all the
conditions return true then only it will
display the records otherwise it won't
next let us look at the r operator
our operator in SQL shows the records
from the table if any of the conditions
separated by the or operator evaluates
to be true
let us understand with an example for
instance if you want to display the
records of employees from the employee
table who are whose salary is greater
than 30 000 or the city that they belong
to is Bangalore so the following query
would be select star
from the table that is employee
where
salary is less than 30 000
or
the city that they belong to is
Bangalore
let us execute this statement now
so this will be the following output
where you can see a total of four
records of the employees uh followed by
Kirin pranay varsha and Rohit who are
having Salvage less than 30 000 or else
they belong to the City Bangalore
so in this way we can use our operator
which basically compares the data with
more than one condition and unlike and
operator if either of the condition is
true it will return the data otherwise
it won't
next let us look at the between operator
between operator in SQL shows the record
within a specified range mentioned in
the SQL query if there is no value in
this given range then this operator
shows null value
suppose if you want to access the
information of all the employees from
the employee table whose salary is in
between 25
000 and 35
000 then we'll write the following query
as select star
from table name that is employee
where
salary
between
25 000
and 30 35 000.
let us execute this query now
so following is the output where it will
display the records of all those
employees who are having salaries in
between 25
000 and 35 000.
and finally let us look at the not
operator
not operator in SQL shows the record
from the table if the condition
evaluates to be false that means the not
operator is also called as a negation or
a negate operator which shows data for
the opposite of the conditions that we
mentioned in the SQL statement
let us understand this with the help of
an example let's say if you want to
access the information of all those
employees from the table who are not
having salary as 40 000 so for that
we'll write the syntax as
select star
from table name that is employee
where
not
salary
equals to forty thousand
so let us execute this query now
so as you can see it will display all
the records of those employees who are
not having the salary as 40 000.
so what are SQL Expressions SQL
expressions are composed of one or more
keywords or values such as operators
operands and various other functions
that evaluate to a single value or a set
of values for a given SQL statement
these SQL expressions are like a formula
which are similar to that of
mathematical formulas we use to solve a
problem and in this case they are
written in a query language using a
proper syntax to perform operations on
the data we have stored in our database
table for example consider the basic
syntax of the select statement here
expressions are used in many contexts
such as to retrieve any value from the
table we use select command and for
comparison we use where Clause so in
this case all these are SQL Expressions
only
types of SQL Expressions SQL Expressions
can be classified into following
categories the first one is Boolean
expression SQL Boolean Expressions fetch
data based on one-to-one matching in
other words we can think of it as a
query that fetches one result at a time
it will fetch the condition against uh
the single value when the query is
executed
the second one is numeric expression SQL
numeric expression is used for
performing mathematical operations in
SQL query besides automatic operations
there are several built-in functions
like average sum count as well
date expression SQL date expressions are
used to compare and get date according
to its various date and time related
query and conditions they give date time
value as the output it can also return
current system date and time values also
now that we have understood what exactly
SQL expressions are let's execute them
in MySQL workbench with the help of
examples
as you can see SQL workbench has started
and before we get to the execution part
of various SQL Expressions we have to
first create a table so for that I've
already created a table named student
within the database simply code the
student table consists of various
columns such as roll number name of the
student age the city they belong to date
of birth the stream that they have
chosen and the total marks that they
have scored in the final exam and here
the primary key is roll number which
basically uniquely identifies each and
every record of the students in the
table
so now that we have created the table if
we want to retrieve the information of
all the students we'll use select
command so the following query would be
select
star
from the table name that is student
and semicolon
let us execute this
and as you can see all the records of
the students are being displayed that is
the name their age the city they belong
to the stream and also the total marks
that they have scored in the final exam
now that we have created table and
inserted values into the table let us
understand various SQL Expressions
firstly let us discuss about Boolean
expression
for that we'll take a simple example
from the table itself
suppose let's say you want to display
the records of those students from the
student table who belong to the city
Kochi for that we'll write the SQL query
as
select
star
from the table name that is student
where
CT equals to Kochi
now let us execute this statement and
see the output
so as you can see there's a student
named Divya whose ages 21 Who belongs to
the city Kochi similarly you can find
for another cities as well so let us
take for Pune
and execute this query
so the output would be uh it will show
the records of two students named Aman
and Indra who's having age 22 and 25 who
belong to the city Pune and having a
streams is strictly an MBA and the total
Marxist 922 and 972.
so the Boolean expression not only
executes the values against the
character values which is in this case
is Pune but it can also take the values
of numerical values as well for example
let's say uh the university has got to
know the highest marks scored by an
individual in the final exam is 988 and
it wants to retrieve the details of that
student so for that the following query
would be
select
star
from table name that is student
where
total marks
is equals to 988
let us execute this query now
so as you can see a student named pratik
Who belongs to the stream CAC has scored
the highest marks on 988 so in this way
Boolean expressions are used to perform
various operations which basically
evaluates a given condition to a
particular value or you can say a single
value and if the condition is true it
will return the output and display all
those records otherwise it won't
up next we have numeric expression
numeric expressions
so numeric expressions are basically
used to perform various mathematical
operations so let us understand this
with an example for instance let's say
the university has decided to change the
total marks weightage from 1000 to 500
and I'll specify a condition where I'll
take the total marks and divide them
into half and check all the students who
have scored more than 480 out of 500 for
that the following query would be select
star
from the table that is student
where
total marks
divided by 2
is greater than 480.
put a semicolon and let us execute this
so as you can see there are total four
students who have scored more than 480
when that when the total marks are
divided into half for instance if you
take uh the record of Rohan who has
scored total marks 977 and if you
divided it by 2 that is approximately
488.5 which is satisfying the condition
which that is greater than 480.
and if you look at this SQL statement
carefully there are a lot of SQL
Expressions here firstly the student
table name that is the student itself
because uh it is used to retrieve the
values from the columns that is uh here
the total marks is the column and we
also have the operands that is total
months divided by 2 and the right hand
operand that is 480 which can also be
considered as an SQL expression here
similarly we have other inbuilt
functions as we discussed earlier like
some average count minimum and maximum
let's say if you want to calculate the
average of total marks of each and every
student scored in the final exam the
following query would be
select
average which is the SQL function
and within the parenthesis
mentioned total marks
total marks
from the table that is M student
let us execute this
as you can see it is displaying the
total average of total marks that is 954
4.375
similarly you can calculate the sum of
all the marks of the students as well so
the query would be select sum
total marks
total marks from the student table
let us execute this
and this will be the following output
so there is a bit error in the code let
me check it once
so as you can see it is displaying the
sum of total marks that is
7635. so in this way you can use numeric
Expressions to perform various
operations on the SQL tables
and finally we have date expression
which basically returns date and time
values of the table say let's say if you
want to display the records of those
students who are born after 1995 January
so for that the following query would be
select star
from the table name that is student
where
date of birth is greater than
1995
January 1st
so let us execute this query and see the
output
as you can see there are total uh five
records of the students who are born
after January 1995.
similarly you can also display the
current date and time as well using the
current timestamp function that is
Select
current timestamp
current time stamp
and let us execute this query
so as you can see it will display the
current
year uh the date and the month format
similarly it is also displaying your uh
time which is in the format of hours
minutes and seconds
so in this way you can use various
Expressions to query the database for a
specific set of data to retrieve the
information from the SQL tables
what is SQL database a database in
general is a collection of organized
data for easier access so that it can be
managed and stored effectively as far as
SQL databases are concerned a relational
database is used to store and manage all
the data in the form of tables simple
SQL queries are returned to retrieve the
data from these SQL database tables in a
nutshell you can see that SQL is used to
connect with the databases as it
directly interacts and communicates with
the database to retrieve the information
stored in tables
popular SQL databases some popular SQL
databases are MySQL Microsoft SQL Server
Oracle database postglue SQL and mongodb
these are some databases that are being
widely used nowadays by many companies
each of them function in their own way
and also the syntax of queries that are
written can also slightly vary from each
other as well
let us now discuss the first topic of
today's session that is SQL create
database in SQL creating a new database
is the first and foremost step to store
the data in the tables so in order to
create a database users must use create
database as a keyword in the syntax so
the syntax is followed as create
database that is the keyword that we are
using here followed by the name of the
database name
in the syntax database name specifies
the name of the database which you want
to create in the system also make sure
that the database you're creating has a
unique name and it does not match with
other databases as well for example if
you look at the following example I am
creating a database named student so the
syntax would be create database followed
by the database name that is student so
let us now run this syntax on MySQL
workbench and see how it is executed in
real time
as you can see MySQL has opened and if
you look carefully at the interface of
MySQL workbench on the left hand side
you will find schemas or the various
databases that are available in the
system at the center you'll find the SQL
editor where the queries are written and
at the bottom you will find the console
where you can see the status or the
output of the query that has been
executed so firstly let's go ahead and
discuss the first topic that is how to
create a database let's say if you want
to create a new database a project so
the create database statement would be
as followed
create database
that is the keyword that is used to
create a new database followed by that
we have to specify the database name
that is Project
put a semicolon and let us execute this
as you can see our database project has
been successfully executed and if you
refresh the schema you will find the
database name as project so in this way
you can create a new project and just
for confirmation if you want to check
the databases created or not you can
check it in the list of databases by
using show databases
keyword so let us see and execute this
so as you can see these are the various
databases that are available in the
system including our database project
that we have created earlier
let us now discuss our next topic that
is how to select a database
now that you have created a database now
the user wants to perform some
operations like creating a new table and
inserting values onto the existing
database in SQL for that firstly they
have to select the database on which
they want to run the database queries
without selecting the database they
cannot create a new table for instance
if I want to create a new table
that is student and when I execute this
query
it will throw an error stating that no
database selected select the default
database to be used so in this way you
won't be able to create a new table
without selecting the database
any database user can easily select a
particular database from the current
database server using the use keyword in
the SQL statement so the following
syntax would be use
followed by the database name
that you want to select for example let
us take for instance if I want to work
on the database project so the following
query would be
use
project which is the
database name here let us execute this
so as you can see the query has been
successfully executed and
also you can find the database name
project is highlighted in a bold that
means you have successfully selected the
database and you can start creating your
new tables
so in this way uh when you have multiple
databases in your SQL schema before
starting your operations you have to
select a database where all the
operations would be performed also keep
in mind that the database that you are
selecting should be unique
finally let us look at how to drop the
database
in other words dropping a database is to
delete a database the SQL drop database
statement deletes the existing database
permanently from the database system
that means the statement deletes all the
data and the tables that are stored in
the database so let us now look at the
syntax of the drop database the syntax
is followed as drop database
followed by the database name that is
Project
here in SQL syntax we have specified the
name of the database which we want to
delete permanently from the database
system after the drop database keyword
and let us execute this and see the
output
as you can see the database has been
dropped and even at the left hand side
if you look at the schemas uh database
project has been deleted successfully
so in this way you can delete a database
using drop database statement but be
careful before using this operation
because by deleting an existing database
it would result in complete loss of
information stored in the database
what is SQL table tables are the
essential elements of a database and in
particular for relational databases as
it is one of the most used data models
to store and retrieve data from tables
tables are basically an organized
collection of data that consists of rows
and columns another point to be noted is
that a table has a specified number of
columns but can have any number of rows
let us understand this with an example
here the name of the table is taken as
an employee and in SQL naming a table is
very important because before performing
any operation you have to specify the
name also the name of the table should
be unique and it should not match with
other tables in the database the
horizontal values represented in the
tables are called as rows or tuples and
each row represents a unique record
similarly the vertical values represent
columns or the attributes of that
particular table and each column
represents a unique field in the record
as we can see in the table employee ID
employee name job department number
salary are the various fields or the
column names the data in this multiple
columns such as the employee name Rohan
who's having employee 2011 who is
working as a data analyst belong to the
department three and having salary 50
000 is stored in the form of rows
I hope you've understood what is an SQL
table now so let us now discuss some
basic SQL queries that are performed on
these tables and execute them in MySQL
workbench as well
SQL create table
SQL create table is foremost thing to do
in SQL if you want to create a table you
should name the table and Define its
columns and each columns data type let
us now look at the syntax of create
table the syntax is followed as create
table which is the keyword used here
followed by that we have to mention the
table name and within the parenthesis
you have to mention the column names
followed by that you have to mention the
data type in this way you can add a
number of columns as per your choice now
that we have understood the syntax let
us jump into MySQL workbench and execute
this
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit skillup by simply learn click
on the link in the description to know
more
as you can see MySQL workbench has
started and on the left side you can see
that simply code is the database which
we are working on and in that database
we are going to create a new table so
let us now look at the syntax of create
a table so the syntax is followed as
create table which is the keyword we are
using followed by that we have to
specify the table name that is we have
taken employee in this case and within
the brackets or the parenthesis you have
to mention the column names followed by
that you have to mention the data types
here I have taken column names as ID
name City job and salary
and finally I have chosen the primary
key as ID because it uniquely identifies
each and every record in the table
in the end you have to close the
brackets and mention semicolon let us
now execute this query and see the
output
as you can see our table is successfully
created so in order to display the
values or whether or not our table is
created or not we have we have the query
as select
star from the table name that is
employee
let us execute this and see the output
as you can see the table is created and
it is showing the column names as ID
name CT job and salary so in this way
you can create a new table
next let us discuss about dropped table
drop table in other words is basically
is to delete a table the SQL drop table
statement is used to remove the table
definition and the overall structure of
the existing table be careful that while
using this command because once a table
is deleted then all the information
available in the data will also be lost
forever the Syntax for the drop table is
drop table and then you have to mention
the table name
so let us now look at the example now
for some reasons if I want to delete the
employee table so the syntax would be
dropped table
followed by that the name of the table
that is employee let us execute this
as you can see our table is completely
dropped and let us now see if it is
actually deleted or not for that we'll
use select statement select star
from the table name that is employee
let me execute this query
as you can see it is throwing an error
stating that table simplyco.employ does
not exist this means you have
successfully deleted the existing table
employee
let us now discuss the next topic that
is SQL insert table SQL insert statement
is used to add new rows of data into a
table this can be a single or multiple
records into the database the Syntax for
the insert table is insert into which is
the keyword followed by that table name
and within the parenthesis you have to
mention the column names values and
again within the parenthesis you have to
mention the values so here the column
one column two column 3 and in number of
columns are the names of the columns in
which the table you want to insert the
data into you may not need to specify
the column names in the SQL query if you
are adding values for all the columns of
the table but make sure the order of the
values is in the same order as the
column in the table
let us jump into the execution part now
I'm taking the same name that is
employee table to insert the new values
so the Syntax for inserting new values
into the table is followed as insert
into table name that is employee and
within the brackets we have to mention
the columns that we have taken earlier
that is ID name City job and salary
after that we have to mention the values
using the values keyword So within the
brackets I'm mentioning the ID name as
well not one name as Rohan the city that
he belongs to is Hyderabad and the job
that he does is Da that is data analyst
and the salary that he earns is 40 000
so let me execute this query and see the
output
foreign
so as you can see our query has been
successfully implemented now let us
display the results by using select
query again let me select this whole
query and execute this
as you can see the details of employee
name that is Rohan whose ID is 101 and
is the CD he belongs to Hyderabad his
job data analyst his salary 40 000 is
being successfully displayed so in this
way you can insert new values into the
table
up next let us discuss about delete
table in SQL delete table in SQL is used
to remove rows from a table this can be
a complete Row from an existing table or
a specific row if you want to remove a
specific Row from a table you should use
where condition but if you do not
specify the where condition here it will
remove all the rows from the table the
Syntax for delete statement is delete
from the table name
so let us take an example now suppose if
I want to delete the records of the
employee who is having employee ID as
102 in the table employee so the
following query would be
delete
from table name that is employee
specify the where condition
keyword that is where
ID is equals to 1.2
let us execute this statement now
as you can see our statement has been
successfully executed now I'll display
the records by using select statement
as you can see the employee ID who is
having uh one or two has his employee ID
has been successfully deleted from the
table so in this way you can use direct
statement to delete a particular record
from the table
huh
let us now discuss about truncate table
in SQL trunky table statement is used to
remove all the rows from the table that
means it deletes the complete data from
an existing table it is similar to that
of delete statement but here we do not
use the where Clause tranquet table is
faster and uses lesser resources than
the delete table command as it deletes
the records at a single time drop table
command can also be used to delete the
complete data but it also deletes the
structure of the table as well truncate
table does not delete the structure of
the data so the Syntax for truncate
table is truncate table
and after that you have to mention the
table name
so if I want to delete all the records
from the employee table the following
query would be
truncate
table
followed by that you have to mention the
table name that is employee let us
execute this and see the output
so the query has been successfully
executed so let me use the select
statement to display the records
as you can see uh all the information of
the employee has been successfully
deleted from the table but if you look
at uh the output closely the structure
hasn't been deleted here the column
names of the table that is ID name City
job and salary have been retained but
only the values in the table have been
deleted so in this way you can use
truncate statement to delete all the
records from the table at a single time
make sure that uh you use this statement
carefully because the rollback process
is not possible after using truncate's
table statement that means if the data
is once deleted it is completely deleted
uh permanently
next let us discuss about SQL alter
table the alter table in SQL
is used to add modify and delete Columns
of an existing table
in many situations you may require to
add columns in the existing table so
instead of creating a whole table again
and again you can easily add single or
multiple columns using alter table
statement with the help of a keyword add
let us now look at the syntax of alter
table the syntax is followed as alter
table table name add and within the
parenthesis you have to mention the new
column and the data type so let us now
jump into the execution part
consider the same table employee again
suppose if you want to add a new column
that is date of birth of the employee in
the above table for this you have to
type the following query as
alter
table
mention the table name that is employee
after that mention the keyword add
and within the brackets mention the new
column name that is date of birth and
the data type of the date of birth is
date so I'll be mentioning the date data
type close the brackets and put the
semicolon let us execute this statement
now
as you can see our statement has been
successfully implemented and I'll use
the select statement to display the new
records
as you can see there's a new column
named date of birth has been
successfully added to our existing table
employee in this way you can use alter
table to add or delete the columns from
the table
let us now discuss about SQL rename
table
SQL rename table is used in SQL to
change the name of the table so in some
situations the database user might want
to change the name of the table so that
they want to give a more relevant name
or the updated name to the table any
database user can easily change the name
of the table by using rename table and
alter table statement in SQL
let us look at the syntax now the syntax
is followed as alter table
current Table name rename to new table
name
let us now execute this in MySQL
workbench
consider the same table employee again
and suppose if you want to change the
name of the about table employee into
let's say employee new for this you have
to type the following query that is
Alter
table
old table name that is employee
rename to is the keyword that you have
to use here
and mention the new table name we are
taking employee
new as our new table name so let us
execute this and see the output
as you can see our statement has been
successfully executed so let let us
update the schema here and see whether
or not the name of the table is changed
so as you can see our table employee
which we had previously has been changed
into employee new in this way you can
use rename statement to give a new name
to your existing table
finally let us now look at SQL copy
table statement if you want to copy
the data of one SQL table into another
SQL table in the same SQL database then
it is possible by using the select into
statement in SQL the select into
statement in SQL copies the content from
an existing table into a new table SQL
creates the new table by using the
structure of the existing table the
syntax is followed as select star into
new table name from the old table name
let us now execute this in MySQL
workbench and see the output
consider the same employee table again
and suppose you want to copy the content
of the employee table into a new table
let's say employee details now as far as
MySQL workbench is concerned there is a
slight change in the query now the
syntax that we've discussed earlier is
applicable to some other SQL databases
like Microsoft SQL server and Oracle
database but for MySQL workbench there
is a different syntax to copy a new
table so the syntax is followed as
create
table
mention the new table name that is
employee details
now select
star
from the old table name that is employee
let us now execute this and see the
output
now it will throw an error stating that
the employee table doesn't exist that's
because we have renamed our previous
employee name table into employee new so
instead of employee change it to employ
new and let us execute this statement
now
so
to in order to display if the employee
table is created successfully or not in
the database let us use select statement
to display the records select star from
the table name which is the new table
name that is employee
details
let us execute this now
as you can see uh the details that we
had earlier in our employee new table
has been copied into another table that
is employee details in this way you can
copy the content from one table existing
table from another new table by using
copy statement in SQL
and with that we have come to end of
today's session these were some of the
queries that were related to SQL tables
if you want to learn more about SQL make
sure to check out our previous playlist
in our Channel also we have a dedicated
video SQL full course 2022 for beginners
wherein we have discussed SQL and
various Concepts from the scratch
what is SQL select statement SQL select
statement is used to fetch the data from
a database table which Returns the data
in a form of a resultant table in simple
words we can say that it is used to
access the information from one or more
database tables within the database
let's look at the syntax of SQL select
statement the syntax is followed as
select column from table name in the
select syntax you can see column name
one column name 2 and N number of
columns are the name of those columns in
the table whose data you wanted to read
and if you want to access all the rows
from all the fields of the table you can
use the select star operator in the
database by using select star from table
name command
let us look an example if you want to
retrieve the information of the student
who's having roll number name and age we
can write a simple query as select roll
number name age from student in this way
we can display the details of the
student
SQL select condition
select statement is used with various
Clauses as well that means it also
retrieves the selected data that follows
a particular condition with the help of
a where Clause by using this command we
can access a particular record from a
particular column of the table let's
understand this with an example consider
the employee table here which is having
ID name age City and salary as its
column in the table
let's say if you want to access the
information of those employees who's
having age as 29. for that we'll write a
simple query as select star from
employee where age is equals to 29 and
if you execute this this will be the
following output which shows the
information of those employees whose age
is 29 so in this way you can use SQL
select condition by specifying a where
statement which is used to filter the
data in a particular table
now that we have understood the basics
of SQL select statement let us now jump
into MySQL workbench and execute this
and understand it in in a more better
way
as you can see MySQL workbench has
started and for time being I've already
created a table employee which is having
column names as employee ID employee
name age designation date of birth city
that they belong to and salary and I've
chosen primary key as employee ID
because it uniquely identifies each and
every record in the table
now that we've created a table in order
to display all these records we have to
use this select statement ultimately so
to display all the values from each
column of the table that is the employee
table we have to write the following
query as select
star
from table name that is employee
let us execute this and see the output
as you can see it will display all the
values of the employees their employee
ID employee name age designation date of
birth the city and their respective
salaries so if you want to display a
particular column so for that you have
to write the query as let's say if I
want to select employee ID employee name
and the city uh of the employees so for
that I'll write select employee ID
comma
employee name
comma let's say I want to display the
salary so I'm taking a salary
from
table name
that is employee
let us execute this now
so as you can see only the employee ID
employee name and the salary of the
employees in the table are being shown
here because we have only specified a
particular column in this case
now similarly we can use where clause
also the where Clause is used with
select statement to return only those
rows from the table which satisfy the
specified condition in the query for
example uh if I want to show the salary
of the employee who is having uh more
than 30 000 so for that I'll write the
query as select
star
from employee
where
salary
is greater than 30 000.
so let us execute this statement and see
the output so as you can see it will
display the records of all those
employees who's having salary more than
30 000.
similarly you can see uh you can also
check
whether the city that they belong to is
Mumbai so for that we have to take the
SQL query as
select star from employee where city is
equals to suppose I want to display the
employee who belongs to the city Mumbai
so for that I'll take the city as Mumbai
and execute this statement
okay uh you have to mention Mumbai in uh
single quotes so that's the reason it is
showing error here
so let us now execute this and see the
output
so as you can see there are only two
employees who belong to the city uh that
is the employee kavya and Pavan who's
having the employee ID 103 and 109. so
in this way you can use select statement
uh to display a particular uh record by
using work loss
foreign
now that we've got an idea on how SQL
select statement works let us now
discuss some select statement functions
the first one is Select
distinct
the select distinct in SQL is used to
fetch identical or distinct column
values from existing table without any
duplicate values now suppose in a
particular table there might be a higher
chance that there exists a duplicate
value and if you want to retrieve only
unique values in such scenario you use a
SQL select listing statement I know it
might be a bit confusing so let me make
it clear to you guys consider the same
employee table again here
and uh if you look at the table
the values in the column City the
Hyderabad has been repeated more than
once here and not just Hyderabad Chennai
has also been repeated twice so in this
case in a broader sense if I just wanted
to know from which city the employee is
from I'll just use the distinct select
statement so using this uh
instead of multiple uh values that are
being displayed the SQL distance
statement make sure that the value is
retrieved only once and there is no room
for any repeated or distinct value so
let us now understand this syntax with
an example the syntax is followed as
select
distinct
now let's say if I want to fetch a
distinct designation of all the
employees of the company so for that I
am specifying the column name here as
designation
from the table that is employee
let us now execute this
uh there is a bit error in the code let
me just check it
so let us execute the query now and see
the output
so as you can see this is the output
that is being displayed where the unique
values
uh of the designation of all the
employees are being displayed that is
business analyst manager HR SD and so on
so in this way by using SQL select
distinct statement we can fetch distinct
values from the existing table
let us now discuss about select count
statement in SQL the select count is
used to get the total number of rows
from a table basically it Returns the
total number of Records present in the
database table let's take a simple
example consider the same employee table
now if you have a record in the table
and if you want to count the total
number of uh Records in the table for
that the following query would be
select
count
star
from the table name that is employee
let us execute this and see the output
now
so as you can see there are total 15
records present in the employee table
similarly you can use the where
condition as well if you want to get the
total number of rows of the employees
who are having salary equals to 50 000
in the employee table so for that the
following query would be select
count
asterisk
from employee
specify the condition here now where
salary
is equals to fifty thousand
let us execute this statement now
so as you can see there are total three
employees who are having salary equals
to fifty thousand
similarly you can get the total number
of rows in a table by using the distinct
statement as well let's say if you want
to retrieve a unique count of the city
of the employees from the table the
following query would be select count
which is the keyword that we are using
and inside the bracket mentioned
distinct keyword
followed by the column name that is City
from the table that is employed
now let us execute this statement and
see the output
so as you can see there are total uh
eight employees who are belong to
different cities so in this way you can
use uh select con statement to retrieve
various number of Records in a
particular table
next let us discuss about select top or
limit
statement in SQL the select top
statement in SQL shows The Limited
number of Records or rows from the
database table the top clause in the
statement specifies how many rows we
want to display from our table this
Clause is used when there are thousands
of Records stored in the database table
now all database systems do not support
top keyword now as far as MySQL is
concerned it supports the limit keyword
so let us now look at the syntax of
Select limit statement the syntax is
followed as
select
star
from
employee table
limit is the keyword that we have to use
and I want to display the first three
records of the employees so I'm
specifying three here
so let us execute this statement
so as you can see the first three
records of the employees who are having
ID employee ID as one not one one or two
one or three are being displayed
let us consider another scenario here if
you want to fix the first three
employees who got highest salaries from
the employee table then the following
query would be
select
star
from
the table name that is employee
ordered by
is the condition that I am using to
display the employee details
salary
desc that means descending now I want to
display the records in the descending
order and I am limiting the value up to
2.
limit three
so let us execute the statement now
so as you can see it will display a
total of three Records who are having
the salary uh who got the highest salary
in the descending order that is Kamal
who got the salary as 60 000 Sindhu
having 50 000 and Kiran who is having 50
000. so in this way you can use limit
statement to display the specified rows
that is the top rows in the table
next let us discuss about select random
statement in SQL as the name suggests
SQL select random statement is used to
return a random Row from a table present
in the database it has many real life
applications for example if a HR manager
wants to send 10 random mails to his
employees then he can use random
function in SQL to send the email it is
also used to display random questions
during an online exams for students so
the syntax for select random is followed
as
select
column name now I want to display the
records of all the employees so I am
choosing star operator
from the table that is employee
order by is the conditional Clause we
have to use
followed by that we have to mention Rand
which is the function
let us execute the statement
so as you can see the details of the
employees are being displayed in a mixed
manner uh that is they are displayed in
a random way as you can see the employee
details of employee who is having ID 114
is being displayed your first and then
112 and then 1.3 so in this way you can
uh display the values randomly using
random function in SQL similarly you can
limit the values as well if you want to
show the top three random values of the
employees you can use limit statement
here so limit
and if I want to display the first four
records of the employees so I'm choosing
four
let us execute the statement now
so it will show the details of the
employees randomly up to uh four that is
the top four details of the employees so
in this way you can use a random
statement to display uh random values
within a database table
next let us discuss about select in
statement in SQL the select in function
is used to fetch specific rows or values
from an existing table with multiple
conditions the conditions are specified
within Clause the operation of Select in
is same as or operation select in is
used to reduce the multiple or operators
in select statement let us understand
this with an example so if I want if I
see details of employees who are having
employee ID as let's say one or two or
one not four or one or seven from the
employee table then the following query
would be select
star
from the table that is employee
where
employee ID now we have to mention the
in keyword here and within the brackets
mention the IDS so I am taking one or
two
or not 4
and 1.7
so let us execute the statement and see
the output
so as you can see it is displaying the
values of the employees who are having
ID either one or two or one not four or
one not seven
next let us discuss about select date
statement in SQL SQL select date is used
to retrieve the values of date from a
database if you want to find a
particular date from a database you can
use this statement so let us understand
with an example let's say if you want to
display the records of all those
employees who are born before 1995 Jan
first so the following query would be
select
star
from the table that is employee
where
date of birth
is less than
1995
Jan first
make sure you incorporate the date in
the single quotes otherwise it will
throw an error so let me execute this
statement
so as you can see it is displaying the
records of all those employees who are
born before 1995 Jan first similarly you
can use a greater than operator as well
to show the employees who are born after
1995. similarly uh if you want to fetch
the employees who have borne between a
particular date let's say who are born
between 1996 and 1998 then the foreign
query would be select start from
employee where date of birth
between is the keyword we have to use
between let's say I'm using
1996 Jan first
and 1998.
1998 Jan first
so let me execute this statement and see
the output
so as you can see it is displaying the
records of all those employees who are
born in between uh the particular date
that we have given that is in between
1996 and 1998. so in this way you can
use the select date statement to
retrieve the date values in the database
next let us discuss about select some
statement in SQL select sum is used to
return the sum of all the values in a
specified column now you have to make a
note here that some sum function is
applied only on numeric or numeric
related fields let us consider the same
employee table again and if you want to
get the sum of all the employee salaries
in the employee table then the following
query would be select
sum as the keyword and within the
brackets mentioned the salary column
from the table that is employee
let us execute the statement and see the
output
so as you can see it is showing the sum
of the Salvage of all the employees here
that is 6 lakh 5000 is the total uh
value of the combined salary of all the
employees similarly you can use the
where condition here as well uh to get
the sum of the salaries of employee by
specifying a condition let's say if I
want to get the total salary of all
those employees who belong to the city
uh Mumbai so for that I am writing the
query as select some salary from
employee where is the conditional clause
City
equals to Mumbai
make sure Mumbai is in single coach
otherwise it will throw an error so let
us execute this statement now and see
the output
so as you can see it is displaying the
sum of all the salaries of those
employees belonging to Mumbai as 80 000.
so in this way you can use the uh some
select some statement in SQL to display
the sum of values in a particular column
and finally let us now look at the
select null statement in SQL null in a
table represents that the field has no
value these null values are used to
represent the missing data in a
particular table now null value is
different from a zero value that means a
field with a null value is the one that
has been left blank during the record
creation Now to verify the column value
is null or not we can use the keyword is
null or is not null now we should make a
note here that null value can't compare
with operators like equals to greater
than or less than so let us take an
example to understand the syntax now if
you want to fetch the details of the
students whose marks are null that means
the marks that they have scored in the
final exam are yet to be assigned to the
students so for that the following query
would be
uh select
select
star
from the table that is student
where is the condition
marks
is null which is the keyword we are
using so let us execute this statement
and see the output
so as you can see there are two students
whose marks are yet to be updated and it
also means that their marks are not
equals to zero it's simply that their
marks have been left out and kept as
null
what is SQL Clause SQL Clause are
basically inbuilt SQL functions that use
a certain conditional expression which
helps to access a particular set of
records from the database table Clauses
help us to restrict and manage the data
using valid constraints on the data in
our database now since we have large
amounts of data stored in the database
we use Clauses to query the table to get
the desired data only so the complexity
is reduced when condition is applied to
an SQL statement
SQL Clauses use filters and analyzes the
data quickly because it is used to
extract only those records that fulfill
the specified condition
types of SQL Clauses SQL Clauses are
divided into three types the first one
is the basic clause which uses a
condition the second one is order by
which is used to sort the data in tables
in either ascending or descending order
and the last one is Group by which is
used for organizing similar data into
groups
SQL where Clause SQL where Clause is the
most used and integral part of any query
to specify a condition in the SQL
statement which retrieves only those
records which satisfy the given
condition the where Clause is not only
used in the select statement but it is
also used in the update delete statement
Etc using logical and comparison
operators like greater than less than
and equal to operators let us now look
at the syntax of where Clause the syntax
is followed as select column 1 column 2
and up to n number of columns from table
name where condition here column and
column 2 represents the columns which we
want to fetch the data from the table
and the condition here represents the
required condition to fetch rows based
on the requirement it contains column
name operator user defined value
comparison and logical operators are
also used in this condition
so in this way we can use where clause
let us now execute some statement which
uses where clause in MySQL workbench
as you can see the MySQL workbench has
started and before we write queries
using a wire Clause we have to first
create a table so I have created a table
here employee which is columns employee
ID employee name age destination date of
birth the city they belong to and their
salary and I've taken primary key here
as employee ID because it uniquely
identifies each and every record in the
table now that we have created the table
let us now look at the simple and basic
query using the where Clause now let's
say if I want to display the details of
all those employees who belong to the
city Mumbai so for that the following
query would be select
star
from the table that is employee
now we have to mention the condition
that is the where Clause where
City
is equals to Mumbai
mention Mumbai in single quotes
otherwise it will show an error so let
us now execute this statement and see
the output
now when we execute the statement it
will show me the output of two employees
who belong to the city so let us now
take another example now we'll use the
greater than operator using the where
Clause now let's say if I want to
display the details of all those
employees whose salary is greater than
30 000 so for that the following query
would be select star
from table that is employee where
salary is greater than 30 000.
so let us execute the statement
now when we execute the statement it
will show me the records of all those
employees who are having salary more
than 30 000 now I think here we have
around uh
15 since we have 15 records in the table
we have a total of eight employees whose
salary is more than thirty thousand so
in this way you can use a greater than
operator similarly you can use the less
than operator as well and let us see the
output
whose salary is less than 35 000 will
take 35 000 here
and now see the output
so there are uh total three employees
who are having the salary less than 35
000 that is uh Aryan Preeti Akil who are
having salary as thirty thousand so in
this way you can use less than operator
as well now let us make another scenario
now if I want to mention a range of
salaries of how much they earn let's say
if I want to display the records of all
those employees who are earning salary
in between 35 000 and 50 000 so for that
the following query would be select
star
from the table
that is employee
where
salary
between is the keyword we have to use
here
35 000
and
50 000.
let us now execute this statement and
see the output
so now these are all the uh records of
the employees who are having salary in
between 35 000 and 15 000. so in this
way you can use uh various comparison
operators to perform uh queries using
where Clause similarly uh you can also
update the values in the table as well
using the update command let's say if I
want to update the salary of employee
whose employee ID is uh one not four so
for that the following query would be
update
table name that is employee
set is the keyword we have to use here
salary
now I want to change the salary as uh 25
000 so I'm choosing 25 000.
specify the condition where
employee ID is equals to uh one not six
so let us execute the statement and see
the output
so as you can see our query successfully
implemented and the employee who ID 106
who's having salary like before some he
used to have some salary now his salary
is changed into 25 000. so let us see
whether it is changed or not we'll use
the select command again to display the
details of all the employees so for that
the query would be select star
from the table that is employed
let us now execute the statement
so 106 uh employee name is varsha who's
working as a software developer and
salary has been changed to 25 000 so in
this way you can use where Clause to
perform various operations using certain
conditions
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit skillup by simply learn click
on the link in the description to know
more
now that we have understood how to write
a query using the where condition let us
now look at some other conditional
statements which uses where Clause first
let us discuss about SQL and condition
SQL and condition is used to specify
multiple condition in where clause and
condition basically Returns the rows or
those values that satisfies both the
conditions that are written after the
where clause in simple terms you can say
that it will only return those values
when both the conditions are met let us
now understand this with an example
let's say if I want to access the
records of all those employees whose
designation is business analyst and
their salary is 35 000. for that the
following query would be select star
from the table that is employee
where I am specifying the condition here
designation
is equals to
business analyst
and
is the keyword that we have to specify
here
salary
is equals to 35 000.
let us execute the statement now
so as you can see it is displaying the
records of two employees whose
designation as business analyst and
their salary is 35 000 but if you look
at the uh employee table carefully let
me just display the values uh there is
the employee ID 101 Who belongs to the
designation business analyst and
similarly we have another employee who's
employed is one not nine and whose
employed is one level here we have three
records but instead it is displaying
only three or two records that's because
there's an employee ID 1.9 who's having
Who belongs to the designation business
analyst that is having forty thousand so
in this case he is not meeting the other
condition that is why it is being
displayed only two values
foreign
so in this way you can use and statement
to filter the records from the table let
us now look at the next statement that
is R SQL or condition is used to specify
again the same multiple conditions in
where clause which is used to fetch the
rows or values which satisfy any of the
condition now unlike and statement if
any of the condition that is provided is
true then it will return all those
values so let me just uh
execute this with an uh example let's
say if I want to access the records of
all those employees whose designation is
manager and the city that they belong to
is Chennai so for that I'll write the
query as select star
from the table that is
employee
where
designation
is equals to manager
or
the city that they belong to is Chennai
foreign
so when execute this statement it will
show a total of three records of all
those employees whose designation is
either manager or the city that they
belong to is Chennai now we have uh the
records of employee who belongs to City
Bangalore indoor as well but it is
showing here because the designation is
manager that is here it is satisfying
either one of the condition that is
either the designation that is manager
or the city that they belong to is
Chennai so in this way you can use our
statement to filter the records
next let us discuss about the limit
condition in SQL the limit condition is
used to fetch those records that have
only limited number of values let's say
if I want to access the records of first
five employees from the table then I'll
write the following query as select star
from the table that is employee
now we have to mention the keyword limit
now I want to access the records of
first five employees so I am specifying
5 as the condition here so let me
execute this statement so it will
display the first five records of the
employees from the employee table now
this limit condition is used like when
you have thousands of Records in a table
and if you want to access the first 100
records of the employees then you can
use the limit condition here with the
example
next let us discuss about SQL as
condition statement now SQL as condition
is used to rename a column temporarily
in a given table now in simple words we
can say that SQL as keyword is used to
give an alias name to the table or
column name in the query and in this way
we can increase the readability and
understandability of the query and call
and also the column headings in the
table so let us understand with an
example let's say if I want to change
the column name of salary to the total
salary then I would write the following
query as select
salary
as
within the single quotes mentioned the
new column name that is total salary
from the table that is employed
so let us execute this statement and see
the output
so as you can see salary has been
changed into a total salary in this way
you can use the and condition statement
to change the column of the table
temporarily
and finally let us discuss the like
statement in SQL the like condition
statement is used to fetch matching rows
or values from the table that satisfies
the wildcard operator now the Wild Card
operator in SQL uh basically have two
types the first one is percentage sign
the percentage sign represents a single
or multiple character and the second one
is underscore underscore represents a
single number or character now you might
be a bit confused here so let me just
explain with an example let's say if you
want to access the records of all those
employees whose name starts with k so
for that I'll write the query as select
star
from the table that is employee now
specify the condition where
employee name like is the keyword we
have to use here and within the single
quotes now we are displaying the records
of employees whose name starts with k
right so I'm taking K and mention the
percentage symbol
so let us execute this statement and see
the output
so it will display the details of all
those employees whose name starts with k
so there are total three employees in
the table whose name starts with care
similarly if you want to display the
records of those employees whose name
ends with a so for that we have to
mention percentage a so let me just
execute this statement and see the
output
so it will display the values of all
those employees whose name is ending
with the letter A so there are total uh
five employees in the table whose name
is ending with a so in this way you can
use the like operator which also uses
the where clause
so what is order by Clause the SQL order
by Clause allows you to sort the results
of a query based on a specific column or
group of columns that means it helps you
to reorder the data that is present in
the tables in one or more columns now
this sorting can be either ascending or
descending order let us now understand
the syntax of SQL order by Clause the
syntax is followed as SQL select column
1 column 2 up to n number of columns
from table name where condition order by
column AC or DAC so let me just explain
the syntax the column specified after
the order by keyword specifies the name
of the columns that are used to sort
data and after that we use two keywords
that is AC to represent the data in
ascending manner or dese to represent
the data in descending order
now the reason for using the order by
Clause is that the order that the data
shows in a database table is completely
random and sometimes this might not be
the order in which you would like to see
uh when we run our queries in the
database so for that purpose we use
order by Clause now that we've
understood what the SQL order by Clauses
let us jump into the execution part
as you can see MySQL workbench has
started and on the left side you can
view the database simply code which has
two tables that is employee and student
we are going to work on the employee
table now so first let me display the
records of all the employee details
present in the employee table for that I
am going to use this select statement
select star
from the table name that is employee
let me just execute this statement
so it will show me the results of
details of all the employees with their
employee ID employee name age
destination date of birth CT they belong
to and the salary they have so let us
just understand the basic query of order
by Clause now so the syntax is followed
as select
star
from the table that is employee
order by
salary
now this is a basic statement related to
order Y and let us execute this so it
will display the output and in a
particular order of the salary and if
you look at carefully it is displaying
in the uh ascending order now if no
keyword is specified after the column
based on which we have sorted the
records in a table the Sorting will be
done by default in ascending order so
with that uh that brings us to the to
our first order by statement that is
order by ascending
statement now the order by ascending
statement is used to sort the data in
ascending order so let us consider
another example here now if I want to
fetch the details of all the employees
and their employee names in ascending
order for that the following query would
be select
star
from the table that is employee
order by
employee name and mention the keyword
ASC
so let us execute this statement and see
the output so it will display the
results uh the employee names in the
ascending order that is in alphabetical
order starting from Akash
Ganesh and up until V so in this way you
can use the order by ascending statement
to display all your records in ascending
manner
similarly you can specify the where
condition here as well
let's say if I want to fetch the details
of all the employees from the employee
table in ascending order of their uh
employee name whose age is greater than
26 so for that the following query would
be select star from employee where age
greater than 26 order by employee name
as an ASC so let me execute this
statement so it will display the request
of all those employees whose age is more
than 26 and it'll this uh it will sort
the data of employee names in ascending
order
so in this way you can use the order by
ascending
getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit scale up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
now let us discuss about order by
descending statement the order by
descending statement is used to sort the
data in the descending order let us
understand this with an example let's
say if I want to display the details of
all the employees from the employee
table in descending order of their
salaries for that the following query
would be select star
from the table that is employee
order by
salary
and mention the keyword Des
so let us execute this statement and see
the output
so this will be the following output
wherein it will show the salaries of all
the employees in the descending order
that is from highest to lowest in this
case the first employee who is having
the highest salary is 65 000 and up
until the lowest salary 25 000. also
similarly you can specify the where
condition here also so if you want to
display the details of employees whose
employee ID is greater than let's say
one or six and want to sort their
service and descending order for that
I'll use the query as select start from
employee so mention the keyword where
employee ID
greater than one or six
so let us execute this statement and see
the output
so it will display the records of all
those employees uh who's having employed
in more than one or six and it will sort
the data of this salaries in descending
order that is from highest lowest again
so in this way you can use the order by
descending statement to display all your
records present in the table in an
ascending manner
let us now discuss the next order by
statement that is SQL order by random
and as well as limit statements the
order by random statement is used to
display the records uh present in the
table randomly and the Syntax for the
order by random is Select
star
from the table that is employee
order by mention the keyword
random is the function we are using here
so we have to mention R A and E
and let us execute the statement now so
it will display the records present in
the table in an in a random order
similarly we also have a limit statement
which is used to display only a specific
number of columns in the database table
so let us now look at the syntax of
order by limit
now let's say if I want to fetch the
first uh six employee details from the
table in descending order of their
salaries so the following query would be
select star
from employee
order by
salary I want to display the salaries
and descending order so I'm specifying
the desc keyword
and uh I'm limit I'm using the limit
function here
so let us display the output of this
query
so it will show me the random uh six
details of the employees in order of
their salaries from highest to lowest
that is in a descending order so in this
way you can also use order by random and
limit statement in your SQL queries
and finally let us now discuss about the
order by multiple statement in SQL till
now we have discussed only how to uh
fetch the records from only a single
table and sort them out but you can
fetch the rows by sorting multiple rows
in either ascending or descending order
using order by multiple statement so let
us understand this is an example let's
say if you want to fetch the details of
all the employees from the table in
ascending order of their designation as
well as descending order of their salary
then the following query would be select
star
from employee
order by
so we're taking the designation as
ascending order so designation
mention the keyword ASC
comma
unless salary
in descending manner so let us display
the uh
statement
so as you can see it will display uh the
designation in ascending order that is
business analyst and then customer care
data analyst HR and so on and their
respective salaries in descending form
so in this way you can fetch the data
from multiple rows using the multiple
statement in SQL
so what is SQL insert statement SQL
insert statement is widely used command
in SQL which is a part of data
manipulation language DML used by
various relational databases the insert
command is used for inserting one or
more rows into a database table with
specify table column values let us now
understand the syntax for insert
statement
now we have two types of syntaxes the
first method is insert into table name
values and within the brackets you have
to mention the values in this first
method there is no need to specify the
column names where the data will be
inserted you need to only insert their
values the second method specifies both
the column name and the values which you
want to insert and the syntax is insert
into which is the keyword we are using
after that we have to mention the table
name and within the brackets we have to
mention the columns and then values
values 1 values two values three and so
on up to our requirement so this was the
syntax uh let us take an example now
let's say I've created a table students
and I want to insert values into it so
the Syntax for inserting the values is
insert into table name I'm taking here
it as students and I'm mentioning The
Columns row number name age City and
inserting the values as roll number as 1
name as Rohan age as 22 and CDs
Hyderabad so in this way you can insert
values up to n number of rows into your
table
so now that we've understood and got an
idea of what SQL insert statement is let
us jump into MySQL workbench and do the
execution part choose from over 300
in-demand skills and get access to 1000
plus hours of video content for free
visit scale up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
as you can see MySQL workbench has
started and uh in order to insert the
values into the table we have to first
create a table so let us first create a
table and the syntax is followed as
create table which is the keyword that
we use and I'm creating a new table that
is customer and which is column names as
customer ID customer name their age
address the product they have purchased
under purchase date of the product and
I'm taking primary key here as customer
ID because it uniquely identifies each
and every record so let me just use the
select statement to display whether the
table is created or not select star
from the table that is customer
so as you can see our table is
successfully created with the column
names that we have specified
now that we've created a table let us
see how to insert the values into it for
that first let us discuss the insert
into value statement the insert into
value statement is used to insert either
all the column values or a specified
number of column values in the table
inserting only specified column data in
the row requires the column name should
be specified in the insert statement so
let's say if I want to insert all the
columns into the customer table the
following query would be
insert
into
table name which is the customer
now within the uh brackets we have to
mention the column names so the columns
that we have taken are customer ID
customer name
their age
address
product that they've purchased
on the purchased date
close the brackets now mention the
values keyword and again within the
brackets specify the values for each of
the columns so I'm taking a customer ID
as let's say 1011
comma customer name uh let's say Rahul
now make sure you uh mention the
character values inside the single
quotes and for integer values you need
not mention the single quotes
next there age let's say 25
comma address let's say uh the City they
belong to is the address so I'm taking
it as Hyderabad
comma makes the product that the
approaches let's say they have let's say
Rahul has purchased a phone as the
product
and finally purchased it
let's say 2022
March
and let's take date as uh 25.
so close the brackets and put the
semicolon
so let us execute this statement and see
so as you can see our query has been
successfully executed now to display the
values I'll use the select command again
so let us execute the statement so as
you can see the values have been
successfully inserted into our table uh
with respect to their columns as
customer ID customer name age address
product and the purchase date
so here we've inserted a row with all
the column values using the insert
statement similarly you can insert a row
with only specified column values as
well let's say if you want to insert
data for only the columns customer ID
customer name and the product they've
purchased and leaving the rest of the
columns as such the following query
would be
insert
into
table name
mention the table name that is customer
and within the brackets mention the
columns that you want to enter the
values so I'm only entering the values
for customer ID
customer name
and the product that they have purchased
and mention the keyword values
open the brackets and the specific
values as accordingly so I'm taking
customer IDs
thousand and uh 12 customer name let's
say copia
foreign
close the brackets mention the uh
semicolon and let us execute the
statement
so as you can see our query successfully
executed so let me display the values
and I'll use the select statement to
display the values so as you can see
only the customer ID customer name and
the product that they've purchased is
being displayed here and leaving the
rest of the columns that is age address
and the purchase date as null values so
in this way you can also insert values
into only the specified uh Columns of
the table next let us discuss about
insert multiple row statement
we can insert multiple rows in a single
insert statement at a time we can insert
multiple row values by grouping row
values with open and close brackets and
separating each row with a comma Now if
you want to insert let's say hundreds of
records and insert values into it it
will take a lot of time and it in the at
the same time it will become hectic if
you specify the column names each and
every time so in order to reduce that
and insert the values quickly we use
this multiple statement so let's say if
I want to insert uh new values insert
two rows of employee ID 1013 and 1014 so
the following query would be insert
into
customer uh that is the table name and
within the brackets uh
so before entering the values you have
to mention the keyword values
and you can directly enter the values
now without mentioning the column names
so as you can see I've inserted two rows
and the data into into the table so let
me just execute the statement and let us
see the output
so I said our query has been
successfully executed uh let me use the
select statement to display the new
values
so as you can see the customer ID 2013
and 2014 details uh has been displayed
so in this way you can use the uh
insert multiple statement to insert
multiple rows into the table so just
keep a note that make sure you insert
the values accordingly in the order of
the columns that you have taken in the
table so what is my SQL update statement
SQL update statement is used to update
the column values in the existing table
that means it is used to change the
values present in one or more rows in an
existing table now where Clause is used
in the update statement to update the
Matched rows that satisfy this condition
that we have specified in the where
Clause let us understand the syntax of
SQL update statement the syntax is
followed as update which is the keyword
followed by that we have to mention the
table name and then set column name is
equals to new value that is the value
that you want to change from the
previous value and after that you have
to mention the condition that is where
specify the condition to understand this
in a better way let us take an example
consider a table student which is having
columns roll number name age and city
now if I want to update the value of
City uh of the student who's having roll
number S3 from Mumbai to Chennai so the
following query would be update student
which is the table name set city is
equals to Chennai where roll number is
equals to 3. now if we execute this
statement this will be the output where
the city which is uh previously Mumbai
has been changed into Chennai so in this
way you can use the update statement now
that we have got an idea on what a SQL
update statement is and how it works let
us jump into MySQL workbench for the
execution part
as you can see MySQL workbench has
started and on the left side we can view
the tables that are present in our
database simply code so I'm going to
work on the employee table so let me
just display the records that are
present in the table for that I'll use
the select command select star
from the table that is employee so let
us execute the statement so it will
display the values of all the details of
the employees having their employee ID
employee name is the designation date of
birth city and salary now let us look at
the update statement first now if I want
to update the salary of the employee
who's having employee ID as let's say
106 to 35
000 now initially the employee ID 106
the employees having the salary 25000
now if I want to change into 30 000 the
following query would be update
table name that is employee
use the keyword set
mention the column name that you want to
change now we are changing the salary
set salary equals to from 25 000 so I'm
changing into 35 000.
where
employee ID equals to 1.6
so let us execute this statement and see
the output
so as you can see our statement is
successfully executed now let us use the
select command to display the records
so as you can see the employee ID uh 106
is having the salary as 135 000 it is
being now changed into 35 000 from 25
000. so in this way you can use the
update statement similarly uh you can
update multiple column values as well
let's say if I want to update the
designation and the salary of the
employee based on their employee ID for
that the following query would be
update table name employee
set designation
now if I want to change the designation
of the employee lohith who's having the
employee ID 103 from HR to senior HR
so I'll mention senior HR
as our new value
and also I want to change the salary so
put a comma
salary equals to let's say I want to
change the salary from 45 000 to 60 000.
foreign
employee ID equals to one not three
so let us execute the statement and see
the output
so our query has been successfully
executed so as you can see the employee
name uh lohith who's having employed 103
his designation has been changed to
senior HR and his salary has also being
changed into 60 000. so in this way you
can use uh update statement to change
multiple values that are present in the
uh columns as well
next let us discuss about update date
statement in SQL update date statement
is used to update the date and time
values in the existing table uh all the
data a date and time value should be
specified in the single quotes and you
can also mention the condition using the
where Clause let's take an example let's
say if I want to update the date of
birth of the employees uh who is having
employee ID 104 so the following query
would be
update
table name employee
set date of birth
now I am changing the date of birth of
the employee uh ID who's a 103 so I'm
changing the date of birth as 1996 Jan
first
mention the condition where
employee ID equals to 1.3 so let us
execute the statement and see the output
so our query has been successfully
executed now in the resultant uh table
you can see the date of birth of the
employee who's having employed is one or
three has been changed to 1996 January
1st in this way you can use the update
date statement to change the date values
let us take another example now if you
can also update multiple rows present in
the table let's say if you want to
update the date of joining of all those
employees who's having the designation
business analyst for that the following
query would be update
table name that is employee
set
date of joining
equals to I'm taking the date of joining
us uh first January 2022.
first January
2022.
now specify the condition where
designation
equals to business analyst
put a semicolon and execute this
statement now
so let us see the output
whether the values are changed or not as
you can see uh the date of joining for
all the business analysts that are
present in the table for example uh for
the employee id101
as well as 109 and 111 their date of
joining has been changed to uh Jan
January 1st 2022. in this way you can
use the update a date statement to
change the values of date and time that
are present in the table
so what is a square delete statement SQL
delete statement is one of the data
manipulation command DML that is used to
remove rows from a table that means you
will able to delete the existing records
from the table now you can either delete
a single row multiple rows or values
from the existing table depending on the
condition that is specified that means
build statement with where condition is
used to delete the rows that satisfies
the condition with where clause and the
remaining rows are not changed also
delete statement without where condition
is used to delete all the rows from the
table let us now understand the syntax
of SQL direct statement the syntax is
followed as delete from table name where
condition here where condition is
optional that means you can either use
it or you cannot use it
so let us take an example let's say if I
want to delete the details of the
employee from the employee table whose
employee ID is but not one so for that
the following syntax would be delete
from employee where employee ID equals
to 1.1 now if you execute this query it
will delete the details of that employee
who's having employed yes or not one in
this way you can use delete statement to
delete one or more rows from the
existing table now that we've got an id1
what SQL delete is let us jump directly
into the MySQL workbench and get into
the execution part as you can see MySQL
workbench has started and on the left
side you can view the various tables
that are present in our database simply
code so let us consider uh employee
table first as an example table to frame
SQL queries to perform various
operations using the delete statement
firstly uh so let me display the values
that are present in the employee table
for that I'm using the select statement
select star from the table that is
employee
so let me just execute this statement so
it will display the records of all the
employees uh their employee ID employee
name is destination date of birth city
and salary
so firstly uh let us see how to delete a
single Row from the given existing table
for that let me take an example let's
say if I want to delete one of the
employee details from the employee table
whose employee ID is let's say 1.8 for
that the following query would be
delete
from table name that is employee where
specify the condition
employee ID
equals to 107.
so let us execute the statement and see
the output
so our query has been successfully
executed let me use the select statement
to display the records and see whether
or not our record is deleted or not so
as you can clearly see uh 107 uh record
of the employee is missing from the
table that means we have successfully
deleted the record of that employee
who's having employee ID 1.7
let us now understand how to delete
multiple rows from the existing table
before that let me display the total
number of Records present in the table
so that we will have a clear idea on how
many records have been deleted after
executing the query for that I am using
a count statement select count
foreign
use the star operator
from the table that is employee
so we have total 14 records in the table
so let us now execute the statement uh
for that we will take an example let's
say if I want to delete multiple
employee details from the employee table
whose designation is let's say business
analyst so for that the following query
would be delete from
table that is employee
foreign
designation
equals to business analyst
[Music]
so let us execute the statement and see
the output
so as you can see our query has been
successfully executed let us again use
the account statement to see the values
that are deleted
foreign
that means there are total of three
employees whose designation as business
analyst and since we have specified the
condition where we want to delete only
those records from the table whose
designation is business analyst so in
this way you can delete multiple rows by
using the where condition statement
now similarly you can delete multiple
records from the table using multiple
conditions as well this can be done
using various operators like and or
between
Etc so let us take an example for that
uh suppose let's say if I want to delete
the employee details uh from the
employee table uh whose designation is
let's say data analyst and their salary
is less than 30 000 by using or operator
for that the following query would be
delete
from table that is employee
specify the condition where
designation
equals to data analyst
or
their salary
is less than 30 000.
so let us execute this statement now
so our query has been successfully
executed and let us see the output for
that I am using the select count
statement as well again
so as you can see only one record has
been deleted from the table that means
there is only a record of the employee
whose designation is either data analyst
or their salary is less than 30 000 so
in this way you can use uh multiple
conditions to delete the records from
table as well
let us not take another scenario let's
say if I want to delete a multiple
employee retails from the employee table
whose salary is in between let's say 30
000 and 45
000 for that I'll use the between
operator and the following query would
be delete
from the table employee
where
salary
between
is the operator that we have to use
thirty thousand
and 45
000.
so let us execute this statement and see
the output
so our query has been successfully
executed let me use the count statement
to display the number of Records now so
as you can see previously we had uh 10
records in the table now it has been
changed to four that means a total of
six records has been deleted from the
table wherein uh the salary of the
employees uh ranging between thirty
thousand and forty five thousand so in
this way you can use the delete
statement to delete multiple records
from the table by specifying the
multiple conditions
now we have seen how to delete a single
record or multiple or records or even
multiple records using multiple
conditions in the existing table
sometimes there might be a requirement
to delete the entire table data to free
up the memory or to allocate new data
into the table for that we use the
delete statement to delete the uh hold
records from the table as well for that
executing delete statement without the
where Clause delete the entire table
data so make sure you are careful while
using the delete statement because
you'll end up deleting the whole table
if you are using a without where Clause
let's say if I want to delete the
remaining records of the table from the
employee table I'll simply write the
query as delete
from table that is employed so let me
execute this statement and see the
output our query has been successfully
uh executed so let me just display the
records uh in the table for that I'll
use the select statement so as you can
see only the columns are being present
but the records that were present in
these columns have been completely
deleted uh using the delete statement so
in this way you can delete uh all the
records from the table without
specifying the condition using the where
clause
so what is SQL join in relational
databases the information you want to
retrieve is often stored in various
different tables in such scenarios
you'll need to join these tables to view
data in a much better way this is where
SQL join comes into picture SQL joints
is widely used clause in SQL essentially
to combine and retrieve data from two or
more tables based on related columns or
you can say common fields between them
now consider two tables here table one
has three columns ABC and three records
let's say for reference we'll take them
as one two three similarly table 2 also
has three columns BCD and three records
three four five here I have taken a
different color combination to represent
values that are present in various
columns now instead of querying each
table every time to retrieve data I'll
simply join these two tables and this
will be the following resultant table
also make sure when you are joining two
tables it should compile also really
have a common column here C is the
common field which forms the basis to
join these two tables here
why we use SQL join
flexibility SQL join allows the user to
access and manage records from more than
one table easily let us understand with
an example consider Mercedes-Benz which
is one of the leading car manufacturers
in the world and let's say they want to
access the records of the customers from
the database now in the database let us
take they have various different kinds
of tables such as customer table order
table vehicle table now if they want to
get the vehicle details of so and so
customer XYZ for that they have to first
query the customer table to get the
customer ID now if once if they get the
customer ID they have to query the order
table to get the order ID and finally
with the help of order ID they can get
the vehicle details now as you can see
this is a time taking process and hectic
at the same time now instead of that
I'll just simply join these tables which
will allow the users to combine rows
from two or more tables based on
different types of conditions in this
way you can access and manage your
records easily
data redundancy SQL join allows uh the
user to maintain data residency as much
as low as possible so that we can
maintain the amount of data anomalies
that is the duplicate values that are
repeated in various tables in the
database
finally efficiency SQL join executes the
query faster and shows the result much
more quickly because instead of using
various sub queries for each and every
table individually we can just simply
join uh two tables using as a simple
single query
types of SQL joints SQL joints are
broadly classified into four types they
are inner joint outer join left join
right join and additionally we also have
cross joint which is not that
significant uh in its usage because most
of the times we use the first four
joints now that we have gone through
different types of SQL joints let us
discuss each of them in detail
firstly let us discuss about SQL inner
joint SQL inner join joins two tables
based on a common column and selects
records that have matching values in
these columns now when the condition uh
is applied for these columns the query
checks all the rows of table 1 and table
two only the rows that satisfy the join
predicate are included in the resultant
table let us now understand the uh
syntax of the SQL inner joint the syntax
is followed as select table one dot
column one table one dot column two
table2. column one and so on from table
1 in a join table 2 on table one dot
column equals to table 2 dot column now
inner joint syntax basically Compares
rows of table one with table two to
check if any anything matches based on
the condition provided in the on clause
and when the condition is met it returns
matched arrows in both tables with the
selected columns in the select clause
let us now discuss about the SQL outer
join SQL outer join or else it is called
as SQL full join or full outer join is
used to get all the rows which are
present in both the tables that means it
will return all the records which are
present in either left table that is the
table one or the right table that is
table two even if there are no matching
records present in both the tables let
us now understand the syntax the syntax
remains same that is selectable one dot
column one table one dot column two and
so on up to table 2 dot column 2 from
table 1 full outer join is the keyword
that we use here table two on table1 dot
column equals to table two dot column
now here you have to mention the uh the
same or the similar column name in the
uh after the on predicate statement
next we have SQL left join left outer
join also known as left join results in
a table containing all the rows from the
table on the left side of the join that
is the first table and only the rows
that satisfy the joint condition from
the table on the right side of the joint
that is the second table any missing
values uh for the rows from the right
table in the result of the joint tables
are represented by null values let's
look at the syntax the syntax is
followed as select column list that is
the column that you want to display in
your table now make sure you maintain
the syntax of the columnist that is the
table name dot column name otherwise it
will throw an error so let me just
repeat the syntax the syntax is Select
column lists from table 1 the keyword
that we use here is left join table 2 on
table one dot column equals to table2
dot column so in this way you can use
the left join to display the records
next finally we have the SQL right join
now right join or right outer join is uh
opposite to that of the left outer join
now it follows the same rules as the
left join and the only difference is
that all the rows from the right table
and only the conditions satisfying the
rows from the left table are present in
the resultant table that means it will
return all the rows from the right table
and all the matching records that are
present in the left table the syntax
Remains the Same that is Select column
list that you want to display in your
table from table one right join is the
keyword we use table 2 on table one dot
column equals to table 2 dot column now
to sum up all these different SQL joints
and how they work I've taken a graphical
representation of two different tables
here which will help us visualize the
real-time working of SQL joins now
consider table 1 here which is columns A
and B and Records uh two different
records let's say record zero record one
and similarly we have table 2 which have
columns A and C and two records that is
record zero and record two now if you
apply left join and by the definition of
left join it will only return those
values which will which are present in
the left table and the matching records
that are present in the right table now
here the uh matching value that are
present in both the tables is 0 and the
require values that are present in the
left table is one and if you consider
the right join it will match the request
from both the tables and it will display
the only the values from the right table
that is the reason it is being displayed
uh the record 0 and the record two and
if you look at the inner join it will
match the values from both the tables
now the common value that is present in
both the tables is record zero and if
you finally look at the outer join it
will return all the values from both the
tables irrespective if they are matching
or not that is the reason uh all the
records that is record zero record one
and record two are being displayed and
with that we have come to the end of
today's session that was all about SQL
joins stay tuned uh for more upcoming
videos awaren will execute all these
types of joints in MySQL workbench using
various examples
so what is SQL inner joint using the
inner join the tables are combined on
the basis of uh condition also known as
The Joint predicate this condition is
applied on The Columns of both the
tables on either side of the join Clause
the query checks all the rows of table 1
and table 2. now it will display only
those values that satisfy the joint
predicate in the resultant table that
means it finds the matching values or
the uh matching records that are found
in both the tables for example I have a
table a which is records one two three
four and in table B I have records three
four five six now if you join these two
tables now the resultant output output
will be 3 and 4 because these are only
two records that are present in both the
tables that is the table is matching the
common values that are present in both
the tables let us now understand the
syntax of SQL inner join the syntax is
followed as select table one dot column
one table one dot column two table 2 dot
column two and so on from table one
inner join is the keyword we have to use
table 2 on table one dot column equals
to table 2 dot column here after the
join expression we are mentioning The
Columns uh from which we want to match
the both the tables
now that we have understood uh what is
SQL in a join let us jump into MySQL
workbench and execute it with the help
of an example
as you can see MySQL workbench has
started and on the left side you can see
the database that is simply code and the
various tables that are present in our
database simply code like we have
customer table Department table employee
table order stable Etc now to perform
the SQL in a join operations I will use
the employee table Department table and
the projects table now let us display
the values that are present in the table
so that we have to use the select
statement or you can directly click on
this table icon here so first let us
display the values present in the
employee table the employee table has
the following Fields such as employee ID
employee name age designation the city
they belong to salary date of joining
and their Department ID next let us
display the values that are present in
the department table the department
table has two fields that is Department
ID and Department name and finally let
us display the values present in the
projects table the projects table has
the project ID employee ID the project
name and the project manager
now let's say we have a query here which
says to retrieve the employee details
and the department they are working in
now before we write a query we have to
check uh for all those tables in which
these informations are present in for
example I can get the employee details
from the employee table such as their
employee ID employee name the
designation salary and so on and also I
can get the Department details from the
Department table now the expected uh
query or the resultant table is based on
these two tables now in order to
retrieve the records from these two
different tables I need to connect them
in other words we have to join these two
tables this is where the inner join
comes into picture with the help of
inner join we can connect these two
tables and we can retrieve all those
matching records from those tables now
the following query uh would be for the
inner join as
select mention the column names that you
want to display now I want I will
display the employee ID
so employee
dot employee ID I'll also display the
employee name so employee dot employee
name
I'll also display the employee
designation
so I am taking employee.designation
now I'll also retrieve the information
from the Department so I'll have to
mention the department table here as
well so Department
dot Department ID
right now the query is continued as from
the table table one that is employee
I'll just write in the next send uh next
sentence from employee
inner join is the keyword we have to use
here and mentioned the second table that
is
Department
on which is the keyword and mention are
the condition on the basis of which you
are connecting these two tables now I'm
connecting the employee and the
department table with the hemp with the
help of the department ID so I'll
mention employee Dot
in the apartment ID
equals to
Department
dot Department ID
so let us now execute this statement and
see the output
so as you can clearly see it is
displaying the values of employee ID
employee name the designation and the
department ID as well now as it clear
clearly you can see that the join
condition is specified in the inner join
Clause after the on keyword as the
expression now for each row in the Pro
in the employee table the query finds a
corresponding Row in the department
table that has the same matching values
based on which we have mentioned here
that is the department ID now if there
is a match between two rows in both the
tables it returns all those rows that
contains columns that we have specified
for example we have specified employee
ID name designation and the department
that they belong to
so in this way you can use the inner
join to get the records from both the
tables
also you can get the Department name as
well by uh mentioning the department
names in the uh query the department
name dot department DOT Department name
now this will display uh the records of
the department name that are present in
the department table as well
so as you can see uh there are total of
uh six records and the employee details
and the department names that they are
working in and also if you uh notice
there are only six records that are
present in a resultant table when we
have a total of 20 records that are
present in the employee table that's
because the energy only matches those
records from those columns that are
having matching values from both the
tables and and also the condition that
we have specified uh in our in a joint
statement
similarly let us look at another query
which says to retrieve the employee
details project they are working on and
the project manager assisting them now
for this to get the employee details
again I'll again use the employee table
and to get the details of the uh project
our name and the project manager's name
I'll use the project table so the
following query would be select e dot
employee ID now here I have taken the
Alias name for the tables that is you
can mention a temporary name for the
tables that you have chosen so for
employee table I'm taking as e and for
projects I'm taking SP in order to save
time and uh to save time we'll write in
this way so the query is followed as
select e dot employee ID e dot employee
name p dot project name p dot project
manager from the first table that is
employee
e inner join projects we have taken the
name as p on E dot employee ID is equals
to P dot employee ID which is the common
column from which we get the matching
values from both the tables let us now
execute uh this statement and see the
output
so as you can see we can uh we are able
to retrieve the employee ID employee
name project name that the employee is
working on and the project manager that
uh have been assigned to these employees
and if you notice uh carefully here like
some of the employees who are having
employee ID like thousand and twelve
thousand and thirteen thousand eighteen
sixteen uh there have no project names
assigned to their uh to their names that
this is because even though we have all
the details of employees uh in the
employee table we do not have the data
that that is being stored in the
projects table that is the reason uh
only a limited number of records are
being shown and as per the definition of
inner join it will re fetch only those
records which have matching values from
both the tables
so in this way you can join uh two or
more tables using the inner join
statement and with that we have come to
the end of today's session that was all
about SQL inner joint now before getting
into the execution part let us just
quickly discuss what is SQL Auto joint
the outer join statement returns all
those records which are present in
either the left table or the right table
now for example if you consider uh the
table here a which has records one two
three four and the table B which has
records three four five six now if you
apply the full outer join to these two
tables it will display all the records
that is one two three and up to 6.
now let us discuss the syntax of SQL
outer join the syntax is followed as
select table one dot column one table
one dot column two table two dot column
one and so on these are basically the
columns that you want to display in your
resultant table from table one full
outer join table 2 on table one dot
column equals to table two dot column
now as far as MySQL concern this syntax
is not applicable now if you're working
on other databases like postview SQL and
Microsoft SQL Server you can apply this
uh syntax but if you're working on MySQL
workbench there is a different syntax
which I'll be discussing in a while so
now that we have understood what is SQL
Auto join let us jump into MySQL
workbench for the execution part
as you can see MySQL workbench has
started and on the home page uh on the
left side you can view the databases and
tables now I've created uh certain
tables uh time for time being so let me
just display the values that are present
in these tables now in order to execute
the I scale outer join we'll consider
the employee table as well as the
project tables so let me just display
the values present in the employee table
I'll use the select operator to display
those values select start from
employee
foreign
so it will display the records of all
those employees having employee ID
employee name is the designation City
salary date of joining and their
Department ID now similarly I'll display
the records of projects let me just take
another tab
I'll use again the select statement to
display the records
start from projects
now if you execute this statement it
will display the project ID employee ID
project name and the project manager
details now let's say if I want to fetch
the details of all the employees from
the employee table and the project
details they are working on from the
projects table I'll have to use the full
join to retrieve information from both
the tables now as discussed earlier the
full auto join keyword is not applicable
to mySQL database so I'll have to
implement a new logic here which is
quite simple as you know the full outer
join is the result of combining the left
and right table so we'll first use the
left join then we'll use the right join
and finally we'll use the union operator
which is used to combine the resultant
set of two or more select statements and
uh and execute it in a single statement
by the way we haven't executed left and
right join yet so stay tuned for the
upcoming videos on both these joints as
well if getting your learning started is
half the battle what if you could do
that for free visit scale up by Sim
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more
so the following query would be let me
let me another tab again
now I mention all those column details
that you want to display in your
resultant table so I want to display the
employee ID employee name project name
and the project manager's name as well
so you have to mention the column names
in the format of table name dot column
name so
I'm taking the uh Alias name for the
employee table as e so e dot employee ID
comma e dot employee name
now for the projects table I am taking
the Alias name as B
so P Dot
project name
comma
P Dot
project manager's name
from the table that is uh project tables
sorry the first table is employee right
so we'll mention the employee now use
the left join keyword
left join on projects
on now I have to mention the condition
uh on the basis of which you're
connecting these two tables now if you
look at the two tables we have the
employee ID that is present in both the
tables so that will be the common
attribute to specify this condition here
so e Dot
employee ID equals to P dot employee ID
now I'll just copy paste this same
statement
and uh instead of using the left join
I'll use the right join keyword so let's
just replace the left join keyword with
the right join
and I'll mention the union operator
keyword to join these two tables so
that's it guys uh this is how you can uh
use the full outer join in MySQL
workbench now let us just execute this
statement and see the output
uh so there's a bit of error let me just
check it once
so I forgot to mention the Alias name
here for both the table so that is why
it is throwing an error so as you can
see this is our output and you can
clearly see that the record from both
the tables that is the left table which
is employee and the right table which is
projects are being displayed here now
unlike the inner join which only fetches
those records which have matching values
in both the tables full outer join
retrieves all the values irrespective of
whether they are matching or not for
instance if you look at the employees
having employee IDs here one or 1012
1013
1016 and as well as 1018 we have uh
their information present in table one
that is the employee table here but we
do not have their information in the
projects table here and similarly
employees having employee IDs like 1022
000 and 23 and 1024 their information is
present in the projects table but it is
not in present in the first table that
is employee you can see only the
employee details are having their
employees ID up to 1020 are being
displayed in the employee table also if
you notice the resultant table here guys
uh some of the employees like kirti
Varon and uh
nithya have no uh projects assigned to
their name that's why we have null
values in the project name column that's
because though the records are present
in the employees table but their
employees IDs are not present in the
project table that means all these
employees are yet to be assigned a new
project so if the value is present in
both the tables that does not match it
will simply just return null values
similarly we can see the other three
projects that are present uh in the
table but there is no sign of employee
details here be it their employee ID or
employee name and it will just simply
return the null values again here
because we do not have the employee
information in the first stable employee
even though their IDs are mentioned in
the project table and hence it will only
return null values now suppose this is
just a demo table having around 20 or 25
records but if you consider a company's
database in real life it will have
thousands of Records in order to access
and manage various database tables and
fetch information from those tables all
together it becomes quite difficult
right so this is why we use full join to
connect the tables and retrieve each and
every information from them and in if
any column has null values they can just
simply update those rows or even delete
them as per the requirement let's just
have a quick recap on what is SQL left
join so SQL left outer join also known
as left join results in a table
containing all the rows from the table
on the left side of the join that is the
first table and only the rows that
satisfy the join condition from the
table on the right side of the join that
is the second table the missing values
for the rows from the right table in the
resultant table of the join are
represented by null values for example
if you consider here two tables that is
table a and table B which is values one
two three four in table a and three four
five six in table B now if you apply
left join for both these tables or it
will display only the values from the
left table that is 1 2 and the matching
values from the right table that is 3 4.
so the resultant table will be 1 2 3 4.
let us now understand the syntax of the
sqlf join statement the syntax is
followed as select column lists these
These are basically the list the columns
that you want to display in a resultant
table from table one left join which is
the keyword we are using here table two
on table one dot column equals to
table2.com now yeah here you have to
mention the uh a common attribute on the
basis of which you're joining these two
tables so now that we've understood
about SK left join let us now jump into
MySQL workbench to execute this using
various examples
as you can see MySQL workbench has
started and on the home page on the left
side in the schema section you can view
the databases and the tables that are
present so in this case we have the
database simplicode and various tables
in that such as customer Department
table employee orders and Etc now in
order to execute this uh left join
statement will will be going to use
customer and the order stable statement
tables so let me just display the values
from both these tables for that I'll use
the select Clause select star
from customer
which is the table name so let us just
execute
so as you can see the customer table has
various Fields such as customer ID
customer name age address and their
phone numbers similarly let us go to
another Tab and display the values that
are present in order statement
select start from the table that is
orders
so let us execute the statement so as
you can see in the output the orders
table has various Fields such as product
ID customer ID product name that is the
product I've purchased quantity the
price of the product and the purchase
date
now let's say if I want to fetch the
details of all the customers and the
product details that they've purchased
I'll have to connect these two tables
that is customer and the orders table to
get the resultant table now for that
I'll use the left join statement so let
me just take another Tab and execute the
statement so the following query would
be select mention the column names that
you want to fetch in your resultant
table so I'm going to take here Alias
name for both the customer and the
orders table as C and O that's because
uh instead of writing the full name of
the tables each and every time you can
just simply use an alias name which is a
temporary name which will save time as
well so for customer uh table I'm taking
as C so I want to display the customer
ID
so C Dot
customer ID
I want to display the customer name
customers address so C dot address
now from the orders table I want to uh
mention the products name that they've
purchased the quantity price and
purchase date
so we have taken o as the alliance name
for our table so o dot purchase name
sorry product name
that they have purchased
I also want to display the quantity so o
dot quantity
its price as well o dot price
and the purchase date oh Dot
purchase date
from the table first table that is
customer
mention the Alias name c
left join which is the keyword
on the second table that is orders
oh
on mention the condition on which you
are joining these two tables so as you
can see we can find the customer ID and
the customer ID in both the customer and
the orders table so we'll mention the
customer ID as the column common
attribute here so C Dot customer ID
equals to
O DOT
customer ID so let us just execute the
statement and see the output
so as you can see it will display the
customer ID customer name address
product name quantity price and purchase
date of the customers in a resultant
table now let us understand what exactly
are the left join statement is doing
here firstly the database checks each
and every row of the table and looks for
a match in the right table based on the
related columns now if a match is found
the data from the right table is added
to the corresponding row of the left
table now you can see uh customers
having customer ID one zero one one zero
one zero one two zero one zero one three
zero and one zero one three one four
zero we have the details present in the
first table as well as the second table
that is
orders so it will display all those
records and then if there are multiple
matches now in this case we can see a
customer name Ajay is having two
different uh Records who has bought sofa
set and a TV so the rows in the left
table are duplicated here that is the
records are repeated in the resultant
table in order uh to include all the
records from the right table
so now uh for all the
columns that you have fetched from the
right table that is orders which is not
satisfying the join conditions then the
values present in the columns will be
resultant as null that means if there is
no matching value found from the right
table it'll simply retain the row from
the left table and inserts null into the
corresponding Columns of the right table
now let me just explain this now if you
see here the customer uh customers like
others and pranay who are having details
in the first table that is a customer
table but they do not have their details
in the Pro order stable so there is no
sign of any their customer ID in the
order table that's why we do not have
their uh details present in the uh
resultant table so it will just show the
null values here
so basically left join is a combination
of inner join we can say because it just
checks the matching values from both the
tables first and then it will check for
any additional or extra values that are
left out from the left table that is the
table one now you might have a question
that when to use and why to use the left
join like there are times when you want
to keep rows from the first table that
don't have any corresponding records in
the second table now if you in this case
if you consider our example we might
want to see information about all the
customers in a resultant table even if
they didn't place any orders so in that
case we'll use the left join which will
be used to combine data from two tables
so that all the rows from the left table
are included in the resultant set even
if there is no matching value from the
right table it follows the same rule as
the left join and the only difference is
that all the rows from the right table
and only the condition satisfying rows
from the left table are present in the
resultant table
so basically the right join returns all
the records from the right table and
only the matching records from the left
table are satisfying the condition for
example let's say we have two tables
table a and table B and when the Left
Right join is applied to the two tables
it would give all the records from the
table B and only the matching records
from the table a that is table one
let us now look at the syntax of SQL
right joint the syntax is same and it is
followed as select table one dot column
one table one dot column two table two
dot column one and so on these are
basically the columns that you want to
display in a resultant table from table
one right join is the keyword we use
here table two on table one dot column
equals to table two dot column
now that we have understood what is SQL
right join let us jump into MySQL
workbench for the execution part
choose from over 300 in-demand skills
and get access to 1 000 Plus hours of
video content for free visit skillup by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more
so MySQL workbench has started and on
the left side you can view the database
simply code which has various tables
such as customer Department employee
orders now for time being I've already
created and inserted values into all
these tables and to in order to execute
the SQL right join we are going to use
the customer table and the orders table
so let me just display the values that
are present in these tables for that I
am going to use this select statement
select star
from the customer table
so as you can see the customer table has
various Fields such as customer ID
customer name their age their address
and the phone number similarly let us
just retrieve the request from the
orders table as well
select
star
from orders table
so the orders table has of various
columns such as product ID customer ID
product name that they've purchased
quantity price of the product and the
purchased date now if I want to join
these two tables I am going to use the
right join statement so the following
query would be
select now I am going to use a layer's
name for both these tables for customer
table I am going to take as C and for
orders table I'm going to take as o now
I want to display uh The Columns from
the customer table uh only so the tables
are the columns are customer name I want
to display their address as well so
mention the column names customer name
C dot address
now from orders table I am going to
display the product name that they've
purchased quantity price and purchase
date
so O DOT
product name
comma O DOT
quantity
comma o dot price
and finally o dot purchase date
from the table one that is customer
mention the keyword right join
mention the second table name that is
orders
on mention the condition on which you're
joining these two tables now now as you
can see we have customer ID as well as
the customer ID present in both the
table customers and orders so we'll be
taking the customer ID here as the
common column on C Dot customer ID
equals to O DOT
customer ID
let us now execute the statement and see
the output
so there is just an error let me check
okay I didn't mention the Alias name
here so mention the Alias name for both
the tables
I guess it will display now
okay yeah
so as you can see this is our resultant
table which uh basically displays the
various columns customer name their
address product name quantity price and
purchase date let us now understand what
exactly the right join is performing
here now basically the right join Clause
starts selecting the data from the right
table and matches it with the rows from
the left table the right join returns a
resultant table that includes all the
rows in the right table whether or not
they are having matching rows from the
left table now if a row in the right
table does not have any matching rows
from the left table The Columns of the
left table in the resultant set will
have null values now clearly the SQL
statement would return all the rows from
the orders table here as you can see we
have all the details like AC TV phone
cooker car sofa set and phone bike Etc
in our orders table so it it is
basically retrieving all the data from
the right table and only those rows from
the customer table where The Joint
condition is being satisfied now it will
only display the matching values here
because can you as you can see we have
customer
id101101012010130 so basically we have
one total six records and we have
them in the resultant table as well now
if you consider the resultant table here
it is showing null values for some of
the customer names and address because
though we have the product names
mentioned in the orders table here for
example the product name car sofa set
bike and the customer IDs are one zero
one four zero one zero one six zero and
one zero one nine zero but we do not
have their uh details present in the
customer table and that is the reason we
that it is showing is null here
so in this way you can use the SQL right
join statement now you might have a
doubt that when to use and why to use
the right time statement again it will
depend on your own requirement for
instance if you want to keep the records
from the second table that do not have
any corresponding records from the first
table in that case we will use the right
join also another point to be noted here
that the table that you have mentioned
to the right side of the right join
keyword that is we have taken here
orders right so it will give the highest
priority to this table and it will
display all the records from the orders
table here even if they do not have any
matching values similarly just take
another scenario here I'm just
interchanging the tables here like the
first table I'm taking is orders and the
second table I'm taking as customers so
when we execute the statement it will
display the records from all the records
from the customer table that is the
first table and even if they do not have
the matching values it will just display
the null values here that's because now
if you consider other
we have their details uh in the employee
in the customer table but we do not have
their information present in the orders
table and that's the reason we can see
that only their details are present but
they do not have the orders details that
we have present here
so in this way you can use the right SQL
join statement as well so with that we
have come to the end of session guys
that was all about the SQL write join
statement to learn more about the SQL
Concepts and about SQL joints you can
check out our video on our Channel
complete SQL tutorial uh 2022 for
beginners which will help you out so
what are keys in SQL SQL Keys plays an
important role in relational databases
it is used for identifying unique rows
from table a key is a subset of columns
in a table that allows a road to be
uniquely identified so a key can be more
than just a column and every Row in the
table will have a unique value for the
key or a unique combination of values if
the key consists of more than just one
column
now as you know databases are used to
store massive amounts of information
which is stored across multiple tables
now each table might be having more than
thousands of Records or rows now
needless to say there will be many
duplicate rows with redundant
information so how do we deal with that
now how do we manage these records that
are storing only unique data now for
that we might need a combination of one
or more columns in the database table to
uniquely identify a row in a database
so in that case we use the SQL Keys now
SQL Keys creates constraints that can be
used to enforce data Integrity in SQL
now as you know a database must adhere
to certain properties to maintain
integrity and quality of the data that
is storing keys and constraints are
rules that Define what data values are
allowed in certain data columns there
are an important database concept as
well as for SQL and are part of database
schema definition defining keys and
constraints is part of database design
process and ensures that data within a
database is reliable and maintains since
integrity
let us now understand why we use SQL
Keys SQL Keys identify each record
separately and uniquely now a key is
used in the definition of various kinds
of Integrity constraints and a table in
a database represents a collection of
Records or events for a particular
relation now since there are thousands
and thousands of such records some of
which may be duplicated now in order to
uh identify these records uniquely and
separately we need SQL keys
SQL Keys allows user to establish and
identify a relationship between the
tables as well and finally SQL Keys
access or manages the store data quickly
and smoothly
now that we have understood what SQL
keys are and why we use them let us now
discuss some of the various types of
keys in SQL SQL keys are broadly
classified into various types such as
primary key Super Key candidate key
alternate key composite key foreign key
now let us discuss each and every type
of key in detail with an example
firstly let us look at what exactly is
primary key
the primary key is one of the most
important and commonly used SQL keys in
the databases the primary key is in SQL
is a single or a group of fields or
columns that can uniquely identify a row
in a dipl putting it simply it is a
column that accepts unique values for
each row therefore whenever you use the
insert into command to insert new values
in a table the value for a primary key
column or columns need to be unique now
primary key advantages is mainly it
uniquely identifies each row of a table
also it gets a unique index for each
primary key column that helps with
faster access
now there are properties uh which are
helpful of SQL primary key they are it
enforces uniqueness by not accepting any
duplicate values and a primary key also
uniquely identifies each field and can
take only one primary key for a table
now a primary key column cannot accept
null values as well
let us consider an example here consider
student table which is having various
Fields such as student ID role number
name class section age and address now
if you look at the table clearly student
ID can be taken as a primary key here
also you can take the roll number but
since we are taking the records of all
the students in a school that's why we
are taking the student ID as the primary
key now if you take the records of the
students for a particular class then you
can take the roll number as a primary
key as well
let us now understand the syntax of
primary key Now to create a new table
with a column defined as a primary key
you can use the keyword primary key at
the end of the definition of that column
and the syntax is create table table
name and within the parenthesis mention
the column names and its column types
and finally mention the primary key
inside the brackets so for example if I
want to create a table which is having
ID last name first name and age in that
I am going to use the primary key here
as ID so in this way you can use the
primary key in SQL
next let us discuss about the candidate
key a candidate key is defined as set of
one or more columns that can identify or
record uniquely in a table so basically
candid key is a Super Key with no
repeated attributes by the way uh we'll
discuss about the super key in a while
uh the primary key should be selected
from all the candidate keys and every
table must have at least a single
candidate key and a table can have
multiple candidate keys but only a
single primary key now candid key
shouldn't have redundant arables that
means it should not have any duplicate
values in the table now unlike primary
key the attributes of candidate key can
contain null values and as discussed a
table can have more than one candidate
keys and it is also called as the
minimal Super Key guys that's because we
select a candidate key from a set of
super Keys such that the selected
candidate key is the minimum attribute
required to uniquely identify the rows
in a table so that let us understand
this with an example consider the
students table here which is having
various columns such as student ID role
number name age address and contact now
as you know we can take the student ID
as the primary key and with that we can
take the roll number as well as the
contact of the students as the candidate
key here because all these three columns
alone can uniquely satisfy the condition
of the candidate key here so in this way
we can use the candidate keys in x
next let us discuss about alternate key
in SQL
alternate key or subset of candidate
keys that can also uniquely identify
tuples in a table which are not chosen
as primary key for example consider the
employee table here which has columns
employee ID employee name job department
number par number other number and uan
now if you look at the table uh The
Columns that can uniquely identify each
and every record are basically employee
ID pan number other number and UA number
now since we have taken the employee ID
as a primary key and the rest of all the
columns that are not chosen as a primary
key are considered to be alternate keys
so in this case we can take the pan
number other number UN number as our
alternate keys next let us discuss about
the super key in SQL super key is
another important key that is used
day-to-day usage and SQL databases a
Super Key or a simple key is a
combination of all possible attributes
which can use uniquely identify the row
or tuples in a table that means that a
Super Key may have some extra attributes
which isn't necessary for uniquely
identifying the rows in the table
a Super Key is a in SQL is a superset of
primary key candidate key and Alternate
key that means basically it is a
combination of all the keys such as
primary candidate and Alternate Keys as
discussed super key will have additional
attributes that are not needed for any
unique identification and finally super
keys with the least number of attributes
form the candidate keys
so let us take an example again consider
the employee table here and if you look
at the possible keys that will be for
super keys are employee ID part number
employee ID other number employee ID uan
number other number pan number uen other
number uan employee ID par number as
well as un and finally part number other
number and uan
now all the above keys are able to
uniquely identify each row so each of
these Keys is a Super Key now again in
this example we have like more than uh
six Super keys but all of them cannot
become a candidate key here only those
super Keys would become a candidate key
which have no redundant attribute for
example uh if you take employee ID part
number this key cannot be considered as
a candidate key because uh when we take
this subset of this key we get two
attributes that is employee ID as well
as the pan number now each of these
attributes is basically a candidate key
so it is a minimal super key but hence
this key is not a candidate key
and finally let us discuss about the
foreign knsql a foreign key is a column
or combination of columns that is used
to establish and force a link between
the data in two tables to control the
data that can be stored in the foreign
key table in a foreign key reference a
link is created between two tables and
the column or columns hold the primary
key value for one table and the
referenced by the column or columns in
other table now this column becomes a
foreign key in the second table the
table with the foreign key is known as
the child table and the table with the
primary key is known as the referenced
or parent table
now as foreign key has bought the
referential Integrity in SQL uh which
means that it requires that a foreign
key must have a matching primary key or
it must be null this constraint is
specified between two tables that is
parent and child and it maintains the
correspondence between the rows in these
tables it means that the reference from
a row in one table to another table must
be valid now the foreign key uh helps in
maintaining the data Integrity of the
table and allows easy navigation between
two instances or attributes it is also
used in SQL to make the database data
consistent and it is also used for the
prevention of any action that may result
in destruction of relation between these
two tables
let us understand this with an example
now consider two tables here employee
and Department the employee table has
employee ID employee name job department
number pan number other number and U.N
number and the department table has
employee ID and the department name now
clearly the employee ID which is the
primary key in the first table employee
is acting as a Crosser friends for the
Department table that is uh the employee
ID acts as the foreign key here for the
Department table
so in this way you can use the foreign
key in SQL
and similarly we have some other types
of keys in SQL which are not that
significant in its usage the first one
being is unique key a unique key same as
a primary key with the difference being
the existence of one null value in a
table field or a row for example
consider a student table having student
ID roll number and its name now for some
reasons if the student is leaving the
school then his roll number might be
deleted although his student ID will be
preserved for further assistance so
since there is a null value in roll
number it can be considered as a unique
key and student ID can be considered as
a primary key similarly we have
composite key a composite key is a
combination of two or more attributes
that can together uh can uniquely
identify a tuple in a table
and that brings us to the end of today's
session uh that was all about uh the SQL
keys so let us just quickly recap what
we have discussed uh the different types
of keys so to summarize this I've
created a table here employee ID
employee name other passport department
ID which is the table one that is
employee table and we have Department
idea and Department columns in the
second table that is Department table
now you are clearly employee ID is the
primary key since it uniquely identifies
each and every record in the table and
employee ID other number password can be
taken as candidate keys because they are
set of more than one primary keys since
though so they can be considered as the
candidate key here now alternate Keys
which are other than the primary key
that is employee ID so I am taking other
card and passport as the alternate Keys
here now the combination of all these
keys that such as primary key candidate
key alternate key forms are super key
now I am taking the passport as the
unique sense and not but everyone has a
passport to their name so I'm taking the
passport attribute here as the unique
key and finally the foreign case the
department ID as it points uh to the
reference to the second table that is
Department table
so in this way you can use the SQL Keys
accordingly now we have Akash who is
basically from a non-technical
background and wants to upskill his
career as a business analyst and for
that his learning SQL now while learning
these SQL concept Concepts is unable to
understand the aggregate functions in
SQL so he turns up to his friend Rohan
for help now Rohan is already a
certified data analyst uh starts
explaining him about the aggregate
functions in SQL the aggregate functions
in SQL are used to perform calculations
on multiple rows of single column and
returns a single value
now in SQL each query delivers filtered
results of groups of values as well as
field values now SQL has these aggregate
functions that can be used to summarize
these enormous amount of data that is
stored in the table now for an entire
group or table this function can
generate a single value they work with
groups of rows and returns all the
possible results based on these fields
or columns
these aggregate functions are basically
used with the group by and having clause
in the select statement the group by
Clause basically divides the result set
into groups of values and aggregate
functions returns a single value for
each groups that means the group by
basically identifies all their records
that are present in a particular field
or a column and combines them into a
single set now that we have understood
what are aggregate functions let us go
through the various aggregate functions
that are present in SQL now in SQL there
are broadly five types of aggregate
functions they are count some average
Max and minimum let us discuss about
them in detail firstly let us discuss
about the count function
the SQL count function Returns the
number of rows in a table satisfying the
criteria specified in the where Clause
it sets the number of rows or non-null
column values only let us look at the
syntax the syntax is followed as select
count which is the keyword column name
from table name where condition Group by
column and order by column
next let us discuss about the sum
function in SQL
the sum function Returns the total
summation of the value of a specified
column value sum performs only on
numeric columns only so
sum does not consider null values it has
optional arguments like all distinct all
keyword is used to take all the values
in the specified column now if you
specify distinct keyword it will remove
all the duplicate values or the
Redundant values
let's look at the syntax the syntax is
followed as select some column name from
table name where condition Group by
column and order by column
next let us look at the average function
the SQL average function calculates the
average value of columns of numeric
types it Returns the average of all null
values and the syntax is similar to that
of count as well as the sum instead of
the count and the sum keyword you have
to replace it with the average keyword
and the syntax is followed as select
average column name from table name
where condition you can also specify the
group by and the order by function as
per your requirement here as well
next we have the max function the SQL
Max function is used to find the maximum
value or highest value of a certain
column or expression this function is
useful to determine the largest of all
the selected values of a column and the
syntax remain the same which is Select
Max is the keyword we use here column
name from table name you can specify the
condition as per your requirement using
the where clause and you can use the
group by function as well
and finally that brings us to the
minimum function which is opposite to
that of Maximum function and the
aggregate SQL minimum function is used
to find the minimum value or the lowest
value of a column or an expression this
function is useful to determine the
smallest of all the selected values of a
particular column or a field
and the syntax Remains the Same Again
instead of uh instead of Max you have to
use the minimum keyword here and the
syntax is followed as select minimum
column name from table name where
condition and group by condition as well
so now that we've understood all these
different types of aggregate functions
let us jump into MySQL workbench for
execution part
as you can see MySQL workbench has
started and on the home page to the left
side we have the simply code database
which has various tables such as
customer Department employee orders and
Etc now as far as the SQL aggregate
functions are concerned we are going to
use the restaurant order stable here so
let me just display the records that are
present in this table for that I am
going to use the select statement select
star from table name that is restaurant
orders
so as you can see the table has various
columns such as order ID order date item
name quantity and price by the way guys
I have taken this data set from kaggle
so if you want to work on the same data
set we'll leave the link in the
description below so you make sure you
check this out
so firstly let us discuss about the
count
function here so if I want to count the
total number of records that are present
in this table I'll use the count
statement here as the following query
would be
select
count
use the astric operator because we want
to display all the records
from the table that is restaurant orders
so let me just execute the statement and
see the output
so as you can see there are total of
three not seven records that are present
in this table let's take another example
now let's say if I want to find the
total customers that are present in this
table so for that I'll use the order ID
as the reference that's because now if
you consider uh for any customer we'll
get a different order ready when you
places an order right so for that I'll
use the order ID so the following query
would be select count
now I'll use the distinct operator here
so that will have the unique values
order ID
from the table that is restaurant orders
so let me just execute the statement and
we'll see the output
so as you can see there are total of 48
customers that are present in the table
who have placed orders on various items
now let's take another example let's say
if I want to find the total number of
orders of each item that is present in
the table then the following query would
be
select
take the column name that is
item name
now I want to count all the records that
are present so I'm taking the count
operator
from table name that is restaurant
orders
now I want to group all the identical
values that are present for each of the
orders that are present so I'll take the
group by
function here
item name
and similarly I'm using order by so that
I want to display the orders in their
alphabetical order
so item name
so let me just execute the statement and
see the output
so as you can see it will display the
total number of records that are present
on each of the item that the order has
been placed now we have a total of uh
let's say four records of aloo gobi and
eight records of Bombay Aloo and so on
and Etc
so let me just uh verify the statement
and see if the condition that is
executed is true or not so I'll use the
select statement select star
from restaurant
orders
where
item name
equals to uh we'll see the records of
Bombay aloe so let me just copy this
field
and see the output
okay
so as you can see uh we have a total of
one two three four five six seven and
eight so clearly we have a total of
eight records that means our count
function has been successfully executed
so in this way you can use the count
function in SQL
you can also use the where condition
here as per your requirement let's say
if I want to display the list of all the
items and the total number of orders of
each and every item whose price is less
than three dollars and for that I'll use
the where statement so these syntax
remains same I will just use the where
condition here where price of the item
mentioned the column is less than three
dollars so let's just execute the
statement and see the output so it will
display all those records who's having
uh the price less than three dollars so
let's just verify for example uh we'll
take the garlic naan here as our example
and let's see if this condition is
satisfied or not
let me just copy this field and I'll
paste it here
and let us execute the statement and see
the output
so as you can see that we had four
records of garlic naan and it is being
presented here and its price is also
2.95 Which is less than 3.
let us not discuss about the minimum as
well as the maximum function in uh
aggregate functions now let us take an
example for that let's say if I want to
find those items which is having the
least amount of price so for that the
following query would be select minimum
is the keyword and within the brackets
mention the column that is price
from the table that is restaurant orders
so let us select the statement and see
the output so as you can see the minimum
price of the item in the table is 0.5 so
let us take another example here now
let's say if I want to find all those
items uh in the restaurant order table
which is having the cheapest price so
for that I'll use the query as select
display the item name
and its price
from the table that is restaurant orders
where
price equals to now we'll write a sub
query here using uh the minimum
statement
where select minimum
price
from the table that is
restaurant orders
so let me just execute the statement and
see the output
so it will display all the records uh in
the restaurant order table and the item
details which is having the least or the
cheapest price for example mango chutney
onion Chutney mint sauce and red sauce
is having the least price that is 0.5
now we can see there are duplicate
values in our resultant stable so I'll
just take the distinct keyword so that
it will terminate all the Redundant
values in the resultant table
so let me just execute the statement
so as you can see these are the four
items which is having the least price
now similarly you can find the maximum
uh
price of the order or the item that is
present in the restaurant order table
for that I'll use the max keyword here
so let me just execute the statement and
see the output so these are the three
items which is having the maximum or the
highest price in our table that is
tanduri King prawn Masala King Brown
balti and King prawn which is having the
price 12.95 which is the highest so in
this way you can use the maximum and the
minimum function to find out the highest
and the lowest value that is present in
your table
yeah
let us not discuss about the sum
function in aggregate functions now
basically the sum function is used to
calculate the total sum of all the
records that are present in a particular
column let's take an example let's say
if I want to find the total amount that
the restaurant has received on a single
day then the following query would be
select sum
now if you look at the orders table we
have different quantities for each item
right so the price will uh so the price
will be basically price into quantity
that will be the total value of the item
so I'll take select some price into
quantity from table that is restaurant
orders
foreign
capital in the record so we'll take as Q
as capital so let me just execute the
statement and see the output
so there's a spelling mistake here
let me just correct that and let us see
the output now
so as you can see it will show me the uh
total sum of all the items that were
placed on that particular day and the
value is
1689.9 dollars now you can name the
column as per your wish as well so I'll
just take it as uh total amount
so in this way you can use the sum
function as well let us now discuss
about the average function
now average function is also similar to
that of some but basically it calculates
the average of all the items or the
records that are present in the table
now let's say if I want to find the
average price of all the items that are
present in our restaurant orders table
then our following query would be select
average
price
from restaurant table
so let us see the output
so as you can see the average price of
all the items that are present is 5.04
dollars so in this way you can use the
average function as well
let's take another scenario for average
price where we'll use the where
condition let's say if I want to display
all those items that are having price
above the average price of all the items
that are present in the table then the
following query would be select I want
to display the item name so I'll take
the item name column
their price
from the table that is restaurant
where
price is greater than I'll write a sub
query select average
price
from the table that is restaurant orders
so let me just execute this statement
and see the output
so basically these are all the items
which are having price more than uh our
average price that we have calculated
earlier that is 5.09 so in this way you
can use the where condition as well as
per your requirement but there's a point
to be noted here that the average and a
sum function basically calculates only
those fields which is having numerical
values whereas the count uh minimum and
maximum function can calculate the
values of various data types such as
character string as well as the
numerical values so what are SQL
functions we know that a function is
basically used to perform some
particular task and it returns zero or
more values as a result now functions
are useful while writing SQL queries
also which can be applied to work on
single or multiple records of a table
now depending on their application in
one or multiple rows SQL functions are
generally categorized into aggregate
functions and single row functions which
is scalar functions now we have already
discussed about aggregate functions in
our previous videos so if you want to
know more about it make sure you check
that out on our Channel as well now
coming back to scalar functions now
unlike the aggregate functions which
return a single value after performing
calculations on a group of value the
scalar functions are a bit different in
its Usage Now the function which returns
only a single value from our input value
is known as a scalar function the scalar
function works on each record
independently and are based on user
input now scalar functions may take
single or multiple arguments but they
always return a single value result
which is mandatory the resultant value
of the scalar functions can be of any
data type so let us now discuss some of
the various scalar functions used in SQL
now scalar functions in SQL are broadly
classified into Phi types the first one
is L case the next one is U case and
then we have length and then we have mid
and finally we have round let us now
discuss about them in detail
so these are basically all these scalar
functions that are used in general now
first we have the L case now the SQL
function L case converts all the
characters of a string to lower case
that is if there is any string value
which is in capital letter it will
change into lower cases that is into
normal text now it takes one argument
and returns back only a single value and
it basically converts the value of a
column field in a table to lower case it
works on all values of the data types
and converts the string in the values to
lower case now similarly we have the
uppercase which is basically opposite of
lowercase it is also similar to that of
L case but it basically converts all the
characters of a string to uppercase
similarly it takes only one argument and
returns back only a single value and it
basically converts the value of any
column field into upper case next we
have length now the length function is
used to return the length of the value
in the field it counts the number of
characters along with spaces and returns
a single value integral and similar to
that of uppercase and lowercase it works
on values of all types of data types
next we have the mid function now the
SQL function mid extracts text from a
value of a field it takes one argument
and works on each value independently so
basically it extracts substrings in SQL
from a column values having string data
type next we have the round function the
round function is used to round a
numerical value to the number of decimal
specified so basically if you're working
on decimal data types you can use this
round function which basically rounds of
any numerical value to its nearest
integer value now other than this five
major user scalar functions SQL we also
have another type which is now which is
used to return the current system date
and time and similarly we have a format
function which is used to format the
contents of the field it is used to
specify how the content of the field
should be displayed or returned it
similarly works on the values of all
data types so now that we've understood
the different scalar functions in SQL
let us jump straight into MySQL
workbench for execution part wherein
will discuss each and every scalar
function with certain examples and
execute them if getting your learning
started is half the battle what if you
could do that for free visit scale up by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more
so as you can
SQL Workman just started and in order to
perform various operations using scalar
functions let us take an example for
that we'll consider the athletes events
one table first so let me just display
the records that are present in that
table so let me use the select statement
for that select star
from athletic events
let us execute this and we'll see the
data that is present in the stick
well so The Athlete's event one table
has various Fields such as ID name sex
age height weight team NOC games your
season and City
right so firstly let us discuss about
the UK's scalar function first now as we
discussed earlier the uks converts all
the characters of a string into
uppercase and the syntax is also simple
that is Select uks and within the
brackets mention the column names that
you want in uppercase from table names
right so let's say now we have the names
of all the athletes a basically in uh
Capital as well as the small letters now
let's say if you want the names of all
those athletes only in capital letters
that is in upper case then you have to
write the following query as select your
case
it's in the brackets the column name
which is name
from table name that is appellates event
one
now with UK's their name I'll want to
display their uh name column as well so
I'll take another expression which is
the I want to display the names of all
those employees as well so I'll just
display
and execute this
well as you can see now there's a
contrast between uh the names the name
first name that we have taken and after
that since we have applied the UK's
function here it has changed the
characters or the characters in string
in the names of the athletes to
completely into uppercase that is like a
djang has been completely changed into
the capital letters and so on like that
next let us discuss about the L case
function Now lks function is similar to
that of uks itself the L case function
is basically used to convert value of a
string column to a low case a character
that means if you want to uh change the
the values in a particular column from
Capital to small so in that case you use
the L case and the syntax is also
similar instead of the UK's keyword you
have to just replace with L case and the
syntax Remains the Same which is Select
L case column name from table name so
now in order to execute this let us take
another example here let us consider the
crypto table here now so I'll just
display the records so let's start from
crypto 22 table
right so let me just display the values
so the crypto 2022 table has various
Fields such as ranking crypto name price
changes 24 hours changes in seven days
changes in 30 days changes in one year
the market cap and volume in 24 hours
so as you can see the crypto name like
the name of all the cryptocurrencies
that are mentioned in the table are in
uh capital letters or in the upper case
now let's say if I want to change them
into lowercase I'll use the L case
function and the query is followed as L
case
mention the column name which is
crypto name I'll just copy the field
here
from the table that is crypto 2022
also I want to display the crypto name
column again as well
and we'll see how it is changed from the
original uh one which we have mentioned
right
so let us just execute this statement
and we'll see the output
so as you can see earlier we had all the
names of cryptocurrencies in uppercase
or in capital letters now since we have
applied the L case function here it has
changed completely into the lowercase or
the small letter values now as you can
see the Bitcoin is just in capital
letters has been completely changed into
Bitcoin so in this way you can use the L
case function uh in order to convert the
values of these strings that are present
in the column fields from capital or the
uppercase to the lowercase characters
Right Moving ahead let us now discuss
about the Lan function
an SQL now the Len function is used to
return the length of the value in the
field so basically it calculates the
length of the uh characters that are
present in the columns so for that let
us and the syntax is also uh similar to
that of the other scalar functions
basically the syntax is Select length
since we are working on MySQL the
keyword we use is length instead of Len
uh and we query on the syntaxes select
length column name from table name
so let's say if I want to calculate the
length of all the characters of the
cryptocurrencies name in the table so
I'll use the length function here and
this query would be select
length
mention the column name which is crypto
mean
I'll just copy paste it
from table name which is crypto 2022
right so let us execute this and we'll
see the output
so it will basically display the length
of all the cryptocurrencies we can
similarly mention the column of crypto
names as well here I'll just write
crypto name column and we'll execute it
again
so as you can see the cryptocurrencies
are being displayed as well as the
length of their cryptocurrencies names
that we have specified here so basically
it counts the number of characters along
with the spaces including and it runs a
single value integer now if you consider
Bitcoin which has basically seven uh
characters in total so it is displaying
a seven and if you look at the wrapped
Bitcoin we have a space in between
wrapped and Bitcoin so it considers the
space as well when you are working on
the length function so it combines the
space as well as the total characters
into the resultant set so in this way
you can use the lens function as well
next let us discuss about the mid scalar
function now this is perhaps one of the
most difficult and confusing scalar
function in SQL so let me just make it
easier and clear for you so make
function basically extracts text from
the value of a field so in other words
you can say it allows you to extract a
substring from a given string that is
you can extract only a certain number of
characters from a string and the syntax
for the mid function is Select mid
column name comma starting position
comma Lin from table name now these
parameters basically the first one is
column name that is basically the string
you want to extract extract as a
substring and next we have the starting
position which basically indicates the
position in the input string from where
the extraction will be started that is
from which position you want to extract
that substring and finally we have the
length it indicates the length of the
string which we want to extract from the
table
so let us understand this with an
example uh in order to understand it
clearly so now since we have this crypto
names right now instead of displaying
the complete name of the uh
cryptocurrencies I'll just assign a
symbol for that so I'll just display the
first three characters so in that case
I'll write the syntax as select mid
mention the column name which is crypto
name
just copying the field crypto name
starting position will be 1 and the
length will be the first three
characters so I'm mentioning three
from table name that is
crypto 2022 right so we are good to go
and we'll execute the statement and
we'll see the output so basically it
will display the first uh three
characters of the string that we have
taken from the uh field that is crypto
name so simultaneously I'll write the
I'll display the crypto names as well so
that we can have a clear picture on how
different it is
so as you can see the Bitcoin uh the
short form has been changed to a bit and
for without Bitcoin we are giving us VRA
and for you by BTC we are going here and
for ethereum eth so in similar way for
all the Bitcoins we are giving let's say
a layer's name in another way like a
shorter name from that where we are
selecting only certain number of
characters as a substring from the
original string
now you might get it out that where you
have to use this now generally this is
not used uh mostly in SQL like for
example if you are working on a field
which has let's say uh months you know
yeah like from January to this December
now in a resultant set if you don't want
to display the complete name of the
month like January and instead you just
want to mention the limited number of
characters or a substring from that
string so you can just mention Jan J and
the three characters right and similarly
Feb March April and so on so in this way
you can use the mid function as per your
requirement as well
and finally we have the round scalar
function now the round function is used
to round a numerical field to the number
of decimal specified so now generally if
you're working on a database which has a
value of decimals let's say up to uh 5
to 10 uh decimal places now if you want
round off that value to let's say just
two decimal places then in that case you
use the round a scalar function and the
syntax is also simple uh the syntax is
followed as select round and within the
brackets mention the column name which
you want to round up and mention the
number of uh positions to which the
numerical value should be rounded from
table name
so let us just take an example to
understand this better I'll uh
consider the crypto 2020 table again so
let me just display the value so let's
start from crypto 2022
right so now if you look into this table
uh let's say now we have this change in
the value in the last 30 days now we
have the decimal places up to two places
right now if I want to change that into
only one place so in that case what I'll
do is I'll write a simple query which
says select round mention the column
name that you want to round up which is
changes 30 right so I'll just copy this
field
and send it here and I want to specify
the decimal places up to only one place
so I'll just display the value as 1.
from table name that is crypto
so as execute this statement and we'll
see the output
right similarly I'll also mention the
crypto names as well
foreign
foreign
so as you can see the values the cryptos
in the the changes of the value in the
last 30 days has been changed to one
decimal place here now if you do not
mention these uh decimal places it will
basically round up the value to its
nearest possible value so let us just
execute this so as you can see minus
20.1 which is earlier has been changed
to minus 20 and similarly so on the
other values have also been changed
accordingly now it will basically round
off the values if the values uh above
0.5 it will basically round off it to
one that is if you have a value around
20.5 it will change to 21 and let's say
if you have 35.78 then it will change
into 36. so in this way you can use the
round function in order to round off the
number of places of a decimal of a given
number or a string value so that brings
us to the end of today's session guys
that was all about the scalar functions
we use in our SQL I hope you've
understood how to use the scalar
functions the syntax and the execution
part
so what is SQL Group by now SQL allows
the user to store more than one type and
up to almost 30 types of data types in
as many columns as required so sometimes
it becomes difficult to find similar
data in these columns now Group by in
SQL helps us club together all these
identical rows present in The Columns of
a data Group by statement is used to
group together any rows of a column with
the same value stored in them on a
function specified in the statement
basically Group by Clause is used to
group the rows with matching values
using the specified condition now
generally we use this group by Clause
with aggregate functions such as count
Max minimums maximum and average by the
way guys uh if you want to know more
about the aggregate functions make sure
to check out our previous video on
introduction the aggregate functions
where we have discussed about these in
detail
now uh the SQL Group by statement uses
the split apply combined technique here
now the different groups are split with
their values and then an aggregate
function is applied to these values of
these groups and finally the values are
combined into a single row now if you
consider this example here we have two
columns and we have three different
items uh a b c having different values
now you can see a has two values four
seven one three
and C has nine four now when we split
this and apply the sum aggregate
function which results in the arithmetic
sum of all these row values as you can
see now a has values four and seven now
when I apply the sum it becomes 11 and b
1 3 it becomes 4 and C 9 4 it becomes
13. so it will display all these
identical arrows having matching values
and into a resultant set so in this way
you can use the SQL Group by
let us now understand the syntax of SQL
Group by statement the syntax is
followed as select column 1 column 2 up
to a number of columns from table name
where condition Group by column name now
the group by statement lets the database
system user know that we wish to group
the same value rows of the column
specified in the statements column names
parameter and you can also use there is
an optional where clause which can be
used to specify any condition According
to which the row are to be selected
next let us understand what is SQL order
by statement the order by Clause is an
SQL sorts the data of a column in the
SQL database it helps us sort the column
in both ascending as well as the
descending order the ASC keyword helps
us sort in ascending order while the
desc keyword sorts in descending order
and if no keyword is specified in which
we have to sort the records in the
column it will take the default value
the order by Clause sorts the record in
ascending order by default if it not
mention any specific keyword that is AAC
or DAC
now the order by Clause can only be for
select statements and the order by
keyword is used to sort the resulting
table in either ascending order b or
descending order based on the columns
specified in the statements column name
now another important thing to be noted
here is that the order by statement
always appear after the group by
statement and is applied to the group of
rows form let us look at the syntax the
syntax is followed as select column 1
column 2 from table name where condition
which is optional as per your
requirement Group by column list order
by column name and you can mention the
AC or desc keyword as per your need
now that we have understood about both
of these statements let us now
understand the differences between Group
by and order by now Group by statement
is used to group the rows that have the
same value whereas the order by is used
to arrange the data obtained in the
resultant table of a query in sorted
form
now the groupa is always used before the
order by clause in the select statement
whereas the all order by statement is
used after the group by clause in a
select statement
now in group by statement the attribute
under the aggregate function cannot be
in group by Clause whereas in order by
the attribute under aggregate function
can be in order by Clause that means if
the group a clause contains an attribute
that is not under select clause or if it
is under select Clause but under
aggregate function then the query
becomes invalid and it throws an
exception hence we can say the group by
Clause is always used in collaboration
with the select Clause now in group by
it is mandatory to use one of the
aggregate functions like count sum
average minimum maximum Etc whereas in
order by statement it is not compulsory
and mandatory to use the aggregate
functions and finally the group by
Clause controls the presentation of rows
or tuples whereas the order by statement
controls the presentation of columns
that means the group is only concerned
with the values of identical rows in the
resultant set whereas the order by
statement uh basically arranges the data
in the columns in either ascending or
descending form now that we have
understood about both these uh skill
statements let us jump into MySQL
workbench for execution part choose from
over 300 in-demand skills and get access
to 1 000 Plus hours of video content for
free visit scale up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
so as you can see MySQL workbench has
started now in order to execute the
group and order by statement we'll
consider the data set of an employee
which have already downloaded from
Google so let me just import the data
set into the MySQL workbench for that
all you have to do is just go to the
tables Tab and right click on it and
you'll find table data import wizard
click on that now it will ask to import
the location from where you have said so
I have saved my file in desktop so I'm
just selecting the file
now once you select the file click the
next button here now it will ask if uh
to name the table whether to use
existing table or to create a new table
so I'm just taking a new table here
employees1
and click on next
it will display all the columns that are
present uh in that CSV file so just
click on next
click on next and it will start to
prevent the import now depending upon
the number of Records present in the
data set it will take bit of time so
don't worry now as you can see our data
set has been successfully imported so
we'll click on next again
so uh it is showing that 14 and Records
have been important successfully
so let me just refresh the schema here
and as you can see employees one uh has
been shown in the table section so let
me just display the records that are
present in these uh tables for that I'm
using this select statement select star
from employees
one
so as you can see our employees one
table has employee ID first name last
name email phone number hiring date job
ID salary manager ID and finally
Department ID
foreign
let us discuss about the group by Clause
uh now let's say if I want to fetch the
total employees in all the Departments
from the employees one table then the
following query would be
select now I can take the employer ID to
display the total number of employees
because each and every every employee
has a different employee ID to their
name so select
count
employee ID
as total
comma
want to display their Department ID as
well so I'm taking Department ID
from employees table
employee one
Group by
now we want to group all their
Department ID right so I'm taking
Department ID
so let me just execute the statement and
see the output
okay
the table name is wrong here so let me
just correct it
so as you can see it will display the
total employees that are present in each
and every department now if you look at
the department ID column uh we have the
values in a random way now in order to
display in a systematic and a proper way
this is where we use the order by
statement so we can sort the department
ID values in the ascending or descending
manner as per as per a requirement so I
want to display an ascending order so
order by Department ID
foreign
let us execute the statement and see the
output so as you can now see that the
department ID are being displayed any in
the ascending manner that is 10 20 30 40
50 and so on up to 110. so in this way
you can use the group by an order by
statements
so that was all about the group and
order by a statement so this is just to
give a quick uh review on how these two
statement works now if you want to learn
more about the order by statement make
sure to check out our rice kill order by
video on our channel uh where we have
discussed about it more in depth and
with more examples as well
and also you might have a doubt that
when to use Group by and when to use the
order by statement now if you want to
form the group of uh the set of records
are the identical columns having values
in them then you must use Group by
clause and in case you want to arrange
the data of a single or a multiple
column uh with variable different
conditions or in that case you have to
use the order by to sort the data in
ascending or descending order so as you
can see MySQL workbench has started and
before getting into the execution part
let us just quickly understand what is
between operator and SQL now the SQL
between operator is used to test whether
an expression is within a range of
values or not his operator is inclusive
so it includes only the start and end
values of the range and the values can
be textual numerical type or day type
now between operator can be used with
select insert update as well as the
delete command so to get a clear picture
of how this operator works let us get
into the syntax of it now the syntax is
followed as select column names from
table name where column name between
range start and range ends so the
columns to be retrieved are specified
after the select statement and that and
the table The Columns are being
retrieved from the specified is the in
is in the from statement and then we
have the between operator which is used
in the where Clause the column we want
to apply the range condition on is
specified with the column name parameter
and the starting value of the range of
values is specified in the range start
parameter and the ending value in the
range and parameter so now that we've
understood how exactly the between
operator works let us get into some
examples and understand its execution
part so let us take an example to
understand the SQL between operator so I
am taking the new employees uh as the
example here so let me just display the
values for that I'm using the select
operator select star from new employees
let us execute the statement so the new
employees table has various columns such
as Employer ID first name last name
email phone number hiring date job ID
salary manager ID Department ID
that's it so all right now we'll take a
simple example uh to understand the
between operator so let's say if you
want to retrieve the ID and name of the
employees with IDs in the range let's
say now we have IDs up to range like 198
200 2.1 so let us take uh the range
between 110 and let's say 170 then
reduce the following query as select
employee ID
comma first name
foreign
use the where condition
where employee ID
between is the keyword
110 and 170.
so let's execute this and we'll see the
output
so as you can see it will display the
records of all those employees whose
employee ID lies between the range that
is 110 and 170. now if any employee
who's having their employee ideas 110
even their values are also included in
the resultant set and similarly if any
employee has 170 in their as their
employee ID even their data will be in
the result and set now in the table we
do not have any employee who is having
the employee ideas 170 so we do not have
the information now so in this case it
will only display only the details of
all those employees who's having the
employee ID range in 110 and 1 7 and 1 7
well moving ahead let us take next
another example now we can use the order
by statement also to sort the result
based on some columns now let's say if
you want to retrieve the details of all
those employees with salary ranging from
35
000 to let's say 75 000 and in order to
sort this result based on the salary
we'll use the following query as select
I want to display all the details so I'm
using the star operator select stars
from new employee
where
salary
between 35 000
and let us take let's say 55 000.
right and I'll use the order by
salary
so that it will display the values of
all the salaries in the ascending order
so let us execute and we'll see the
output
so as you can see there are only uh five
employees in our new employees table uh
for example run scale Ladwig who's
working as a clerk he's having salary 36
000 which is in the bracket of thirty
five thousand and fifty five thousand
similarly we have Diana Lawrence whose
salary 42 000. similarly we have
Jennifer Valen whose salary is forty
four thousand and so on so in general we
use the between operator to find the
range of values like for example we are
finding the salary range right so in a
similar way we can use the between
operator
to find the range between
two given values of a particular column
now similarly we can use the not
operator with between as well now we can
also use the not operator with the
between operator to select the values
that do not belong to that specified
range now instead of using between if I
mention the not between keyword here it
will basically display all those records
of employees whose salary is not in the
ring of 35 000 and 55 000. now it will
display the records of all those
employees like if you take Hermann bear
whose salary is 10 000 which is not in
the bracket or in the range of 35 000
and 55 000. similarly it will display
the records of all those employees whose
salary is not in between that ring which
is 35 000 and 55 000. in this way you
can use the not between keyword as well
which will exclude uh the results that
are not in the given range now you can
use the uh between operator with the
date values as well now when using the
between with dates or the date time
values we need to remember to enclose
the date in single inverted commas as
otherwise the query will return a syntax
error so let us take an example here
let's say if I want to retrieve the
details of all those employees whose
hiring date is in between let's say 2000
and 2007. now as you can see our hiring
date is between like 2005 2004
2002 and similarly Etc right so in that
in that case I want to display all those
employee details whose hiring date was
in between 2000s and 2007. so in that
case the following query would be select
starts from new employees again which
will display all the records where
higher date between mention the inverted
commas so I'll take from 1st January
2000
and
31st December
2007.
right so let us execute this statement
and we'll see the output
so it will display be the records of all
those employees who have their hiring
date in between this range which is
January 1st 2000 and 31st December 2007.
so in this way you can use the between
operator with the date values as well
right moving ahead uh now we can use the
between operator with the text values as
well between operator can also be used
with the character data types like for
example while using any text values we
need to remember to again enclose the
data in single inverted commas otherwise
it will return a syntax error so let us
take an example here let's say uh we
want to retrieve all the employee
details and along with their names
belonging to our range from let's say
alphabets A and J that means we want the
details of all those employees whose
name is in between the first letter that
is a and the letter J in that case the
following query would be select star
from new employees
where I'm taking first name
right first name
between
letter a and letter j
and close them in the inverted commas
and we'll see the output now
so let us also order
we'll use the order by statement so that
will have an ascending order
I think there is a no need for that so
we'll just directly uh
execute this so as you can see it will
display the records of all those
employees uh whose name is in the range
with starting letter a and the starting
letter J now you can see Donald
O'Connell whose first name starts with d
right so it is in the range of a and j
it will it lies between a and j and
similarly we have Hermann we have
Alexander and David guy himero Etc
so in this way you can use the between
operator to find the values in a
particular range which have only text
data types and that brings us to the end
of today's session guys that was a quick
tutorial on how to use the between
operator in SQL if you remember all the
SQL between operator rules and syntaxes
you can easily customize your queries to
retrieve the type of information that
you want this tool along with other SQL
tools enables us to write different
kinds of essential queries now this
between operator is generally used to
find the values within a certain range
for example you can find the salaries of
employees within a certain brackets you
can also find the marks of the students
in a particular range and similarly you
can find the details of the products
which lie in a certain range so in all
these cases you can use the between
operator as per requirement so now that
you know about the between operator it
is time for you to start using the
between operator along with other SQL
commands Clauses and operators to query
your database tables
so firstly we'll discuss what is where
Clause the SQL where Clause is used to
specify a condition while fetching the
data from more than one table or by
joining with multiple tables if the
given condition is satisfied then only
it returns a specific value from the
table now we can use the wire Clause to
filter the records and fetch only the
necessary requests from a database the
where Clause is not only used in the
select statement but it is also used in
the update delete
Etc
let us now understand the syntax the
syntax is simple and is followed as
select column one column two so on from
table name where condition
let us understand with an example
consider the employee table here which
is having various columns such as ID
name age City and salary now let's say
if I want to uh find the employee who is
having the maximum salary in this table
and for that I'll write a query stating
select star from employee where salary
is greater than 50 000. now if you
implement this query it will basically
show those records which is having
salary more than 50 000 now if you look
into the table abay Kumar whose ID is
1175 is having 52 600 which is greater
than 50 000. so in this way where
basically uh meets the condition that is
set by the user
let us now understand what is having
clause in SQL
the having classes generally used along
with the group by clause and having
Clause is used to filter the results
obtained by the group by Clause based on
some specific condition having Clause is
quite similar to that of where Clause as
both are used to filter records in SQL
but where Clause cannot be used with the
aggregate functions like count Max sum
and Etc which is why having Clause is
needed and that is the reason we use the
having clause
let us now understand the syntax the
syntax is also similar you have to
mention the having keyword here instead
of where and the syntax is followed as
select column 1 column two from table
name Group by column 1 column two so on
having and mentioned the condition now
group a clause is used to arrange the
data into groups and having Clause is
used in the column operations and it
basically uh group all the identical
data and gives you the condition that is
specified by the U
let us understand this with an example
again consider the same employee table
here which is having ID name HCT and
salary now
as we know we have to use uh aggregate
functions so I'm using the average
function here and since the having plus
also uses a group by
um so that is the reason I'm also using
the group by
now let's say if I want to find the
average salary of all the employees from
different cities then the following
query would be select City average
salary from employee Group by city now
when I perform this query the this will
be the following output where it will
show the resultant set of all the cities
and their average salary now we have New
Delhi that is being repeated wise which
is two records and we have ghaziabad
which is two records now New Delhi has
two requests which is having service 36
000 and 38 000. now if you consider the
average it is basically 37 000 and
similarly for gaziabad we have three
records which have salaries for six
thousand five hundred for two thousand
six hundred fifty two thousand six
hundred now when you calculate the
average it is showing us forty seven
thousand two thirty three
now now that you have applied this now
let us have the having condition here
now let's say if I want to find the
average salary of all those employees
from different cities who is having
average salary greater than 40 000.
now in this case if I implement this
query this will be the following output
as you can see both ghaziabad and Noida
has the average salary more than 40 000
that is forty seven thousand two thirty
three and forty eight thousand so in
this way you can use the SQL having
Clause as well
let us now look at the differences
between these two Clauses that is a
skill wear and having clause
now SQL where Clause basically filters
the individual rows in the table based
on the specific condition whereas the
having Clause filters groups instead of
one row at a time
now as discussed earlier where Clauses
can be used with select update delete
statement whereas the having uh class
can be used only with the select
statement
now where comes before group a which
means that where plus filters rows
performing aggregate calculations and
having comes after Guru by which means
the having plus filters rows after
performing aggregate uh calculations so
consequently having is or slower than
where in terms of complexity and
efficiency as well now as discussed
earlier where class cannot contain
aggregate functions and having plus can
contain aggregate functions such as
count some average
Etc
now SQL wire is considered as a
pre-filter because it performs the row
operations first and having Clause is
considered as a post filter because it
performs the column operations after
grouping the data
so now that we have understood about
these both types of SQL Clauses let us
jump into MySQL workbench for the
execution part if getting your learning
started is half the battle what if you
could do that for free visit scale up by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more
so as you can see MySQL workbench has
started and on the left side you can
view the simply code database which is
having different tables such as customer
Department employee employees one and
Etc now to perform the where and having
Clause statements we'll use the
employees once uh table so let me just
display the records present in that
table so I'll use the select operator
select star from employee
employee one table
click on the execute Button as you can
see the employees one table has various
columns such as employee ID first name
last name of the employee their email ID
phone numbers hiring date job ID salary
manager ID and Department ID
so firstly let us discuss about the
where uh clause or basically where
condition so let's say if you want to
fix the records of all those employees
from these employees one table whose
salary is let's say less than 5000 and
they belong to Department 30.
so in that case the following query
would be
select
star
from employees
table one
where
salary is less than five thousand
now I'm using the and operator which is
basically a logical operator so whenever
you're performing the wear condition you
can use the logical operators and
comparison operators of a logical
operators such as and or between Etc and
the comparison operators like less than
equal to less than greater than equals
to
Etc
so I'm using the and operator here and
Department ID
is equals to 30. foreign
so let me execute the statement and see
the output
so as you can see there are total of
four employees whose salary is less than
50 000 and they belong to the Department
30.
now you can also as discussed earlier
you can also perform the update
operations uh using the where uh
Clause as well now let's say if I want
to update the salary of uh employee who
is having employed in 116 as let's say
10 000 then the query would be update
table name that is employee one
salary equals to ten thousand
where
employee ID
is equals to uh let's say 160.
an employee name is Shelly baida so I'm
just uh
taking that example so let me just
execute this query so as you can see our
query has been successfully executed so
let me just verify whether it is
executed or not so I'll use the select
statement select start from
employee one
where
employee ID
equals to 160.
so let me run this query and we'll see
the output so as you can see the
employee uh Shelley bada who's having
employee ID 116 and their salary has
been changed into 10 000 years
successfully so in this way you can use
the uh where Clause as well
you can also use the where clause for
delete also now let's say if I want to
delete uh the details of the employees
who's having employee ideas 120 let's
say then I'll use the delete statement
delete
from
employee one
where
employee ID is equals to 120.
7
so let me just execute this query
so as you can see our query has been
successfully executed here and the
details of the employee who's having
employed as 127 has been deleted
successfully so in this way you can use
the where Clause to perform various
operations such as select update delete
Etc using comparison and logical
operators let us now understand about
the having clause for that let me take
an example let's say if you want to
display the records of all those
employees present in different
departments and whose average salary is
uh greater than let's say a 5000. so in
that case the following query would be
select
now I want to display the department ID
so I'm taking the department ID column
average salary
from employees
one
now as you know while using the uh
having Clause we have to use the group
by uh statement as well so I'll Group by
all the department IDs since we have
multiple Department IDs present in the
table
Department ID
having
average salary
greater than 5000.
five thousand dollars okay let me just
display the output
so our query has been successfully
executed and as you can see here uh it
is displaying all the different
departments uh and their average
salaries as well here now I can use the
different aggregate functions here as
well if I want to count uh the number of
employees in each department I can take
the count function so let me just use it
count employee ID which will basically
count all the total employees in the
different departments so let me just
execute this statement
so as you can see it will display the
count of all the employees that are
present in different departments and
having average salary more than 50 000.
so in this way you can use the having
Clause as well now we can also combine
both the wear condition as well as the
uh having condition as well now we can
combine the where and having plus
together in a select query in this case
the where Clause is used first to filter
individual rows and then the rows are
then grouped to perform the aggregate
calculations and finally the having
Clause is used to filter the grouped
data that is the identical groups that
are having the same values
now as discussed earlier uh
we have to use the where condition
before the group by so I am just taking
the wire Clause before the group by and
let's say if I want to display only
those uh departments that are having
more than 80.
as the department ID so Department
ID
greater than 80.
so let me just display
so as you can see it will display only
those records where the department ID is
more than 80 that is 1900 and 110 and
the details of all the employees whose
average salary is more than 500. now I
can also use the order by statement here
in order to mention all these records in
a systematic manner that is an ascending
or descending order so order byte
Department ID
so let us execute this query
so as you can see it will showcase the
department ID values and the ascending
order that is 1900 and 110. so in this
way you can use the having uh Clause as
well in SQL
so as you can see MySQL workbench has
started and in mysqld column operations
play an important role because sorry
even for data analysis or even if you're
performing queries on your database
table it is quite essential because
let's say for instance you have created
a table as per required with requirement
with a set of different columns now
later at a different stage you might
need to add some additional requirements
where the table might need to have some
additional columns or even some columns
might require to be deleted or some
column names need to be changed into a
new columns within that existing table
now there are mainly two different ways
to satisfy this condition first is you
have to delete the table and recreate a
new table as per your new requirement
now this is possible and advise only
when the table is empty right now if the
table is not empty you have to copy the
data and then delete the table or create
another table and then copy our load the
data into the our new table now this is
time consuming and also not advisable
the other way is to add delete or modify
the columns and the data present in it
to the current Table without touching
the existing columns and its
corresponding data now this is done by
using the alter table statement which
fulfills the requirement of adding new
data within the existing columns now the
alter table statement is used to change
the structure of the existing table by
adding deleting or modifying The Columns
without modifying the data in it
so let us discuss what are the different
operations that are performed in SQL
firstly let us discuss the add column
operation in SQL
for for that let me consider the
employee table so let me just display
the values in it select star
from employee
so as you can see uh the employee table
has various columns like employee ID
employee name age designation City
salary date of joining Department ID
now let's say I have an additional
requirement where I want to add another
column let's say if I want to add the
other number details of the employees
for that I'll use the alter statement
and the query is Alter
payable
employee
add column
aadhar number
and mentioned the column data type I am
taking varker
and will specify not null as are
constraint that means uh it must have a
other number for every employee in the
table so let me just execute the
statement so as you can see our query
has been successfully executed so let me
just display the values
so as you can see uh there is a new
column other number that has been
created in our existing table without
disrupting any columns and its values in
the uh employee table
now similarly you can add multiple
columns to your existing table as well
and the query is Alter table
employee
add column
and within the brackets mention the
different column names now let's say if
I want to add the part number as well as
the u n that is the universal account
number of the employees so
the query will be add column
number
mention the column data type I'm taking
marker again
foreign
number
mention the data type
as what care
so let us execute the statement and see
the output
so our query has been executed
successfully let us see the output now
so as you can see uh we have two other
columns part number and UN number in our
employee table since we have not
mentioned mentioned any constraints here
as null or not null so it by default it
is taking here as null values so in this
way you can use the alter table command
to add multiple columns in your table as
well
now similarly you can even modify or
update the column values as well let's
say if I want to update the existing
column name into a new name now for that
I'll use the alter table statement again
now consider the employee table again so
let me just display the values
[Music]
now if I want to change the salary
column name into total salary so for
that the following query would be alter
table
employee
change column is the keyword we use in
MySQL so mention the keyword change
column so we want to change the salary
column into total salary
and also mention the data type as well
let us execute the query and see
so our query has been successfully
executed so let me just display the
records again so as you can see our
salary name of the column salary has
been changed into the total salary here
so in this way you can update the column
values as well now similarly you can
also modify the existing uh column type
in the table as well for that the
following query would be alter table
employee
modify is the keyword
now let's say if I want to change the
age data type so let's see what the
initial or the previous data type was in
for age so I'll use the describe
employee
query here
so we basically have VAR care as our
data type for the age now if I want to
change into int so I'll just basically
mention the in keyword here
so let us execute this statement and see
the output
so there was a bit error I forgot to
mention the column keyword here so
that's how it is showing an error so let
me just again uh describe the table
employee so as you can see the data type
of the age column has been changed from
barcap to int so in this way you can use
the alter table to modify the column
data type as well
now similarly we can also uh modify a
new column or an existing column with a
default value as well let's say I want
to take a new column uh bonus that is
the bonus salary for all the employees
so for that the following query would be
alter table
employee
all the column is the keyword we use
here
bonus is the column that I'm creating
set default
is the keyword and I'm keeping the bonus
already default as let's say 15 000.
so let us execute the query and see the
output
so I forgot to add the column of the
bonus so let me just first add the
column so altar table employee add
column bonus
20.
so our bonus column has been
successfully created here
so now we can see our query will be
successful here as well
so let me just describe the table again
now if you scroll down you can see the
bonus column uh the field which it has
the default salary as fifteen thousand
so in this way you can add the uh
default value to your existing columns
or uh to your new columns as well
and finally we can also drop the columns
uh the drop column is basically is used
to delete the unnecessary or unwanted
columns in our database so let's say if
I want to delete the create already
created a columns such as other pan uin
on bonus
so I'll use the drop statement here to
delete the columns that were created
earlier so drop
so the query would be alter table
employee
drop column now first let us delete a
single column here so let's say if I
want to delete the other number column
so I'll use the other number column here
so let us see the output our query has
been successfully executed let me just
select the records so as you can see uh
other number column has been
successfully deleted and similarly you
can also delete multiple columns as well
all you have to do is just write the
same query and put a comma and write
again the column drop column keyword
here and let's say if I want to delete
the pi number as well so
pan number as well as the UN number here
now so I can use this query here
so let me just execute this on CD output
so our query has been executed let me
just display the records
so as you can see uh the U.N number as
well as the part number has been
successfully uh deleted from the
employee table as well and similarly the
altered statement table statement is
also used to add and drop various
constraints on an existing table like
which we have discussed earlier uh if
you want your column uh a null value
then you can mention the null as the
constraint there and if you don't want
any null values for your columns then
you can use the not null keyword in your
uh alter table statements so in this way
you can use the
alter table statement to perform various
column operations in SQL so that was all
about the SQL column operations guys
where we have discussed about how to add
how to delete and how to update or
modify the existing columns in the
database so what is a sub query an SQL
sub query is a query which is written
inside another query a sub query is
usually added within the where Clause of
another SQL select statement in a sub
query the outer queries result is
dependent on the result set of the inner
query and that is the reason why sub
queries are also called as the nested
queries our sub queries also called as
an inner query or inner select while the
statement containing the main query or
the parent query is called as the outer
query or outer select query statement
now the inner query executes first
before its uh parent query or the outer
query so that the results of an inner
query can be passed to the outer query
let us understand this uh with an
example here now consider this syntax
over here which is followed as select
employee name Department from employee
where salary equals to select maximum
salary from employee now select employee
name Department from employees the outer
query and the rest part is the inner
query now when the above query is
applied to the given employee table here
the sub query is executed first which
select the maximum salary from the
employee table then the resultant is the
passed onto the where Clause of the
outer query now this outer query is
executed which selects the rows in this
case the employee name and the
department from the employee table where
the salary is equals to the resultant of
the sub query which is the it selects
the maximum salary from the employee
table Returns the final result
so let us now look at the types of sub
queries that are used in SQL now sub
queries in SQL are majorly used with
insert delete select update statement
along with the comparison operators like
less than equals to greater than or
equals to between in and Etc
uh sub queries are used to execute a
query dependent on the outcome of
another query and it allows the user to
fetch the results without writing two
distinct queries and it is time saving
as well so now that we have understood
what is sub queries under different
types let us jump into MySQL workbench
uh to execute the various sub queries
that are used in SQL so as you can see
MySQL workbench has started and we have
various tables in our database simply
code such as customer Department
employee employee one and so on firstly
let us discuss the sub queries using the
select statement now in SQL in most of
the cases we use the select statement to
perform the sub queries so for that let
us consider the table employees one here
so let me just display the records that
are present in the table for that I am
using the select statement Select Staff
from employee
so what
so let us run the query and see the
records so as you can see the employees
one table has various columns such as
employee ID first name last name emails
their phone number hiring date job ID
salary manager ID and Department ID
now let us understand this concept with
the help of an example for executing the
select statement using the sub queries
now let's say if I want to find all
those employees whose salary is less
than the average salary of all the
employees that is present in the
employees one table so in this scenario
we'll use a sub query to get those
employees whose salary is less than the
average salary from the employee table
and the following query would be
select now since I want to display all
the records I'm using the star operator
from
employees1
where
salary
is less than and within the parenthesis
we have to mention the sub query that is
Select
average salary
from
employees one table so let us execute
the statement and see the output
foreign
there is a render in the code just let
me check so yeah I forgot to mention the
parenthesis here uh make sure you uh
write the sub queries always within the
parenthesis otherwise it will show an
error here so now let us understand this
query and let us break this query
statement to understand in a better way
now here the query to find out the
average salary is this sub query here
that is the select average salary from
the employee one table so let me just
execute this statement
so we have the average salary that is
six thousand seven or eight point six
six so now the outer query takes the
result of this inner query which is
basically the sub query and executes the
remaining SQL command based on the
result so the sub query first Returns
the average salary that is six Thousand
Seven not eight and this result is
passed on to the outer query which
fetches the details of all those
employees who is having salary less than
the average salary that is six thousand
seven or eight so when execute this
statement it will display the approach
of all those records who's having salary
less than six thousand seven on eight
that is uh 2 600 4400 and so on
in this way so in this way you can use
the select statement to perform the sub
queries in SQL if getting your learning
started is half the battle what if you
could do that for free visit scale up by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more
now other than uh the SQL select
statement SQL sub queries can also be
used with the insert statement in the
insert statement
the data returned from the sub queries
used to insert the data from one table
that is the existing table into another
new table
now let us consider the employee table
here so let me just display the records
select star from employee
uh let me just display the records now
so the employee table has various Fields
such as employee ID employee name age
designation CT total salary date of
joining Department ID and bonus now if I
want to copy this data from the employee
table into a new table let's say
employee new table so I'll have I can
use the sub queries with the insert
statement here so let me just create a
new table here and the query is followed
as create table employee new the
employee new table has the employee ID
employee name designation total salary
that's it so I'm taking primary key as
employee ID as it uniquely identifies
the each record in the table
so let me just execute the statement
now I'll use the select statement
now as you can see the employee new
table has various Fields employee ID
employee name designation and total
salary but we do not have any values
that are present in the employee new
table so we'll use the sub query using
the insert statement to into insert
values into it now let's say if I want
to insert the values from the employee
table that is the existing table whose
salary is uh greater than 30 000. so I
want to fetch only those records from
the employee table into the employee new
table or salary is greater than 40 000
so the following query would be insert
into
the new table that is employee new
select
now
since we are only concerned with the
employee ID employee name designation
and total salary we'll mention only
those columns employee employee ID
employee name
designation
total salary
from the previous existing table that is
our employee table
where
total salary
I'm using the in operator here
and within the parenthesis I'll write
the sub query that is Select
total salary
employee
where
total salary
is greater than forty thousand
close the parenthesis and let us execute
the statement now
so our statement has been successfully
executed so let me just display the
records again
so let's start from the table employee
name
so as you can see it will uh insert only
those records for all those employees
total salary is greater than 40 000. so
we have only two employees Kiran and
Ajay who's having salary is fifty
thousand and sixty thousand
now the insert statement basically
specifies that new data is added to this
table that is the employee new table and
as we are copying all the data from the
employee table which is our existing
table to the new employee new table
there is no need to specify the column
name in the insert statement otherwise
you would need to mention the column
name in which you want to add the data
the only thing that you have to keep in
mind is that the table structure has to
remain the same even if the column names
are a bit different the column data
types have must remain the same in order
to insert the data using sub queries
from one table to another table so in
this way you can write sub queries using
the insert statement as well also in a
similar way you can use the update as
well as the delete statement to modify
the existing data that is present in the
table
to know more about it make sure to check
out our SQL full course for beginners
2022 on our channel so that brings us to
the end of today's session guys that was
all about sub queries in sqn so as you
can see MySQL workbench has started and
before understanding the syntax of how
to create a functions let us just
understand what a function is actually
is now a function in SQL is basically a
set of SQL statements that performs a
specific task now if you have to
repeatedly write a larger SQL queries to
perform a task you can simply create a
function for that now next time instead
of rewriting the whole SQL query you can
just simply call that function to get
the desired result
now these SQL functions are basically
programs either developed by the user or
already provided by the SQL system now
we have several email functions or the
system defined functions like aggregate
functions string functions date
functions Etc now other than that we can
create a user defined function as well
so firstly let us go through the syntax
uh on how to create a function so the
syntax is followed as delimiter which I
am explained in a while when we are
creating the actual functions so let us
keep it aside for a while create
function function name and inside the
parenthesis mention the parameters now
you can create a number of parameters as
per your choice uh the thing is you have
to mention the parameter name as well as
its data type returns data type
deterministic begin and inside that we
have to write the code that is the
actual code for the function and use the
end so let me just explain how this
syntax Works firstly we are specifying
the name of the stored function that we
want to create after the create function
keyword next we have to list all the
parameters of the stored function inside
the parenthesis followed by the function
name and then we are specifying the data
type of the return value in the return
statement
which can be valid using any data type
here as well like int car marker Etc and
then we are specifying if a function is
deterministic or not now a deterministic
function always results Returns the same
value for the same input parameters
whereas a non-deterministic function
returns different result for the same
input parameters so let me just explain
this one example now if I take a
function x y z and I am specifying a
parameter let's say a p function so it
will always result the same answer as
long as its input that is p is the same
and finally we'll write the code in the
body section after the begin uh keyword
so this code will be written uh in the
body of the stored function in the begin
end block now inside the body section
you need to specify at least one return
statement this return statement
basically returns a value to the calling
program now whenever the return
statement is reached this execution of
this function is terminated
automatically
so let us now understand this with an
example uh we have a query here which
says like a Creator function bonus
status which has one parameter salary of
type care and returns wire care of size
20. now we have to use the following
operations in this statement to create
this function the first one is return
eligible for bonus as their statement if
salary is greater than 35 000 else
return not eligible
so let us now write the Syntax for this
so let me just switch to another Tab and
we'll write the query here first write
the
keyword that is create function
now the function is bonus status
inside the parenthesis mention the
parameter now I am taking parameter as
salary here which is of character I am
giving sizes 20.
close the parenthesis
now mention the return return statement
that is it returns
of size 20.
deterministic
is the keyword that we are using here
begin
and inside this we have to write our
main query now the query that we have
earlier discussed is that if salary
is greater than 35
000.
then
return
eligible for bonus
eligible for bonus and close the
parenthesis
else
return
else or return
inside the parenthesis
not eligible
mention the double quotes and close the
parenthesis and put a semicolon
now that's it that is the end of our
body so now I'll use the end if
statement
which will basically close the body of
our function and then I'll use the end
uh
operator here
with the dollar signed
and that is it this is basically our
code for to create a function so let us
now execute the statement and see the
output now while I execute the statement
it will throw an error and this is where
we'll use the SQL delimiter
now as you know when we write an SQL
statement you use the semicolon after
the SQL statement uh like if you write
it two separate statement for example if
I say
select star from layer I'm taking an
example as employee and I'm taking
another example as select star
from orders
now when I execute this query it will
throw an output because I haven't
selected which query I want to execute
now for that we'll place an individual
semicolon for at the end of our
statement right so in a similar way
a MySQL uses the delimiter function to
separate statement and executes each
statement separately now however a
function consists of a multiple
statement separated by a semicolon so if
you used to define a function that
contains semicolon characters then it
will not treat the whole function as a
single statement but many statements
therefore you must redefine the
delimiter temporarily so that you can
pass the whole function as a single
statement so for that we'll use the
delimiter here so let me just
incorporate the delimiter here
you have to use delimiter with the help
of a double slash or double dollar sign
here
we have to specify at the beginning as
well as the end
delimiter
and I'll mention two double so that's it
now our code is complete and let us
execute the statement now so our query
has been successfully executed now to
see whether our function is created or
not let us just refresh the schema here
and as you can see in function section
you can see bonus status which is the
function we have created earlier has
been created successfully so let us now
just verify whether our function is
working or not so I'll just write a
simple query as select
bonus status
let us take 40 000 as our example
so let me just execute this statement
and we'll see the output
so as you can see uh the condition which
is specified is if the cell is greater
than 35 000 then the employees eligible
for bonus now since we have taken the
salary is 40 000 it is showing us
eligible for bonus now similarly let's
say if I take uh twenty thousand
and if I execute the statement it will
definitely show me not eligible so as
you can see it will show not eligible
for bonus
so in this way you can create an user
defined function by passing certain
parameters to get the desired result of
your choice so now that you've created a
function you can query an already
existing table by calling that function
in an SQL statement by passing certain
parameters into that function let us
understand this with an example consider
the employee table here so let me just
display the records in that employee
table so as you can see the employee
table has various columns such as
employee ID employee name age
designation cities total salary date of
joining and Department ID Now using this
already created functions let's say if I
want to know whether the employee is
eligible for the bonus or not using
their total salary I'll use the function
and to achieve that I'll simply use the
select statement to display the records
so let me just write the query here
select I want to fetch the employee ID
employee name the total salary so I am
mentioning The Columns employee ID
employee name
their total salary
now I'll call this function here that is
our bonus status
and inside the function I am going to
pass the uh parameter which is the total
salary on which we'll know whether the
employee is eligible for bonus or not so
I am taking as total salary
from the table that is employee so let
us execute this statement and see the
output
so there was a mistake in the function
name so let us execute the statement now
and we'll see the output
so as you can see based on the total
salary and the functions that we have
created earlier it will result whether
or not the employee is eligible for
bonus or not now you can see the
employer Rahul who's having salary 40
000 which is above 35 000. so in this
case it is showing as eligible for bonus
now if you consider another employee
Varun whose salary is 30 000 Which is
less than 35 000 so that is why it is
showing us not eligible in this way and
for the rest of the employees also it
will show the uh same as per the
condition that we have specified in our
function that is the salary should be
greater than 35 000 so in this way you
can simply call a function using its
name and provide the parameter and get
the required output now the other
important thing to notice here is that
we have used the function as a column as
a parameter in our select query now we
have passed the parameter that is total
salary into our function so that is
bonus status and the function returned a
result of this calculation now in this
way a skill function can be very useful
as we have avoided writing complex
calculations in a select query and also
we can reuse this function later in any
other queries as well and that brings us
to the end of today's session guys I
hope you understood how to create a user
defined function
so what is commit and rollback in SQL
commit and rollback are the commonly
used transaction control language
commands or TCL commands used in SQL
these TCL commands or transaction
control language commands are basically
used for managing and controlling the
transactions in a database to maintain
consistency and it also helps a user
manage all the changes made by the DML
commands for maintaining its
transactions TCL lets the statements get
grouped into a logical transactions now
to understand more about commit and roll
back it is important to understand what
exactly are transactions now a
transaction is basically a block of SQL
query or set of SQL statements executed
on the information and data stored in
the database management system
so any transaction when made happens
temporarily or permanently in database
now a user needs TCL commands to make
these changes permanent or temporary
for example if you're creating a record
or updating a record or even deleting
the records from the table then you are
performing a transaction on that table
so it is important to control these
transaction to ensure that the data
Integrity is maintained and it also
handles the database errors effectively
so generally you will incorporate many
SQL queries into a group and you will
execute all of them together as a part
of a transaction
next let us discuss about the commit
command in SQL the commit command in SQL
is a transaction command that is used to
save all the changes made by a
particular transaction in rdbms since
the last commit our rollback command is
used it signifies the end of a
successful transaction in an SQL
database
now generally the commit command is used
after a data manipulation language a DML
operations like insert delete and update
transactions now when you perform a DML
operation without a commit statement the
changes are only visible to you now you
can use a select statement and check the
updated records from this modified data
but once you use a commit command after
a transaction the changes in the table
or database are visible to other
database users as well now another thing
to keep in mind is that the database
cannot be restored to its previous state
once the combat command is executed
all the transaction commands obeys the
basic principles of asset properties in
SQL and the Syntax for commit and SQL is
followed as you the easy text is
basically the is uses just one keyword
that is commit and you can use this
commit using various DML operators like
insert update delete statements as well
now let us say for example I have an
employee table and from that I want to
delete an employee a record whose ID is
110. now when I perform this query it
will delete the employee ID 110 and then
if I perform a commit operation then it
will permanently save that transaction
that is it will completely delete the
records from the table next let us
discuss about the rollback in SQL the
rollback in SQL is a command that is
used to revert changes performed by
transaction now whenever a rollback
command is used it reverts all the
changes since the last Commander a
rollback that we have made in our SQL
table
the syntax is similar to that it is
includes just one keyword that is
rollback and it is similarly used with
the insert update delete statement and
let's say for example I am deleting a
record whose ID is one not PSI and for
some reasons if I want that record back
in my table then I'll use the rollback
command here which will restore the
deleted record that is the the ID of the
employee who's having is one or five so
it will revert back the changes that
were made in the database by bringing
back the original state
let us now understand some differences
between commit and rollback
the comment is used to save the changes
permanently in the database whereas the
rollback is used to undo the changes and
restore its previous States
the comment statement is basically used
after an intended transaction which has
been successfully completed that is if
you are performing any SQL operations or
transaction in SQL and if you are sure
that if there is no changes to be made
for that transaction only then you have
to use the commit statement whereas a
roadblock statement is used after a
transaction is unsuccessful due to any
circumstances like system failure Etc
after executing commit command any
transaction can't be used for rollback
which you've discussed earlier and on
the other hand after executing the
rollback command a transaction can be
still modified and send for commit again
so now that we have understood what
comment and rollback are let us jump
into MySQL Workman for execution part
as you can see MySQL workbench has
started and now by default MySQL
automatically commits the changes
permanently to the database so in order
to First MySQL not to commit changes
automatically we use a following
statement here which is followed as set
auto commit
to 0 so let me just display this uh okay
it is successfully executed now what
this basically does is it will not
commit any changes permanently that were
done prior to the database earlier or
else you can click on edit option here
and choose preferences and in
preferences you'll find SQL execution
under the SQL editor section so you'll
find an option which says new
connections use Auto commit mode so if
you find a tick here in this checkbox
make sure you untick before you proceed
to commit and roll back commands so
click on OK so that you are good to go
now so let me just consider uh a table
here to perform the commit and roll back
commands here so for that I'm taking the
employee one table as a reference so let
me just display the records from that
table and I'll use the select statement
for that select star from employee one
so let me execute the statement
so in our employee one we have various
columns such as employee ID employee
name age designation City total salary
date of joining and Department ID
now to commit the current transaction
and make its changes permanent we use
the commit statement right so I'll use
the commit command here
and I'll execute this so now basically
what this does is it will
permanently or save the changes that
were done prior to this
database that is database table that is
the employment table
so let me just display the values now
so now let us perform some transactions
on this table so as we discussed earlier
we can use any DML operators like insert
update or delete to perform operations
using the commit and rollback command so
I'm going to use the update command here
so I'm basically updating the salary of
an employee let's say sanjana whose
employee ID is 2013 total salary is 30
000. now I want to update that salary as
35 000 so for that I'm using the update
statement
update the table name that is employee
one
set total salary
as 35
000.
where employee ID equals 2030.
so let us execute this statement
so as you can see one row has been
affected and our query has been executed
successfully let me just display the
records again
so as you can see uh employee sanjana
whose employee ad is thousand thirteen a
total salary has been changed to 35 000
which was earlier thirty thousand now
let's say in future I have this
requirement where I want to have the
original salary salary or the previous
salary now for that I can use the
rollback here
so when I execute the rollback
statement here and select this table
again
the total salary has been changed to 30
000 again so basically we have done a
transaction where we have upgraded the
total salary of the employee sanjana to
35 000 and after that we are again
rolling back to its previous state that
is again to thirty thousand
now similarly you can perform another
transaction let's say using the delete
operation now I want to delete all the
records from this employee one table
whose designation is let's say business
analyst now we have a total of business
analyst uh one two three right we have
total three records so we'll be deleting
all these requests from the table so
tell it from employee one
where
designation
equals to
business analyst
right so let me just execute the
statement
sorry the column name has been returned
wrong so that is why it is showing me as
error
so as you can see our query has been
successfully executed and it shows three
rows are affected that makes all the
records of the employees whose
designation is business analysts have
been deleted see as you can clearly see
there are no records of business analyst
records right so again I have this
requirement where I want to get back the
results or the records of the employees
who are working as business analyst
from this employee one table so for that
I can simply use the rollback here so
we'll simultaneously perform to a
transaction here firstly we'll update
this table again
and then we'll delete which was already
done
so now let me just roll back this
statement again
so when I roll back this statement and
display the records from the table as
you can clearly see the employee sanjana
whose employed is 1013 her salary which
we have set as 35 000 has been reverted
back to 30 000 to its previous or
original state and similarly we have
deleted uh the records of employees
whose designation as business analyst
and similarly their records also have
been reverted back
so in this way you can use the rollback
command to get back to the current
transaction and cancel it changes
now let us take another scenario here
now what if I perform a transaction
before the commit command so for that
I'll take another another example where
I'll update the age of an employee let's
say Rahul is employed is 1013 and is
ages 26 I want to change it to 27 so
I'll use another update statement here
update
employee one table
equals to 27 so his previous age was 26
now I'm changing it to 27.
where employee ID is uh 1011.
all right so let me just execute the
statement
so it is successfully executed and we
will select the records so as you can
see rahul's age has been changed to 27
from 26. now let's say if I commit this
uh
transaction all right so I'll just
commit this transaction so basically you
cannot make any further changes uh to
this record since we have committed uh
the transaction already
so
I'll perform the uh two transactions
again here which is basically updating
the employee's total salary to 35 000
and deleting all the records of
employees whose designation is business
analyst so let me just uh
execute this
so as you can clearly see all our skill
queries has been successfully executed
so let me just display the table here
now
so as you can clearly see that we uh the
employee sanjana who's having one
employee ideas 1013 her salary has been
changed to 35
000 and we also have uh no records of
those employees whose designation is
business analyst and similarly the first
transaction which you have done which is
updating the salary of uh employee Rahul
whose ID is 2011 to 27. now let's say if
I want to roll back this Trends all
these transactions so let me just roll
back here and we'll see what happens so
our rollback has been successfully
executed and let me just display the
records again
now all the changes done past the last
commit will be reverted if you roll back
a transaction since we have uh performed
two operations or transactions after
commit statement which is basically
updating uh the employee salary to 35
000 and delete the records of employees
whose designation as business analyst
now clearly we can see that their
records have been reverted back to their
original state so so like we have this
employee name sanjana whose salary was
30 000 which is we have changed to 35
000 and since we have rolled back again
to its previous state it is 30 000 and
similarly we all we have all the records
of the business analyst as well but if
you look at here we have
change the employees age here like we
have taken rahul's
age as 27 which was earlier 26 and we
have changed that to 27 but even after
rolling back this we haven't uh got the
original record that is his age is 26
that's because we have already committed
this transaction so it will basically uh
not revert back to its previous state
so once the comment statement has
executed the modification made by the
transaction it cannot be rolled back
again however once the rollback
statement is executed the database
reaches its previous state
so that brings us to the end of today's
session guys now that was all about the
commit and rollback uh commands in SQL
so basically to ensure that the changes
made by the transactions have
permanently saved in the database we use
the commit after the transaction
successful completion in case the
transaction faces any error while
execution then to undo or revert the
changes done by the transaction a
rollback command is used now you might
uh get a doubt that where we have to use
this and where this is applicable now if
you are an SQL Developer or even a
beginner who is working on a database
let's say you're working on a database
which has thousands of records and
you're modifying let's say a 100 records
in that now due to some errors you want
to revert back all the changes that you
have made right so for that you will
basically use the rollback function for
that so in this way it will be helpful
uh for getting the records again back to
its original state
firstly let us understand what is SQL
like loss the like operator is used to
find specific characters in a tables
column it is also used to compare
columns with the specified values
together with the where Clause it
determines if a pattern matches specific
values in a table it uses Wild Card
characters which are characters used to
replace one or more characters in a
string to fulfill this purpose you can
also use like when only a portion of the
value in that table is known let us now
understand the syntax the syntax is
simple it is usually used with the
select command and the syntax of this is
followed as select column 1 column 2 so
on up to column n from table name where
column name like and pattern now
basically the columns to be shown in the
result table are specified after the
select statement the column that is
designed for pattern matching is
specified in the where clause and the
pattern forms from the specific row
selection which is defined in the
pattern parameter of the like operator
now the like operator is case
insensitive that means you can either
give capital or small letters as well
now multiple patterns can be specified
with this operator using the and or or
keywords as well and while car
characters are the most vital tools of
this operator so let's go over what
these are and how they are used with the
like operator
so what is wild car character now Wild
Card characters are special symbols and
characters used to represent one or more
than one character in a string these are
imperative to the like operator as this
enable patterns to be specified that is
it filters the data using certain
patterns to identify a value of a string
in the database now the two wired cars
used with the like operator are
generally percent and the underscore now
the percent sign is used to represent
zero or one or more characters whereas
the underscore is used to represent
exactly one character now to get a clear
picture of both these characters let us
look at an example uh in an SQL
statement and see how they are used now
consider this following example which is
Select employee ID employee name from
employees where name like a percent
now from the stable employee if you want
to know the employee ID of all the
employees whose name start with a letter
or character a you should use this
following query which is the uh
character or the pattern we are using
here is a percentage
now as we discussed earlier you can also
use a small letter range sort of capital
letter A because the like operator is
not K sensitive
now there are many operations that can
you that you can perform using by
specifying different patterns using the
like operators now for example if you
have to find a value that starts with a
then the following query would be where
column name like a pattern so basically
we are mentioning the pattern here as a
percentage which will retrieve all those
uh string values which starts with the
character a now similarly if you want to
find values that end with let's say s h
then you have to use percentage SH now
similarly if you want to find values
that can have a character a in any
position then you have to mention the
pattern as where column name like
percentage a percentage which basically
returns any values that contain the
letter a in any position and similarly
you can use the underscore operator as
well let's say if you want to return
only exact return exactly one character
then you have to mention a single
underscore sign now let's say if you
want to find values that have a
character a in third position then the
following query would be where column
name like and within the single quotes
you have to mention three underscores
that is uh three times you have to
specify the underscore that would be
present before the character a and then
you have to mention the percentage
and similarly you have these different
types of operations which you can take a
screenshot of this by pausing this video
now
so now that you have understood how
exactly SQL like works let us jump into
MySQL workbench to understand in depth
on how these exactly work by using their
different examples
getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit skillup by simply learn click
on the link in the description to know
more
as you can see MySQL workbench just
started and in order to execute the SQL
like Operator Let Us consider a
following table in our database let's
say new employees on which will apply
various operations using the like
operator so let me first display the
records that are present in the new
employees table and for that I'm using
the select operator and the query select
star from new employees
so let me just execute this and a new
employees table has various columns such
as employee ID first name last name
email phone number hiring date job ID
salary manager ID and Department
so firstly let us discuss some examples
using the person Wild Card which
basically uses the percentage sign right
so let's say if I want to fetch the
details of all those employees whose
first name starts with a or let's say s
then the following query would be select
star
from the table name that is new
employees
where is the conditional clause
first name
like is the keyword
and within the single quotes mention s
percentage
now it is important to enclose all the
patterns that you have specified in a
single inverted comma otherwise the
query will return a syntax error so let
me just display this and execute this
so when you execute this query it has
returned me seven rows as you can see in
the output which basically returns all
those employees name whose uh first name
starts with the character that is s so
we have like different employees like
Susan Mavericks Shelley Higgins Shelley
bada sigal Tobias and Etc
now similarly let's say if you want to
fetch the details of all those employees
whose uh last name or like first name
ends with uh let us take a character
let's say uh n so let me just display
and execute the query
so when you execute this query it
basically returns all those employees uh
details whose first name ends with n
like for example if you consider here
Susan maveris whose first name has uh n
in the last position and similarly we
have Hermann bear John Chen den rafley
and Etc
next let us take another example let's
say if I want to select all the
employees whose first name starts with
let's say S and ends with
let's say in
so then the following query would be
select
star from new employee
where
first name
like
now the first character would be S and
you have to mention it percentage symbol
and the next last character would be n
so let me just display execute this
statement so as you can see we have a
records of three employees whose uh
first name have the letter or the
character s in the first place and the
character and in the last phase for
example Susan maveris in the first name
we have S in the first place and then in
the last place similarly we have Stephen
Markle and Stephen styles
now let us take another example let's
say uh I want to find the details of the
particular employee now the thing is I
don't know the exact name of that
employee but I know that uh his salary
is somewhere between 30 000 and 50 000.
so for that I can use the and or
operator here so the following query
would be select
star
from new employee
where
first name
like
let's say if I know the employee name
starts with uh K okay then well mention
a percentage symbol
and we'll mention uh the and operator
here and salary between thirty thousand
foreign
so let us execute this statement and
we'll see the output
so when you execute this we can see that
there are no records in the table that
means there is no employee whose name
starts with k and a salary is between 30
000 and 50 000. so let us take another
example let's say the employees name
starts with j
so and a salary somewhere between thirty
thousand and fifteen thousand so let me
just execute the statement
now as you can see in a result set we
have three different employees uh
Jennifer Valen Julian Eyre and Jason
Malin whose salary is between 30 000 and
50 000 respectively like we have forty
four thousand thirty two thousand and
thirty three thousand so in this way you
can find the details of employee even if
you do not know the complete details but
just by specifying the pattern uh of
their name or the character that we have
in their name you can fetch their
details now if you want to if you
further know that department ID let's
say uh Jennifer Valen Department ID is
10 and she belongs to that department
and I want to get the details of that
employee only then I can retrieve their
details in this way so I hope you've
understood how to use the percentage
sign to find the different patterns uh
in order to find the complete uh string
value from the table let us now discuss
uh some examples using the underscore
wild character using the under under
score symbol
so let me take an example here let's say
if you want to fetch the details of all
those employees who have exactly three
characters in their first name so in
that case the following query would be
select star from new employees
where
first name
like and within the codes now we we've
discussed there should be only three
exactly three characters in their name
right so we'll mention the underscore
three times one two three
close the single brackets and let us
execute this statement
so as you can see it has fetched a total
of four records uh for example Pat Fay
uh we have only three characters that is
p80 in his first name and similarly we
have Lex Dahan then rapidly guy himro
all these employees have only exactly
three characters in their first name
let us talk take another example let's
say if you want to select all the
employees with the first name that
starts with s and are at least five
characters in length then in that case
the following query would be select star
from new employees
where
first name
like
single quotes now the first character
would be S so I'm mentioning s and after
s we have to mention the underscore four
times
that basically means it will return an
exactly of at least five characters in
our employees table who's having the
first name uh having five characters
so let me just execute this statement
and we'll see the output
so as you can see we have two records of
employees Susan Mavericks and Seagal
Tobias now if you look uh carefully
Susan whose first name has a total of
five characters that there's Susa and
that is five and similarly we have
Seagal now if you want at least uh let's
say five characters in length then you
have to mention the percentage sign
so it basically means uh the employees
name will start with s and it will have
at least five characters in length so
let me just execute this statement
so it will display all those records uh
whose first name is starts with the
character s and have at least five
characters in their first name
so we have Susan mavres like we have
also Shelley who's uh
who's having let's say one two three
four five six seven characters in total
in their in her first name
so in this way retrieve all those values
whose first name starts with s and
basically have at least five characters
in length
as you can see MySQL Workman just
started now in order to find the nth
highest salary we need an employee table
and for that I'm going to consider the
new employees table here so let me just
display the records that are present in
the table
and for that I'll use the select
statement and the query is followed as
select star from new employees
so let me just display the results so as
you can see the new employees table has
various columns such as employee ID
first name last name email phone number
hiring date salary manager ID and
Department
so firstly before discussing how to find
the highest salary let us see how to
find the maximum salary now to find the
maximum salary in SQL you can simply use
the aggregate function Max to find the
highest salary in SQL so the following
query would be select Max
salary
from the table that is new employees
so let me just display the results so as
you can see it is showing as 93 000
which is the highest salary in our table
now next to find the second highest
salary in the above table we'll use the
concept of sub query which means that
firstly we'll find the highest salary in
the table and then we'll Nest that query
to a sub query to find the second
highest album SQL so the query would
basically be us now I'll put this as a
sub query here
and I'll write the outermost query now
that is
select
salary
from the table that is new employees
where salary is less than this inner
query or the sub query
so let us just execute this query and
see the output now it will display all
the salaries that are great that is less
than the uh sub query that we have
written here that is the maximum salary
which is 93 000. now that is not the
answer that we want or the results that
we want now we want the maximum salary
Which is less than the 93 000 so I'm
going to take the max function again
here
foreign
so basically how this query works is the
firstly the inner query gets executed
which is the maximum salary that is 93
000 next the outer query executes that
is it will select the maximum salary
from the new employee table which is
less than the 93 000. so let me just
display the results
so as you can see it is showing as 90
000 and as the second highest salary so
let us just verify whether it is correct
or not I'll use the select statement
again select star from new employees
we'll use the order by order by function
order by salary and I'll display the
values in descending order that means
from highest to lowest
so in this way we can find the highest
salary
and the corresponding service that are
less than the highest salary so as you
can clearly see that we have nine three
thousand as our highest salary and the
next salary as 90 000 as our next second
highest salary now till now it is fine
now let's say if you are asked to find
the fifth highest salary or let's say
20th highest salary basically in highest
salary from this table now you can't
keep on adding sub queries to this
already uh return query right it will
become time consuming and it becomes
complex as well
now in general there are two ways to
find the nth highest salary the first
one is using the limit clause and the
second one is using uh the dense rank
function which is an inbuilt function
provided by SQL which we are going to
discuss about in a while so firstly let
us discuss about the uh
limit clause and how we'll use the limit
Clause to find the nth highest salary
here
so firstly let us understand the syntax
here now the syntax is followed as
select column list
from table name order by expression
limit n minus 1 comma 1 so let me just
explain the syntax here now after the
select statement you will have to
mention all the columns that you want to
fetch in your resultant table from the
table name order by expression which is
this basically the column name you have
to specify here and you are using the
limit keyword and after that we have two
parameters here that is n minus 1 comma
1. Now in the syntax the limit n minus 1
comma 1 Clause returns one row that
starts after the row end now in other
words if I have to Define this the first
parameter that is n minus 1 defines
after how many rows it will start
fetching the records in a resultant set
and the second parameter will uh
basically return the number of rows in
that table
so let me just explain this with an
example so select now I'll use the
distinct keyword here which will
basically remove all the uh
anomalies or the repeated values in our
table so distinct salary from table name
that is new employees
order by salary
limit now let's say if I want to find
the 10th highest salary in our table so
now our n becomes 10 so the value here
it will be n minus 1 so 10 minus 1 is
basically 9 comma 1. now what this query
basically does is it will return one
record after the first nine rows that is
basically the tenth row which is the
query that we want that is to find the
10th highest salary so let me just
execute this statement
okay there is an error
so yes uh the query is returning me as
24 000 which is the 10th highest salary
here now similarly if you want to find
the let's say uh 24th highest salary
I'll just change the value into 24
so oh sorry uh so basically if you
wanted to find the 24th highest salary
you will have to mention 23 here that is
n minus 1 right so let us find the
output so the next highest salary is 48
000.
uh so I forgot to mention the descending
keyword here that is why it is showing
me the uh highest value so if I run this
query again
so the 24th highest salary here is 29
900. so in this way you can basically
use the limit Clause to find the nth
highest salary
now let's say if I want to fetch the
complete details of that employee who is
having the 24th highest salary I'll
simply use a sub query here so I'll put
this query as a sub query and I'll write
another outer query using the select
statement
select star
from new employees
where
salary
is equals to
the inner query so let me just execute
this query and we'll see the output so
now it will display the complete details
of the employee uh their employee ID
first name last name email phone number
their salary manager ID department and
Etc so in this way if you want to fetch
the complete details as well you can use
this sub query here
now let's say if you are asked to find
the first five highest salaries in the
table then the parameter here will be
changed now here our n value becomes 1
so the N minus 1 becomes 0. now and we
want to fetch the first five records
from the table so we'll mention five as
our second parameter which will
basically display the first five records
so let me just display and execute this
statement so as you can see it will
display the first five highest salary
starting from ninety three thousand
ninety thousand next eighty eight
thousand eighty three thousand and next
eighty two thousand now if you have to
observe this query carefully it is
somewhat similar to that of the top
function we use now since stop function
is not applicable in MySQL we are using
the limit Clause here now if you are
working on different other databases
like SQL server or mongodb or Oracle you
can use the top function now the format
uh will remain the same only the syntax
will change with the use of top keyword
so in this way you can use the limit for
Clause to find the nth highest salary
let us not discuss the second way that
is using the dense rank function
now MySQL dense rank function is an
irbin function which is used to return
sequential numbers starting from 1 based
on the ordering of rows imposed by the
order by Clause now when you have two
records with the same data set then it
will give the same rank to the both rows
so firstly let us understand the syntax
here the syntax is followed as select
column list these are basically all the
columns that you want to fetch in your
resultant table comma dense run is the
keyword we use here over and inside the
parenthesis we are writing the order by
uh clause and we'll mention the
expression as and will give a Alias name
to this
dense rank function from the table name
so now basically uh the function is
always used with Over clause here which
will always assign rank on basis of the
order by clause and the rank is also
assigned to the rows in a sequential
manner that is the rack the assignment
of rank to this rows will always starts
from 1 and the next value will be 1
greater than the previous ranker side so
let us understand this with an example
now let's say I'm
I'll use the select Clause here and I
want to display the employee ID
the first name of the employee
last name
comma salary
and next I'll mention the Denso dense
rank keyword
over
and inside the brackets use the order by
clause and mention the uh expression now
we want to specify the condition here
which is basically on the salary right
we want to find the nth highest salary
here so we'll specify the salary here
as uh let's give an Aliyah's name let's
say a rank salary
from the table that is
new employee
so let us execute the statement and
we'll see the output
so as you can see it will display the
employee ID the first name last name
salary and the rank of the salary
now since we haven't given any uh
a keyword here for descending and
ascending it is showing in the ascending
order by default so let me just write
the descending keyword by using the tesc
so let us now display this
as you can clearly see it will display
the records from highest to the lowest
value and the rank is aside accordingly
now for the salary 93 000 it is giving
rank as one and for ninety thousand two
for eighty eight thousand three and so
on now if you look here like the uh
employee Adams rib who's having 82 000
as salary and similarly John Chen who's
also having 82 000 salary and the rank
is assigned as 5 which is same now if
you carefully look here it will assign
rank based on the value and not on the
number so even if the values are
repeated it will assign the same rank to
that value
foreign
so I hope you understood how to use the
dense rank function here now let's say
to find the nth highest salary we'll
have to use a sub query here now
basically I'll keep this as a sub query
here and I'll use another select
statement
so basically I want to again display the
employee ID first name last name and
salary in a resultant table so I'll just
copy this
and keep it as an outer query
from
this uh table right so and I'll mention
a wear condition where rank salary
is equals to now you can mention the
entire cellular whatever you want to
display you can mention this here now
let's say if I want to find the uh 32nd
highest salary I'll just mention the
rank salary equals to 32 so let us now
execute this statement and we'll see the
output
now it will show me an error basically
here which says every derived table must
have its own Alias name so we have not
given uh any a specifically as an import
table here so let us just give a layers
name let's say as e or you can take EMP
or anything as per your choice right so
let me just display this and we'll see
the output so as you can see the 30 what
is that 30 second highest salary uh has
been assigned to the employee Hazel Phil
tanker who sell this 22 000. so let's
just check whether it is correct or not
I'll just copy this dense rank select
statement again
so let's just scroll down and as you can
see uh 32
which is the rank here has been assigned
to the employee Hazard Phil tanker who
Salvage 22 000 so which is correct and
your successfully executed query in this
case now similarly if you want to find
another uh
employee salary let's say if you want to
find 18 16 highest salary where you take
this
will execute the statement and it is
showing me as the 48 000 which is the
16th highest salary and the employee ID
is 105 the employee name is David Austin
so what is web SQL web storage API
offers a really nice way to store key
value pair data information within the
user browser itself without any hassle
and in a convenient way but what if you
need to store complex relational data
and perform simple or complex queries on
this data well web storage does not
allow this but web SQL database does
basically web SQL database is a web
browser API specification for storing
and managing data in databases that can
be queried using a variant of SQL that
means just like any other SQL databases
web SQL also provides a way to store the
data in the database that can be queried
using various SQL statements now the w3c
or the World Wide Web Consortium stop
supporting the usage of web SQL database
specification however it is still
implemented and supported by some
browsers like Google Chrome Android and
some mobile versions of safari and Apple
iOS as well
now although web SQL tends to be labeled
as an HTML5 feature where SQL database
is not exactly a part of the HTML5
specification but it is a part of a
separate suit of specifications which
introduces a set of apis to manipulate
client-side databases in using SQL now
client-side means that the processing
takes place on the user's computer it
requires browsers to run the scripts on
the client machine without involving any
processing on the server now server side
means the processing takes place on a
web server and this processing is vital
and important to execute the task
required by the user on the web now
since the client-side script is executed
on the client's computer it is visible
onto the client and on the other hand
the server-side script is executed in
This Server hence it is not visible to
the users so web SQL is kind of risky to
use because it stores the data at the
client side and not on the server side
so if the user or someone outside your
own browser who has the HTML script or
the syntax ready of the web SQL that you
are creating he can have the access and
he can manage the browser or the API as
well so that is why web SQL helps
developers to perform database
operations on client-side like creating
databases opening transactions creating
tables into inserting values to tables
deleting and reading data from it
the core methods in web SQL now core
methods are an important concept of web
SQL because they are used to perform
credit operations like create update
delete and read operations on the
database now when web SQL there are
mainly Three core methods they are open
database transaction and finally we have
execute SQL
firstly open database now open database
it creates a database object using the
existing database or you can also create
a new one
next we have transaction this method is
used to control a transaction and can
perform commit or roll back depending on
the situation
and finally execute SQL it is used
basically used to execute read and write
operations to perform the result of the
query that means it is used to execute
the actual SQL query that we are
performing on the web SQL
so let us now discuss about them in
detail
creating an opening database in web SQL
as you all know to work with SQL queries
you must first create a database so the
first step we are going to follow is
creating a database now in order to
start communication with the database
you have to use the open database method
which will basically create a database
object now if you try to open a database
that doesn't exist the system will
automatically create a database for you
and eventually a database object will be
created for that and open the database
we have to use the following syntax as
VAR DB obj DB obj is basically the
object that I have taken to our database
is equals to open database is the method
and inside the parenthesis we have to
mention first the database name version
number text description size and
creation callback so let me just uh
explain about these terms so by using
this open database function we can
basically create a database in web SQL
and open the database and these are
basically the five parameter meters that
are accepted by the open database
function the first one is database name
this argument provides the name of the
database which is mandatory to be
provided otherwise you will get an error
next we have the version number the
version number is also required now some
database may be in version 1.0 or some
may be in 2.0 so if you know the version
number of the database then only you can
open the database that you're working on
next we have the text description this
argument describes the database and
provides information about the database
now you can provide any any sort of
description to your database that you
are working on next we have the size of
the database this argument decides the
size of the database basically which is
generally in mb
and finally we have a creation callback
now if the database does not exist and
yet it is being created this callback
will be invoked so it is optional and is
not needed for the database to be
created and eventually we can apply if
you want
so in this way you can successfully
create and open a database so let me
just take an example here I have taken
uh DB as my database object here open
database and the name of the database is
library and the version is 1.0 and the
text description I've given is my
library and the size I've taken is 5
into 2024 into 2024 which is basically
uh 5 MB now the size is basically from
1mb to 5 MB Max so you have to take in
that range itself
next let us discuss about how we create
transaction and use execute SQL method
now once the database is created and
open we want to create a new table to
store and manage that data now any SQL
operation like creating a table or
inserting data into a table has to
happen in a transaction a transaction is
basically a set of operations in web SQL
now transaction provides uh two features
namely rollback and commit if a
transaction fails at any point in time
or a query has an error then it will be
rolled back including all the queries
that you have inserted and if all the
queries are successfully executed then
the transaction will be committed now
the Syntax for for creating a
transaction is basically DB which is a
database object dot transaction which is
the keyword or the method now inside the
uh parenthesis we will write a function
TX TX is basically the object of the
transaction now since we created our
database object DB and using the open
database method we can perform a
transaction here using the database
method transaction now the transaction
basically can take up to three arguments
the first one is transaction callback
the second one is error callback and the
last one is Success callback now these
arguments are optional and so here I'm
just using the transaction itself now in
the transaction callback I have an
attribute TX that as we've discussed
earlier which is a transaction object
now I'll use the execute SQL method of
this object to create a new table that
is author now I'm using this execute SQL
method to create a table author which
has ID first name last name as different
columns now just like in SQL we provide
a primary key to one of the column which
uniquely identifies each and record
similarly we provide with the keyword
unique to identify the records uniquely
in this so for that I am taking ID as
our unique column and once it's done to
execute this query in web SQL we will
use the method executed SQL as usual so
let us now discuss how to insert a new
record in our table to our database so
now that you have a database that is
library and have created a table that is
authors earlier will now insert the
records into our table now for that I'll
be using the execute SQL method again on
the transaction instance so the open
database Remains the Same now
additionally I'll just take the
transaction method here following that I
am using a function T so the query would
be T dot execute X SQL and similar to
that of what we we write in our SQL
statement we use the same insert command
here as well and the syntax is insert
into authors first name last name and
values I'm taking as James priest now
consider the below example which is same
uh I'm just inserting some more values
into our table for that I am using
another execute SQL method using the TX
function which is an attribute to our
method that we have used in our function
so TX dot execute SQL insert into author
now I'm taking another attribute or say
I'm adding another column ID which is
unique so first name and last name
values as I'm taking ideas to Rohan
Nanda similarly I'm taking another
record that is three uh Kiran and Kumar
so in this way you can use the insert
statement to add new records into a
table in a web SQL
so now that we have inserted some values
into our table we need to read the data
that we have inserted into a table right
so to do that we need to create another
new transaction and another execute SQL
command should be implemented here
so now that we know how to add the data
into our databases now you have to read
and display those records back to the
user in their browser and for that we
need to create a simple select statement
to read all values from the authors
table here now when execute SQL is
called this time a callback method is
passed that accepts a transaction object
and the result set containing the rows
that we have inserted into our table
will be returned in our SQL statement
now you can see the Callback method that
I have used is display result which I am
again putting it in the select statement
as well
now as the display result method
iterates through this rows it formats
the person's name in the list and adds
it to an unorder list with the uh ID as
well
so in this way we can execute and
finally we can see the output of our
data so let me just take an example here
so I'll jump to notepad and uh I'll show
you a script on the web SQL that I've
already created
so this is how the script or the whole
syntax of the queries that are performed
in web SQL will look like now as I have
discussed earlier this is somewhat kind
of based on HTML so I'm not going into
detail about this if you want to learn
more about SQL we have a dedicated
playlist on our Channel where we have
discussed about HTML and JavaScript
Concepts in detail so make sure you
check that out
so to keep it simple the first part this
is basically the header part and we have
the body and inside the body we
basically write our SQL query here now
first of all I've created a variable
I've called a variable DB obj which is
the database object in which I'm calling
the open database method so every time
this open database method is called a
reference of this database will be sent
to this database object which is DB obj
and if I want to perform any further
operations on this database I'll use the
same object only instead of creating a
new one every time
so I've created a database here as my
database with version as 1.0 and I've
kept the text description as my first
web SQL example you can write
description of your own choice uh
database size I'm giving it as 2 MB
which should be in the format as 2 into
2024 into 1024 and I'm writing the query
for opening the database that is the DV
obj which is a database object open
database method and inside that I'm
calling all this variables inside the
body now I'm using the execute SQL
command here inside the function TX
and this method performs a very
important role in web SQL database this
method is basically used to execute read
and write statements and it provides a
callback method to process the result of
any query
so I've created a table here employee
table and I've created column as ID name
and their location now I am using a
function insert which will insert all
the values into our table columns that
is ID name and location and finally I am
using the Callback method here to read
the data that we have created in our
tables using the select operator that is
Select Staff from employee table and I
am using the Callback function here as
well
so that is it now this is all not
related this is from Pure basically on
HTML which is basically I've created
form which will take the input from the
user and I've created different tabs for
ID name location and I also created an
insert button so that the user will
insert the data into the values
and again this is completely based on
HTML guys so you might need a reference
of HTML first to understand this so I
would recommend you to first check the
HTML videos on tags attributes and all
so that it will be clear so let me just
execute this statement now and let us
see the output
so we have to save the file in the HTML
format so I'm
[Music]
so as you can see our file has been
created and let us open this so as you
can see it will display ID name location
and in and it will ask me to insert
values into it so let me just uh insert
values I've already taken one value so
let me just take another here I am
taking IDs to name as let's say Rahul
location in Mumbai so click on insert
button it will insert the values into
our table now similarly you can add a
number of values as per your choice let
us take another example here IDs 3 name
Kiran
and location as Chennai
so in this way we can add values into
our table it will keep on adding every
time you insert a new value into these
three uh columns that is ID name and
location so that was all about web SQL
guys I hope you understood the concept
that you are covered in today's tutorial
so firstly what is cast function the
cache function in SQL is one of the most
commonly used conversion function which
allows the user to convert from one data
type to another it is very useful for
concatenating results from various data
types now this conversion can be either
a single expression or the values from
the columns in the SQL tables
it also allows the user to perform
calculations on two different data types
as well now using cast it does not
change the data completely in the
database this conversion of data from
one data type to another is only valid
while the query is running and is not
permanent that is the changes to the
query is only done on a temporary basis
however it is possible to convert and
insert into a new column or table as
well let us now understand the syntax of
cache function the syntax is followed as
cast expression as data type length
expression here represents the data
which we want to convert and the data
type specifies uh the data type which we
want to convert the value and finally
the length of the data which is optional
you can give it as per your requirement
for only certain data types such as
ncare or VAR care
now let us consider an example here
which says select cached 76.87 as it
here I am taking a string value which is
76.87 and I'm converting this data type
into the int value now the output is as
expected that is 76 which is an integer
value in this way you can use the cast
function to change one data type to
another data type in real time
next let us discuss about what is
convert function
the convert function converts an
expression in one data type to
corresponding value in other data type
now you might be confused that the
convert is different from the cache
function convert is similar to that of
cache function as well while the
functionality of both these conversion
functions is same the only main
difference is the syntax and the usage
so you can specify the format to convert
as well as the data type in the convert
function and it is a very useful
function especially for converting the
strings to date formats and the syntax
is followed as convert expression comma
data type now again the data type
parameter defines the target data which
is to be converted now and the data type
parameter can take data types as an
input such as big in small and decimal
numeric values float values character
values variable characters in care Etc
and the length is optional parameter
which specifies the target data type
length and the default of this parameter
is around 10 or 20.
now we also have the expression this
parameter specifies the value in which
we want to convert to another data type
so let us consider an example here which
is Select convert
2022.06.07 as date now this is basically
a string value or you can say a part of
a decimal value and I'm changing this
string or character into date format
which is 2022 hyphen 0 6 hyphen 0 7
which is converted into date format so
in this way you can use the convert
function as well
let us now understand the difference
between the cast and convert function in
SQL now both these SQL conversion
functions are row functions which are
capable of type casting column values or
an expression from one data type to
another and the functionality of both of
the functions are almost similar but
there are some major differences in them
as well
now both the cash function convert
function are obviously are used to
convert one data type to another data
type and one of the main difference is
the syntax now the syntax of cast is
very simple it includes the value to
convert and the type of resulting data
type it has as a keyword to separate the
data type from the value and there is an
option to express the length which is
the integer that specifies the length of
the target data type and on the other
hand the convert syntax mentions the
resulting data type first along with the
optional length there is another
expression and another optional
parameter called style in the convert
function which is only specific to the
SQL Server database now this style
allows formatting the data type and
specifies how the convert function
should translate or format the data type
now apart from this there are some
certain differences as well the cache is
an ANSI standard function that is cast
is uh considered as the American
National Standard institute's standard
function that means it is applicable to
most of the SQL databases out there like
postview SQL MySQL mariadb mongodb
Etc
on the other hand conversion function is
a specific function that is only
restricted to mainly Microsoft SQL
Server cast function is also more
portable function of these two it means
that the cache function can be used by
many databases out there and also cache
is considered less powerful and less
flexible than the convert function and
on the other hand the convert function
is generally considered as a flexible
function which allows more flexibility
and is mostly preferred to use for date
time values Etc convert is also useful
in formatting the data's format as well
and finally cache function is used to
convert a data type without a specific
format whereas the convert function does
converting and formatting data types
simultaneously
now for example cast cannot convert a
date time to specific format whereas the
convert function can do that
so these were some major differences
between the cache and convert function I
know you might be confusing at first
because there isn't much difference
between these two functions and also
there is no difference in the
performance of these two functions as
well so it's just a matter of preference
to choose which function to use you can
choose to use cast when you work with
multiple relational databases and the
syntax is a pretty standardized easy to
remember and since it is an ANSI
standard function you can use it in any
database as well
on the other hand if you need to specify
the output styling we can use the
convert function for that and even
though the style is optional and is
limited to certain uh databases like SQL
Server the cast function is often is
used to preserve decimal values and
places while converting between decimal
numeric values whereas the convert
function cannot do this so it is a
matter of requirement when to use both
these functions and it is up to the user
to choose between these both conversion
functions so now that we have understood
about these two functions let us jump
into MySQL workbench for execution part
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit scale up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
as you can see MySQL workbench has
started and we can now work on our
conversion functions firstly let us
discuss about the cast function in SQL
so let us take an example for this let's
say if I want to convert a string value
into an integer data type then the
following query would be select
cast and within the parenthesis let's
say I have a string value which is
45.68 and I want to change this into int
data type so I'll mention int
as end which is the keyword we use in
the cast functions so let us now execute
the statement and see the output
now it will show me an error that's
because the in data type is not
supported in MySQL workbench if you are
working on cast function so instead of
into you can take the sine function
which is basically a sister group of the
int data type so you can take the signed
integer as well so let us now display
this value so as you can see it will
return me the 46 which will round off
the decimal value which is 45.68 to 46.
now let us take another example let's
say I have a string value I want to
change it into date format so then the
following query would be select cast
so let me just uh take some the string
values like 22 comma
9 comma 24.
as date
so let us execute this statement and
we'll see the output
so as you can see the string value that
we have taken here that suggests 22 924
has been changed into date format which
is 2022 which is the year 9 is the month
and 24 is the date which is in the
format of year month and date now if you
pass the values here which is not in the
range of the function that of the
derivative that you have specified in
this function for example instead of 9
if I take 14 and let's say if I want to
pass this function then it will show me
a null value that's because the value 14
is not in the range of the date value
that is 14 there are only like 12 months
rights from so the values it can take is
from only from 1 to 12. now if you pass
other than this range then it will show
an error now similarly if I want to uh
specify this value into date time
function then I can simply mention the
daytime function data type as well
so let us see the output
so it will show me the output in the
form of a date as well as the time
format here
so let us now understand another example
now as discussed earlier a cast function
not only changes the data type of an
expression it can also change the data
type of the column values in the table
as well so for that let us take an
example for this let me consider the
restaurant orders table here
now I have this price column which is in
decimal values now let's say if I want
to round off these values into integer
values then the following query would be
select cast
mention the parameter which is price as
signed
from the table name that is restaurant
orders
so let us execute and see the output
so as you can see the prices are being
changed into the integer values now and
the decimal values have been rounded off
so similarly if I want to mention the
columns I can mention them as well so
I'll take the item name the previous
price and the change price so I'm giving
this change price as the new price as a
new column
so let us now execute this statement and
see the output so as you can see it will
display uh the item name the price and
the new price of these items now as you
can see the price of the Tandoori mix
Grill which is 11.95 has been rounded
off to an integer value that is 12 and
similarly all the other values as well
now if you scroll down a bit as you can
see we have a price which is 0.5 and the
new price is changed into zero which is
not acceptable right now the price has
should be of a value now instead of sign
if you can take the decimal data type uh
wherein you can mention this and it will
change the value into the nearest value
of the decimal value now as you can see
here the 0.5 has been rounded off to 1
here and similarly 0.8 which is more
than 0.5 is also rounded to 1. so in
this way you can use the cast function
to change the data type accordingly so
now that we have covered the cached
functions let us now see a few data type
conversions here which will help you
understand the usage of the conversion
convert function as well
now firstly let us start with the
decimal data type now as the date as the
name suggests decimal produces a decimal
value and has two optional parameters
which is basically m and d where m is
the maximum number of digits that you
want to show in the resultant table or
which is also known as precision and D
is the number of digits after the
decimal points from the scale are you
understand with an example here so the
following query would be select convert
and inside the convert mention the
expression so I'm taking the value as
let's say 21.345
and I want to change this value into
decimal data type
and inside the decimal I am mentioning
the parameters so I'm taking as let's
say
7 as the total number of digits that I
will display and I'm taking only two
decimal values that I want to display
after the decimal point
all right so let us just execute this
statement and we'll see the output
so as you can see it will show me only
the uh two values that is 3 5 after the
decimal point so the output is 21.35 now
the value that we have taken is 21.345
which is converted into decimal uh data
type format which is 21.35 basically it
will round off the value of 345 into 3
5.
now similarly you can convert the values
into date and time data types as well in
using the convert function so let us
consider the example for that as well so
select convert
let's say now I have a value 10 comma 25
as date time
data type so we'll convert this into
date times uh data type so let's see the
output
so as you can see the value the string
value which you have specified here as
11 10 25 it will be changed into the
date time data type that is 2011 10 25
and the uh time as well and similarly
you can use the convert function to
change a number or a string value into
year type as well so let's say I'm
taking a value 22 and I want to change
this uh string value into your data type
so the following query would be select
convert 22 as EO
so as you can see the output the value
of the string value that we have taken
as 22 has been now converted into 2022
which is in the format of er data type
now similarly you can convert a string
value into the time as well so let's say
I'm taking a value like let's say 0 9 17
26.
and I'm specifying the data type as time
so let us see the output for this as
well
so as you can see the string value that
we have taken as 0 9 1 7 2 6 which is
basically a number and we want to
convert that number into time data type
so it will display the value as 9 17 26
which is in the format of harsh minutes
and seconds
and that brings us to the end of today's
session guys that was all about the
MySQL conversion functions we have
studied and understood what convert and
cast function does how exactly it works
its parameters with some examples now
you can try converting the value in
every valid data type using these two
functions that is convert and cast
so I hope you found this tutorial
helpful and informative
what is vo and SQL a database view in
SQL is like having virtual tables
containing a single query and its result
the result is usually a virtual table
with rows and columns just like the
actual table in a database we can either
pass a query to store all the rows and
Columns of a table or only a part of it
now the most significant advantage of a
view in SQL is that it stores the query
and hence we don't have to write it
again and again from scratch now but
then then a question arises why not use
the stored procedure instead even a
stored procedure can hold a query and
execute whenever called however the
advantage with view is that they are
easier and more straightforward compared
to procedures while procedures can have
multiple statements with them views can
have only one also viewers do not accept
any parameters as in case with the
stored procedure now SQL views can be
considered as one of the database
objects which is created over an SQL
query it's represents the data returned
by an SQL query so a view does not
actually store the data in the tables
but every time we call a view in the
database it it Returns the result set of
the query in which it is defined so in a
nutshell we can say that a view is
similar to that of a relational database
table which can be treated as a virtual
table and it is just a mere
representative of an underlying SQL
query it always fetches the data from
base table that are used to create The
View using the view creation query let
us now understand the syntax the views
in SQL are created with the create view
syntax and creating viewers in SQL is
very simple following is the basic
syntax to create a view in SQL and it is
followed as create view view name as
select column 1 column 2 up to so on
column n from table 1 table to table n
where condition now to see the data in
the view we can query The View using the
following select statement now create
view is used at the start of the code to
initiate the view and then select is
used to decide which columns to pick
from the tables now table one table up
to so on table and denotes the names of
the table however you can work on a
single table as well now where is used
to define the condition which is used to
select only a particular number of rows
now another significant advantage of
views is that it allow certain
operations like insert update delete
just like you perform in a normal SQL
table
now other than this we have other
operations which can be performed using
the view now view is used to filter
records using where Clause now we know
that there is a lot of chunks of data in
our database and if we want only a part
of it we can filter the data using the
where plots similarly we can select
columns from a single table as per our
need and in the same way we can use the
group by Clause to select only a
particular or a summarized result of a
resultant set and finally we can also
select columns from multiple tables
using the join condition as well so now
that we've understood what exactly views
are let us jump into MySQL workbench for
execution part if getting your learning
started is half the battle what if you
could do that for free visit skill up by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more
so as you can see MySQL Workman just
started and before we proceed into the
execution part and see how to create a
view in SQL using various examples let
us first quickly understand why we use
in SQL so that will have a clear picture
uh before we get into the execution part
now there are various reasons for using
Vios and SQL the first one is majorly
because of security reasons
right now views provide security to the
data acting as a security mechanism and
Views can actually enhance security by
restricting data access to users for
instance we can limit a user from
accessing the actual table that contains
sensitive data but provide access to the
view that has only insensitive data
let's take an example to understand this
now in a company there is an employee HR
and a manager who might be working on a
same database table to fetch some
information now because they are from
different departments there must be some
data that might be relevant to HR but it
might be relevant to the manager and in
other case that data might be relevant
to manager but it might be irrelevant to
the employee so in that case there
should be a security mechanism that
would hide irrelevant information of the
table from certain Usage Now views
allows us to hide or show some date of
table depending on the requirement and
security with the help of condition
means we can hide some data for a
particular person now the second reason
is because of
to reduce the complexity now views are
introduced or whatever actually
introduced to reduce the complexity of
the multiple tables and deliver data in
a simple manner views hide the
complexity of the data in the database
as they join and simplify multiple
tables into a single virtual table which
is easier for a user to understand
and finally because of consistency
reasons now viewers also maintain the
data Integrity as it represents a
consistent and accurate data from the
database you can easily make changes to
the Views according to the user
requirement and the effect of the same
will be seen quickly in a quick manner
so now that we've understood why we use
views in SQL let us just quickly uh go
get into the execution part now now we
can easily create a view in SQL from a
single table or even multiple tables
using the create view of statement now
but before we create a view we'll create
a table named customers that we will use
throughout this session now so let us
just create a table first which is a
customer table and the syntax is create
table customer and in the customer table
I am going to create various columns or
Fields such as customer ID customer name
age address and I'm giving customer ID
as a primary key because it uniquely
identifies each and every record in the
table so let us just execute the
statement and when see the output so our
query has been successfully executed so
let me just use the select statement to
display the result
so let's start from
right so our table has been created and
the fields our customer ID customer name
is and address are being displayed now
let us quickly insert uh some values
into the in this table now I'll use the
insert statement for that insert into
table name which is customer
values
and within the brackets now customer ID
let us take as 1.1
name let us take as Kiran
and age I'm taking as 25
and address I'm taking is Hyderabad
right so let us execute this statement
and we'll see the output so our query
has been successfully executed and the
information has been inserted into our
table
so as you can see the details of Kiran
has been successfully executed and
displayed in our table now similarly
I'll insert some more records into the
table so let me just copy this insert
statement
so let us change the values here one or
two one not three one not four and one
not five and name also let us change
I'm taking another customer name as
Priya
kushal
web half
and let's say guys
and let us change their age as well I'm
taking as 26
24 28
and 23.
now you can change their address as well
so I'm taking
the address of Priya as Bangalore for
kushal I'm taking us
Mumbai
let us just remain
Hyderabad for viber itself and let us
take as Chennai for Gayatri
so let us just execute the statement and
we'll see the output
so our query has been successfully
executed let me just display the values
huh
so as you can see a total of five
records have been inserted into our
table now we can proceed uh into
creating a view for our table customer
now to begin with I will create a simple
view from our customer table which is an
existing table which we have created
just now so the following syntax would
be create view which is the keyword we
use uh you can give any name to your
view let's say uh customer View
as
select the columns that you want to
display in your resultant view table
which is a virtual table right so I want
to display all the fields in my
resultant view table so I'll use the
select star operator select star from
customer
so let us execute the statement and
we'll see the output so our query has
been successfully executed and now when
you refresh the uh schema section you
can see in views you can find a new one
which is created as a customer view so
let me just uh display the results in
the view for that I'll use the select
query again select star
from
customer View
so as you can see the exact details of
the customers that we have already
inserted in our previous table customers
has been inserted in the customer view
as well
so that means in this way this view will
store all the columns that were uh in
the customer table and it will simply
copy paste all the records from customer
table into the customer view which you
have created now
now similarly you can also uh Create A
View From the existing table as well so
for that let us take an example let's
say if I want to create a view of
projects table here so let me just
display the records from the projects
table
and we'll see the output
so as you can see the project table has
various Fields such as project ID
employee ID project name project manager
now let's say I I've had a new
requirement wherein uh there is a new
employee who is joining as a fresher
into the company and as a manager I want
to uh show the details of all the
project names uh that the company is
currently working on now I want to hide
the employee ID details because I don't
want the fresher to have exact idea on
which project the current employees are
working so for that I'll create a view a
simple view here which will basically
give all access to the fresher or the
the employee host recently joined he can
only view the project name and project
manager's name that's it so let me just
create a view here create View
let us take the view name as project
view again
as
select the columns now I'll just select
the project ID
the project name
and the project manager's name here
click manages from the table that is
projects
so let us execute this statement and
we'll see the output
so our query has been successfully
executed now when you refresh this again
you can see another view is formed in
the views section which is the project
view so let me just display the records
that are present in this view I'll use
the select statement again select start
from
projects View
so as you can see now only the project
ID the project name and the name of the
project manager are being displayed
without displaying the employee IDs in
this view table so it will basically
encapsulate or hide The Unwanted details
for the new employee so that he can only
view the project name and the project
manager's name itself that's it right so
that brings us to the next segment
wherein we'll understand how to perform
various operations in a view and SQL
that is how to insert update and delete
recalls in a view
now just like actual tables we can
easily insert update and delete rows in
a view that is not allowed in store
procedures now firstly let us discuss
how to insert a row in a view for an
inserting a row in a view we'll use the
project view as an example that we have
created earlier now the view already had
let's say I think a 10 rows and we will
insert another row using the insert into
command so the following syntax is
insert
into
name of the view that is Project views
project View
values
and inside that let's say I'm taking a
project ID as one one two zero comma
project name let us say artificial
neural network
comma and let us say the project manager
name is Akash
foreign
so let us execute the statement and
we'll see the output
so our query has been successfully
executed so let me just use the select
statement again to display the records
so as you can see there's a new record
with the project id1120 and the project
name is artificial neural networks and
the project manager name is Akash so as
you can see in the output in this way we
can create another row by inserting in
the view which confirms that the insert
statement has been successfully executed
right so next let us discuss how to
update
a record in a view now like just like
inserting we can also update a row in a
view if you notice the previous example
uh we have inserted a new row that is
with the project ID as one one two zero
let us update uh one of the record in
this
let's say if I want to update the
project details uh of blockchain
Technology as something else I'll use
the update statement here
so the Syntax for the update would be
update mention the view name that is
Project View
set
uh now since we are changing the project
name I'll mention the field project name
set project name equals to now let's say
if I want to change the project ID
110 as let's say SEO optimization
or let's say SEO Analytics
where
project ID
equals to 1110
right so let us execute this statement
and we'll see the output
so our query has been successfully
executed so let me run the select
statement again to display the records
so as you can clearly see that the
project ID which was 1110 which was
earlier blockchain technology has been
changed into SEO Analytics
so the updated uh the version of the
column name which was blockchain
technology uh has been changed into SEO
analytics successfully thus it is
confirmed that the update statement has
been executed successfully as well now
finally let us see how to delete a
record in a view now just like how we
inserted an updated a row we can also
delete a row using the delete statement
for example we will delete the row which
is having project ID let's say 810 which
is Project name as diabetic retinopathy
and the project manager name is Harsh so
let me uh just delete this record so
I'll use the delete statement here
select from Project View
where is the condition we use here
where project ID
equals to 810
right so let me just execute this again
so our query has been executed
successfully let me just display the
records so as you can see the record the
project ID which is having 810 which is
one of the record in this table has been
successfully uh deleted so in this way
you can perform various such operations
which we actually generally perform in
the normal SQL tables you can similarly
perform them in SQL views as well now
for some reasons if you want to delete
the whole view that is the view that we
have already created now for some
reasons if you want to delete it you can
simply use the drop command here which
will completely delete the view that you
have created so the query would be drop
mention the view name which is Project
View
right so let us just execute this
so our query has been successfully
executed so let me just uh use the
select statement to display the records
select star from
lectures project View
so let us execute this now when you
execute this it will simply say that
project view does not exist which means
that our view which we have created has
been successfully deleted from the
database and the schema as well and that
brings us to the end of today's session
guys I hope you understood how to create
a view in SQL now you might have a doubt
that when to use uh views in SQL now
since views have both advantages and
disadvantages the question arises when
to use them right now for instance if
you remove an attribute or if you
actually delete a table it can impact
the functionality of a view as well just
like in a related table for instance if
a view is using the email column of a
table and you drop that column or even a
single data of it that is in use by the
view the output of the view will be
impacted now the short answer to when to
use uh views in SQL is when you want to
write complex select queries that
require Gathering data from multiple
tables in that case you can use SQL
views SQL as a standard language for
relational database systems all the
relational database systems like MySQL
Ms access Oracle cybase info mix and
other nosql psql languages use SQL as
their standard database languages SQL
comes with a dozen of advantages like it
allows you to create and drop databases
and tables set permissions on tables
procedures and Views and so much more
SQL is easy to learn as the statements
comprise of descriptive English words
and sentences and are not case sensitive
we can create and interact with database
using SQL in an efficient and an easy
way the benefit with SQL is that we
don't have to specify how to get the
data from the database rather we simply
specify what is to be retrieved and SQL
does the rest also called a query
language said SQL can do much more
besides querying as we discussed earlier
it provides statements for defining the
structure of the data manipulating data
declaring constraints and retrieving
data from the database depending on
various conditions and our requirements
now the working of SQL is also very
simple
a typical SQL process takes place with
the help of a database server and a SQL
now if you look at the diagram we have a
end user we have a database server SQL
engine database and a record now to
understand how SQL works let us take an
example suppose John is an HR Manager
working in an organization he wants
information of all the employees who
have joined last year for that John
writes an SQL query in his laptop to
retrieve the data now in order to
execute the query it must interact with
relational dbms and the request should
be a valid query before the SQL engine
can process it the SQL engine then
writes to and retrieves data from a
database server now to retrieve the data
the query processor is the SQL engine
accepts and executes SQL commands from
the data Observer to
don't worry to an application server now
this application server processes the
SQL request and sends it to a web server
where the user can access the
information via SQL database table
now if the required data is found in the
tables the database server sends the
information back to the user in this way
John can retrieve the information from
the database using SQL so that was all
about SQL and how does it work let us
now move to the next question
what are the messages of SQL or you
might be asked in another way like why
we use SQL SQL is responsible for
maintaining the relational data and thus
shows present in the database it is used
to query and manipulate data stored in
the regulational databases some of the
features sqlr it is used to execute
queries against a database it retrieves
the data from the database we can
perform various operations like ins
update and delete and many other
operations on SQL database tables as
well and it can also perform complex
operations on the database using various
Clauses operators and functions
then a database is an organized
collection of structure information or
data typically stored electronically in
a computer system a database is usually
covered by these management which is
dbms together the data and the PMS along
with applications that are associated
with them are referred to as a database
system often shorted with just database
now data with the most common types of
database in operation today is typically
modeled in rows and columns in a series
of tables to make processing and data
querying efficient the data can then be
easily accessed managed modified updated
and organized in this databases now most
databases use SQL for ring queries and
to retrieve that information from the
databases now some popular SL databases
are post to SQL MySQL Oracle Microsoft
SQL server mongodb and others well
moving ahead
the next question is what do you
understand by tables and Fields in a
database a table is a set of data that
are organized in a model with columns
and rows columns can be categorized as a
vertical and rows are horizontal Fields
a table has specified number of columns
called Fields but can have any number of
rows which is called a record now if you
take an example of a table that has been
here the salary is a field in the
similar way employee ID employee name
job and Department also Commander the
field now the vertical rows are
categorized as columns and we have five
different columns which are employee ID
employee job department and salary and
the horizontal rows are categorized as
rows or Tuple which is basically the
information that we put in inward
database tables
right the next question is mention
different types of commands used in SQL
SQL commands are instructions for
communicating with the database and are
used to carry out specific tasks work
and functions on database data now SQL
commands are further categorized into
four different types the first one is
data definition language or ddl ddl
helps a user to define the database
structure or schemas that are capable of
creating delete deleting and modifying
data
create drop alter truncate are some
examples of ddl commands or statements
we have data manipulation language or
DML DML is used to modify or manipulate
data present in the database tables
insert update select and delete are some
SQL commands that come under DML next we
have data control language or DCL DCL is
used to control access to the data
stored in the database by granting and
revoking permission to the user and
finally we have transaction control
language PCL
it is used for managing and controlling
the transactions in a database to
maintain consistency commit and roll
back commands come under TCL we also
have data query language additionally
which is used to retrieve the data from
the database select commands lets the
user query the database to fetch data
from details
the next question is what are the
statements used under DML commands now
this might be a follow-up question for
the previous question that we have
discussed which is types of SQL commands
interviewer wants to know whether really
understood the statements that you have
covered under the DML fans and
understood them in a very good way now
for that you have to be familiar with
all the DML commands so you might ask
any one of these commands in your
interview as well so there are four
different types of statements used under
DML commands the first one is Select
this command is used to fetch data from
a database table next we have insert
this command allows inserting data into
the tiller database that is if you want
to enter a new record into our holiday
sync table you can use the insert
command next we have the update this
command allows modifying a data in the
table now for some reasons if you want
to change the data that is present in
your table you can use the update
command and finally we have the delete
this command allows deleting specific
rows or all the rows from a table
moving ahead the next question is what
is difference between delete and
truncate
difference between delete and trunk
command is the most common part of an
interview question and is asked in
various interviews by the recruiters
they are mainly used to delete the data
from the database but eventually they
have some differences between them as
well now the first difference is the
delete command is used to delete a
specified amount of rows that is you can
delete either a single row or more than
one row whereas the truncate command is
used to delete all the rows at a time
from a table
delete is a DML command which is a data
manipulation language whereas the
truncate comes under the ddl which is
the data definition language Now using
delete there may be a where clause in
the delete command in order to show the
records whereas in truncate there is no
where clause in the truncate command
now in delete command the changes can be
rolled back that is if you have deleted
a particular of rows you can use the
rollback statement to bring back those
requests that you have deleted where in
case of truncate once the changes are
made they cannot be rolled back now
delete is slower than truncate whereas
the truncate is faster than delete now
that's because uh this delete command is
very so because it maintains the
transaction loss whereas the truncate
command is first because it deletes
entire data at a time without
maintaining any transaction loss as in
the same way the delete statement
occupies more transaction space than the
truncate because it maintains a lock for
each deleted row whereas the truncate
statement occupies less transaction
space because it means a transaction log
for the entire data page instead of each
row so those are the main differences
between delete and truncate
Right Moving ahead the next question is
what are the constraints in SQL
constraints are a set of rules imposed
on the tables additional databases
constraints help in maintaining the data
accuracy integracy integrity and
reliability of a database constraints
can be imposed at the time of creation
of the table or after its creation as
well
now constraints can be a column level or
table level column level constraints
applied to a column and the table level
constraints are applied to the whole
table now the following constraints are
com which are commonly used in SQL are
the first one is unique constraint is
specified with a column tells that the
all values in a column must be unique
that is the values in any row of a
column must not be repeated next we have
primary key a primary key is a field
which can uniquely identify each row in
a table and is constant is used to
specify a field in a table as a primary
key next we have foreign key a funky is
a fee is a field which can be uniquely
identified each row in other table and
this constraint is used to specify a
field as a foreign key next we have the
default constraint this constraint
specifies a default value for the column
when no value specified by the user next
we have the check constraint the check
constraint helps to vibrate the values
of column to meet a particular condition
that is it helps to ensure that the
value stored in the column makes a
specified condition and finally we have
the not null constraint this constraint
basically tells that we cannot store a
null value in a column that is if a
column is specified as not null then
will not be able to store null value in
this particular column anymore and you
have to give a value to it
so that was all about constraints in SQL
right the next question is what do you
understand by the term clause and
explain various Clauses in SQL
now classes are built-in functions
available to the user in SQL with the
help of Clauses we can deal with data
easily stored in the table SQL Clause
helps to limit the result set by
providing a condition to the query and
helps to filter records from the entire
set of Records now we have various
Clauses in SQL some of them are the
first one is where Clause where Clause
is used to filter the records in the
database order by Clause order by Clause
is used to sort the data either in
ascending or descending order using the
ASC and the desc keywords in the SQL
quiz and next we have the group by
Clause Group by Clause is used to group
entries with identical data and may be
used with aggregation methods to obtain
summarize database result this can be
used when you are performing aggregate
operations for the database tables next
we have having having is similar to that
of where Clause but it filters the
records or the rows where aggregate
values meets the specified conditions
only
next we have the limit Clause limit
Clause is used to specify only a certain
number of results in the query of a
resultant set table
that is if you want to specify or
retrieve only a particular number of
words let's say the pub 50 or the first
50 records in a table in that case you
can use the limit which will specify
only a limited number of records and
finally we have the distinct clause
which will basically delete all the rows
having duplicate values that means if in
your database table if any record has
been repeated multiple times then the
distinct Clause is used to discard all
those rows
moving ahead the next question is what
are different types of operators used in
SQ
operators are the foundation of any
programming language be it SQL or any
other programming language like CC plus
plus Java and other programming
languages now we can Define operators as
a symbols that help us to perform
specific mathematical and logical
computations on our SQL databases tables
now in SQL we have multiple types of
operators available which will be
discussing shortly now we use SQL
operators to specify conditions and
statements satisfying a query of a
desired data input now the first type of
operator is basically the arithmetic
operators which are used to perform the
today operations like addition
subtraction multiplication division and
reminder and modulus operations next we
have the bitwise operators and in
bitwise operators we have bitwise and
bitwise or bitwise xor Etc
next we have comparison operators as a
word suggest we use this operator to
compare the values in our SQL database
table equal to not equal to greater than
not greater than less than not less than
not equal to Etc are some examples of
comparison operators next we have
compound operators which are similar to
that of automatic operators but we
examples such as R equals multiply
equals subtract equals divide equals and
modulo equals next we have the logical
operators
in SQL The Logical operators are used
for filtering the data and getting
precise results based on a given
condition the SQL logical operator are
also used to combine multiple conditions
these operators can be combined to test
for multiple conditions in a select
insert update or delete statements
examples of logical operators are all
and between not exists or in like and is
null and finally we have string
operators and some examples of string
operators are swing concatenations
wildcard character matches and Etc
the next question is name the operator
which is used for pattern matching in
SQL the SQL like operator is a command
that is used for pattern matching that
determines whether a specific character
string matches a pattern lycorator is
frequently used in a where Clause to
look for a specific pattern in a column
now the SQL pattern matching provides
for pattern searching data if you have
no clue as to what the word should be
that is present in your database table
now this kind of SQL query uses wild
cards to match a string pattern rather
than writing the exact word the like
operator is used in conjunction with SQL
wire cuts to fetch the required
information using the percentage Wildcat
symbol to perform a simple search which
basically matches 0 or more one
character of any type and can be used to
define wildcards both before and after
the pattern search in our database table
and similarly we have the underscore
wildcard
which matches exactly one character
rather than multiple colors of any type
it can be used in conjunction with the
underscore as well as the percentage
wild card as well
so in this way the SQL like operator is
the one which is used for pattern
matching in SQL
moving ahead the next question is what
is the difference between SQL and MySQL
this is one of the most frequently Asked
question in your interviews and the
interviewer expects whether you're
familiar on the differences between the
SQL and MySQL so SQL is basically a
programming language which has a
particular syntax in English words and
Etc well as MySQL it is an rdbms which
is a relational database management
system SQL is used for querying
relational database system whereas MySQL
is used to modify and delete data in the
database in an organized way SQL though
considered as a language we have SQL
Server which is a light licensed product
of Microsoft MySQL is an open source
platform managed by Oracle Corporation
SQL provides adequate production to SQL
servers against Intruders whereas
mysqing and open source platform
security cannot be reliable and can be
at risk sometimes and finally SQL
doesn't support any connectors whereas
MySQL support connectors such as
workbench tools and many other
substitutes to build database
Etc
next what is the difference what is the
main difference between where and having
clause now where Clause is used to
filter the records from the table based
on the specified condition whereas
having Clause is used to filter records
from the group based on a specified
condition where Clause can be used
without the group by Clause whereas the
having Clause cannot be used without
using the group by Clause bear Clause
implements in a row operation whereas
the having Clause implements in column
operations
weight loss cannot contain aggregated
functions whereas having plots can
contain aggregate functions and finally
where Clause can be used with select
update delete statements and on the
other hand having plus can only be used
with this select statement so these were
the some main differences between where
and having clause in s given
now the next question is what are keys
in SQL and why do we use them the SQL
case is an attribute or set of
attributes which helps you to identify a
row in a table may also help in
establishing a relation between multiple
tables in the databases as well now the
reason why we use SQL keys are Keys
identify each record separately and
uniquely now if you are working on a
large data sets you might want to
specify a different key to each column
because you want to uniquely identify
each and every record using certain
columns right so in this in that case
you have to use Keys now Keys also
allows the user to establish and
identify a relationship between tables
and finally it accesses or manages the
store data quickly and
Right Moving ahead the next question is
mention different types of cases used in
SQL now this is again another follow-up
question to the SQL Keys which I've
discussed earlier and the interviewer or
the recruiter might want to know whether
you have the knowledge of period various
different types of keys that are used in
SQL now there are primarily for
different types of cases to use in SQL
the first one is basically the primary
key the primary key in SQL is a single a
group of fields of columns that can
uniquely identify a row in a table now
let's say if you're working on an
employee table so in that case ID as a
primary key because it uniquely
identifies each and every record or the
details of an employer in that table
next we have the Super Key a Super Key
is basically a combination of all
possible attributes which can uniquely
identify the rows in a table
next we have the candidate key candidate
key can be identified or defined as a
set of one or more columns that can
identify or record a tuple uniquely in
the email so along with the primary key
there may be some other columns or
Fields where you can easily identify a
unique manner so in that case you will
use the candidate key now for example
let's say other card pan card are some
examples of candidate as they also work
in a similar fashion to that of primary
key which uniquely identifies the
records of those employees in the table
and finally we have foreign key a
foreign key is a set of attributes in a
table that refers to the primary key of
an other table
so these were the different types of
keys that are used in SQ
right the next question is what's the
difference between car and Barca data
type now speaking of our car it is a
fixed length character string data type
whereas or variable character is a
variable and character string data type
CAD data type can be awesome multiple
bytes whereas the Barca can accept
characteristics up to 255 bytes
data type can be used when the character
length is known whereas wirecap data
type is used when the character left is
not known next the car is used with when
the character length of the data is same
whereas the worker is used when the
character length of the data is variable
now carries considered a static data
type and this game and is given static
memory allocation because it only uh
stores the character values whereas the
worker is considered as a dynamic data
type and is given dynamic memory
allocation because it has various string
like characters and variables to be
taught in the tables so that were the
main differences between the car and
back at data types
moving ahead the next question is what
are aggregate functions in SQL an
aggregate function SQL performs
calculation on multiple values and
returns a single value it allows the
user to perform complex calculation on a
service to return a single scalar value
we often use this aggregate functions
with a group by and having Clauses of
the select statement now SQL aggregate
functions are further classified into
five types the first one is Count next
one is Sun next we have average and then
we have minimum and finally we have
maximum
foreign
next question is write an SQL query to
find second salary from employee table
now other than some different uh
definitions and other theoretical
questions you might be asked to write
some basic SQL queries during your
interviews now we all know to find the
highest salary in employee the following
query is Select ID employee name Max
salary from employee basically we are
selecting ID employee name as the
columns in our resultant set and we are
using the aggregate function Max to the
salary field which will basically
retrieve the maximum salary of that
employee present in that employee table
right now this is clear and it's a piece
of cake to do right now to find the
second highest salary in employee the
following query would be select ID
employee name maximum salary from
employee where salary is lesson now we
have to use a sub query here which is
Select maximum salary from employee now
what is query basically does is it
basically processes the inner query
which is Select Max salary from employee
now once it executes this now the outer
query executed which is it will display
the ID employee name maximum salary of
the employee whose salary is less than
the maximum salary which you have
calculated earlier so in this way you
can find the second highest salary in
employee using in a sub query
now the next question is what are
software is in SQL and why we use them
which is obvious a follow-up query that
we have discussed earlier a sub query is
basically a type of query which is
written inside another query a sub query
becomes a part of larger query and a sub
queries also called as inner query or a
nested query a sub query provides data
to the main query also called parent
query or the outer query a sub query is
basically a select statement that is
embedded in a clause of another SQL
statement and the inner queries executed
once before its parent or outer query so
that the results of an inner query can
be passed to the artery now what I mean
is like let's say let's take an example
here which we have is Select name listed
price REM orders where Lister prices
greater than select average listed price
from orders now we have a sub query
which is Select average listed price
from orders which is basically an inner
query or the nested query now first this
part of the query gets executed where it
will select the average price of the
listed prices in the orders table and
finally it will display the records of
all those items and it's listed primary
orders which is greater than the average
of the listed prices which is basically
the inner query so in the this way we
can use the sub queries to perform
complex operations on our table
databases
like moving ahead
what are joints in SQL and mention it
types the SQL join Claus is used to
combine records or rows from two or more
tables in a SQL database based on a
related column between one or two tables
SQL joints are mostly used when a user
is trying to fetch data from multiple
tables join keyword merges two or more
tables and creates a temporary resultant
set of the merged tables we can join the
table using a select statement and a
join condition and the query is followed
as select table one dot column one comma
table element dot column two comma table
2 Dot column comma table 2 dot call to
and so on from table 1 join condition
which is basically the type of join you
want to apply to your SQL query it it
may be in a in a join out a joint left
Joiner outer join on table two on
provide the condition on which you want
to join the tables that is table one dot
column is equals to table two dot column
so in this way you can use the joints in
SQL as well
now moving ahead the next question is
what are joints in sqlr mentions types
now we have basically there are four
different types of joints in SQL which
is the first one is inner join the inner
join basically returns records that have
matching values in both the tables that
is if you consider tables and if you
want to get the common values that are
present in both the tables in that case
you will use the image next we have the
outer join or full outer join which
basically returns all the records when
there is a match to either left or right
table now option basically what it does
is no matter uh if it has any matching
values or not it will display all that
it's from both the tables that is table
1 and table two
next we have the left joint left Joy
left outer joint returns all levels from
the left table and only the matching
records from the right table now left
chain is is used or even if you want to
display the records from the first table
and only the matching values that are
present in the second table so in that
case you can use the left outer join and
finally we have the right outer join or
right outer join which basically returns
all the records from right table and
only the matching records from the from
the left table so in this way you can
use different types of joints in your
SQL series as well
right the next question is write an SQL
query to find names of all the employees
that begins with a I think this is a
simple query and you know to display the
details of all the employees whose name
begins with a we need to type this
following query which is used with the
like operator and the queries follow us
select star from employee where e-name
which is based I am taking as the name
like a percentage so this will basically
display the records of all those
employees whose name starts with a and
similarly you might be asked to display
the names of all the employees that ends
with a and the following queries are
similar to that of the first one we have
discussed and the only difference is you
have to change the percentage sign and
the query is followed as select star
from employee where e-name like now
instead of putting the character a in
the first we have to place the
percentage while we cut first and then
the a character which basically display
all the records of employees whose name
might be starting with any character but
it should end with a
moving ahead the next question is write
an SQL query to return even an odd
number records from a table
now to find and return the records with
the odd or even values we need to check
the reminder when we divide the column
value by 2. now when the reminder is 0
that's an in number otherwise that's an
odd number now if you take an example
here in order to play even number of
Records we are using the modulus
operator here and the queries followed
as Select Staff from table where ID
modulus 2 is equals to 0. now if take a
employee table let's say they're having
employee ID starting from 100 now 100
modulus 2 is basically equals to zero it
basically Returns the even number
records there and similarly all the
employees uh having their ID even
numbers that is 100 100 and 204 106 and
so on and all those requests will be
displayed in the resistance set and
similarly in order to display odd number
records we use the following query
select star from table where ID modulus
2 not equal to zero now if you take the
employee ID as one not one when you
perform the operation one not one
modulus to do you have the reminder as
one which basically not equals zero and
it is a number record so employee is
having employee IDs like one or one one
or three one or five and and so on in
odd numbered places this will basically
return the request so in this way you
can return even an odd number records
from the table using the modulus
operator
moving ahead the next question is
explain what is an alias in SQL and why
we use it alias in SQL is basically a
temporary name that is given to a table
or column while writing a query this is
usually done in the column or table
names are long giving aliases makes the
table or column name more readable and
is also preferred when there are lot of
queries written for a table the error is
based in SQL is a temporary change and
only exists to till the duration of that
not to give an alias name for a query is
followed as select column name as a
layer's name from table name for example
I have the column name as employee name
and I just want to give the Alias as e n
so in this way I'm using the Alias name
for the column name as well and
similarly fun to give a layers
select common column 2 from table name
as early as name so just like uh in a
way is given the Alias name for your
columns you can similarly the Alias name
for your table as well
foreign
ahead how to create a new table from an
exit table now a copy of table can be
created from an existing table using the
combination of create and select
statements using these two statements we
can either select all the columns or
only a specific columns from an existing
table as a result the note table will be
replaced all the values of the exit
table and the web Clause can also be
used as an optional statement to select
the specific columns from the table and
the syntax is followed as create table
new table name one and select mention
all the columns that you want to
retrieve from the existing table which
is from existing table one and you can
also specify condition using the
variables as well
and finally the question is what are the
applications of SQL in real life
now apple is used in various fields in
nowadays for example SQL is used in
banking it is used in education it is
used in finance it is used in healthcare
it is used in e-commerce sector is used
in traveling sector it is used in
manufacturing sector as well now talking
about banking SQL is one of the major
components of the banking sectors like
Bank stored the account detail customers
and the transactions that are done on a
daily basis in databases now in
education uh schools and universities
use SQL and databases to store and
retrieve information about their
students faculty and staff SQL is also
used in finance where
regularly managing the assets Revenue
details shares of the companies as well
for execution and retrieval of data
plays an important role for all the
businesses and finance uh segments to
make strategies and derive insights from
it SQL is also used rapidly and
extensively in healthcare sector as well
where hospitals and other medical
centers use SQL to store the details of
their patients without any hassle it
also helps in maintaining all the
documents and the bills of the patients
and similarly in manufacturing as all
manufacturing sector also we have a lot
of applications of SQL as well to track
the shipments extra
now in travel aspects of uh also we use
the SQL wherein the details of the
customers who are traveling can also be
uh used with the help of SQL
and finally SQL is also used in
e-commerce like we have uh Amazon which
is one of the probably the one of the
biggest e-commerce companies in the
world which is used to locate or heavily
rely on SQL to make better decisions and
provide Solutions and service to its
customers so these were some of the
applications of SQL in real life
and with that we have come to the end of
today's session guys those were some of
the basic SQL interview questions that
are being asked done nowadays now the
level of the interview questions
entirely depend on the position you are
applying for it could be a simple SQL
question or a query for analyst role or
it could be a more complex SQL interview
questions and data modeling things for
data engineering roles now in this
tutorial we have only discussed some of
the basic uh questions or basic
interview questions on SQL uh stay tuned
for more uh videos wherein we'll discuss
a more of a further bit of questions
like intermediate as well as the
advanced questions that we'll be
covering in our upcoming videos and that
brings us to the end of today's session
guys that was all about SQL data
analysis I hope you understood how to
use SQL for data analysis on real-time
data sets thank you for watching the
video guys I hope you found this
tutorial informative and helpful if you
did make sure to leave us a like and
share it with your friends and
colleagues if you have any further
queries regarding any of the topics
covered in today's session let us know
in the comment section below and a team
of experts will be more than happy to
help resolve all your queries at the
earliest until next time stay safe and
keep learning
thank you
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here